at the end of time
[Music]
13 o'clock
well hey everybody what's going on it's
Wednesday Ben had a great idea and I
wish that I would have thought of this
says I wonder if they'll leave the timer
running then claim they were kidnapped
before they could come on the stream I
was like well [__] we can't do it now
because you said but that would have
been really funny yeah if we'd come on
like five minutes late and be like you
guys you guys
[__] taking some rope off or some
[__] like that or something come here
and they got us
see that's the thing I mean this show
I mean I found some like cases of like a
whole bunch of different cases like you
know just kind of like brief outlines of
each case and [__] like that and I will
note that obviously like really getting
kidnapped is not funny but most of these
people like I said claimed they were
kidnapped for really dumb reasons a
couple of them it's just kind of like
because they were probably mentally ill
I imagine but the other ones
it just seemed like they had really
really stupid reasons so in that sense
it's like actually kind of funny but the
thing about it I was just reading an
article
like right before the show started
and they're talking about
um in response to the very famous case
which just happened like at the end of
July in Alabama the Carly Russell case
which we'll get into in a little bit but
um because of that I think it's like
lawmakers in Alabama are thinking oh
maybe we should make it a felony
like to falsely report that you've been
kidnapped or falsely reported kidnapping
because some people have reported like
their kids kidnapped and stuff like that
and I was kind of like well okay while
that seems on its face to be like an
okay idea because it would maybe
discourage people from doing it
um one it's really not that common for
people to do it so it just seems like
they're trying to like react to a
problem that doesn't exist in a great
degree and two it seems like it might
have the unintended effect of
people that really get kidnapped like
not reporting it right because they're
afraid that they're gonna get in trouble
right so I don't think it's the
brightest idea right I mean honestly a
lot of states don't even really have
specific laws
um you know making it illegal and I'm
not saying like oh it's okay to do it or
anything because they can't get you on
other things a lot of states will
actually just kind of give you like
filing a false report [__] like that and
a lot of them will also like take you to
court and make you pay
pay back like reparations and stuff like
that like for all of the restitution
yeah recitation restitution for like all
of the time that they wasted like
looking for your dumb ass like when you
were just holed up with your yeah lover
somewhere like in a motel and you didn't
want to get in trouble you know what I
mean you just said oh my God I totally
got kidnapped yeah so I don't know so so
yeah so I was reading the article about
it and I was just kind of like I see
what they're getting at but it just
seems like that's gonna blow up in their
faces there never would have been a
Travis Walton case
yeah we yeah we did a show about that
dude didn't we yeah he got abducted by
aliens though that's kind of a
difference
charged him
yeah that's the thing I don't know like
how many states actually have laws
against yeah reporting like like that
specific thing a lot I mean I think all
states have a thing about like filing a
false report obviously and I think that
some states though that's like the only
thing they can probably get here Travis
Walton might have been full of [__] too
um I mean there was that was a good case
but
I'm good yeah it's like you never know
honestly yeah I mean I that's the thing
do I really think that he was abducted
by aliens no of course not
but it's just kind of like I I'm not
really entirely sure like what happened
there it's what his friend said and his
friends weren't really all that closely
tied to him some of them
didn't know him very long
they stuck to the story
they did yeah so that's something yeah
but it's not something I thought it was
a UFO yeah
yeah Ben said Is it against the law to
get objected by aliens yeah not yet
uh Tammy said Steven Seagal finally got
Tom's ass yeah Steven Seagal came and
kidnapped yeah it'd be [__] funny he
came to he came to the house and he ate
him yeah that's what happened no we
smuggled him out in his big he snuggles
me out knocks me out and [__] and I wake
up but I'm in this backyard with a pool
he's sitting there on a [__]
I'm gonna have a new kind of Asian
experience
I ain't Asian you're gonna be Asian now
he's over there got big old shish kebabs
he's got a big old [__] oh I got a
big old [__]
[__] table filled with crawfish
yeah
that'd be funny Santa
treadmill yeah
Savage uh Ben said he replaced him with
a clone yeah I mean
I don't know I don't know how I feel
about the Travis Walling case but
like I said I I don't believe that he
was kid if it was he was abducted by
aliens that's for sure but I don't know
what actually did happen I don't know if
they were all in on it or if he was
pranking them or something else weird
happened and you know and they actually
were just reporting what they saw and it
was really weird but it was just
something that it's unlikely yeah very
unlikely that he was but who are we the
[__] say yeah yeah
parts of the [__] government are
saying that they that it's real but you
know we'll see I don't know I I said I
spoke about that earlier on another show
I think it's a distraction
they have any downed craft yeah they
wouldn't tell us about it at all I don't
think
no probably not no
and it wouldn't be the government that
would have it be all their contractors
all their contractors in the [__]
Lockheed Martin or something would have
it Northrop would have it so
and
there'd be no way to get to it
it would have erased the trail
Tammy said Stephen is checking time for
breast cancer yeah he's he's being
helpful it's helpful I don't not feeling
any lumps
Zach said I had what I'm kind of jealous
of your picks
I had a big chest too
look how big my chest is
yeah he still has it it's just
underneath several layers to go yeah
Zach said I had a super Vivid nightmare
once that uh that I was a kid and
someone tried kidnapping me from the
store and I tried screaming but nothing
came out see that kind of shit's really
I never got I mean I've heard like a lot
of stories of
people almost getting kidnapped like his
children and stuff like that I don't
think that ever happened to me I did
have some dude try to like get me to get
in his car but I wasn't like a little
little kid I was like a teenager and I
was just like [__] no
the [__] away from me dudes are trying
to be a pickup artist
uh well no he's probably trying to be a
[__] rapist and murderer probably
you see do you see who he was I don't
remember what he looked like it was a
long time ago because I was just walking
I didn't have a car for a long time so I
had to walk and take the bus everywhere
so every now they get like [__]
creepy ass people yeah yeah
and I wanted to do that too like when I
was remember when I worked at that print
shop that wasn't that long ago yeah like
back in 2013 or whatever it was and I
used to like take walks on my uh lunch
break
and some dude campus like offer me a
ride I'm like no I'm like walking for
exercise I'm like I was staying like way
over here yeah yeah anything else you're
a hooker well no I don't think he
thought I was a hooker he was just
trying to like get me to get in the car
because it was I mean there wasn't like
it's not like a street where hookers
would walk or would walk they do that
anyway I know that but I'm just saying
that it's just kind of like he was just
I saw a hooker [__] Burger King
yeah when I was a [__] remember years
back I told you about it yeah it was I
was uh at uh what do you call it
it's a Starbucks sitting there across
the street near the burger cave across
the street she was walking in between
the two [__] going hey waving at
everybody and she had a [__] Coke
[__] Burger King bag in her hand in a
Coke and that's all she did is just walk
up and down a wave at people because she
was from that homeless and Captain that
used to be there yeah remember that
they're out there and that's not that
area wasn't a place that had hookers
just she was there
trying to get people to pick her up
right but I wasn't doing that I was just
walking like a normal person and like he
was trying to like get me to get in the
car and then I was just like no and then
he got really really mad and he was just
like and I was just like okay what the
[__] ever
freak maybe yeah I went there I didn't
see him yeah it was a little scary
but you know dude some guys just see if
see if a girl just walking down the
street well she's she's looking to get
picked up
I just think that if they've been if
they've been in the cut they're picking
up hookers that's then that you know
that's how they interpret that well it's
not my fault they're morons yeah so it's
just kind of like pissing the world is
how the world is they got some real
idiots out there you know that's what I
mean well like I said that's not my
[__] problem that's your [__]
problem you need to fix that
stop being stupid
yeah Xanax said a guy tried to ask me
for directions when I was five and I
told him I'd ask my dad who was nearby
and the guy sped off yeah I've heard a
lot of stories like that there
definitely are a lot of like creeps out
there trying to like pick up little kids
and whatnot
yeah Camp guy said I knew a gal that
said there was an intruder dude hiding
in her closet when she came back from
the mall she screamed and the dude ran
out of the house yeah I would [__]
[__] my pants well I still kind of every
um every time I go to get in my car no
matter where I am I always look in the
back seat so sister this is a couple
months back I think I said about on the
show woke up in the middle of night
rolled over and looked at the door the
doorway into her bedroom and there was a
dude standing there
and they turned around just left
she froze
yeah he left he came in through the
window
I wonder why why I wonder why he laughed
he went out through the front door
um she thought so sister thought it's
because there was a bunch of pillows
next to her and that maybe in the
darkness it looked like a man laying in
the land next to her
so he thought somebody else I thought
her boyfriend was in there with her yeah
it was like oh no yeah
is cute man she looks like a model
that's well that's the thing like if
that happened to me like even if they
even if the dude left I'd be like well
that dude is probably gonna be back yeah
I told her I told her I said you tell
your sister to move he's gonna I would
move yeah he's gonna come back she
didn't move though she's just kind of an
airhead
jeez
you know he said I would stay there no I
wouldn't I wouldn't either
because she he targeted her he knew
where she lived
yeah that's what I'm saying and he was
probably like oh well I'll come back
tomorrow night maybe the boyfriend won't
be there yep so I'd be like yep he
probably assumed that they'd be waiting
for him next time or something but he
ran out what you saw him
but you don't break into houses at night
the people are asleep in there at night
that's not a burglary
you break in in a day when people are at
work yeah because then you can steal you
still shouldn't get out and then just
get out and no one will see you you do
it in a group so it doesn't look
suspicious yeah vehicle and everything
like they're moving
yeah that's what I mean anybody like
busting your house in the middle of the
night when you're home they're in there
looking for people yeah they're uh
they're up to no good obviously
so uh so yeah
I had that happen where I woke up and
there was a dude standing in my the
doorway in my bedroom but I'm pretty
sure it was um sleep paralysis yeah I
mean I think it was
because I just woke up and he was
standing there and I was just kind of
like
oh look at that
but
I mean I didn't see him leave she said
he was young
so he got did she get a decent look at
him just a young black guy
huh that's all she could remember did
she figure out how he got in just the
day coming no they came with that window
yeah they found the uh the screen
on the ground yeah and he got up got up
on top there's a dumpster on her back
she's in an apartment at the ground
floor of her apartment and there's a
dumpster there he got up on the dumpster
took the screen off threw it down and
[__] just slid the window open
because it was open and he got him hmm
when evidently she was like
Payton she's an artist she was painting
and she'd always have to take the
windows open or when something goes
seriously why don't you shut shut the
curtains man or let people see inside
your apartment she's at the ground floor
people coming in and out right that's
what happened he was coming in and out
of that apartment sorry in there
he knew she was in there yeah he just
thought she didn't he didn't think she
was alone she was though yeah
she's lucky I mean that could have did
his 20s could have gone very very badly
could have gone very badly you guys he
got cold feet I thought somebody was in
there with it yeah might live in the
same complex
or a friend in the complex yeah or
something or yeah something like that
that's because I already got the whole
story I'm piecing it together now I am
I'm a [__] criminologist
you've been there to go see his buddy
and he saw her
came back later for
but then again in and he thought there
was a big dude sleeping next to him with
a bunch of pillows said the lighting
wasn't right and he split ran out the
front door
she called the cops and [__]
but then she says oh you know he was he
you know she she thought oh it was just
a he just tried to rob a place but I was
here oh you know and he left I was going
no that's not what that was no but she's
ignorant you know college student
and I told her I said you tell that you
tell that girl to move he'll be back I
mean I would know it's been about four
months now I guess five months I
remember you telling me yeah he'll be
he'll he'll probably be back and the
thing is is that her boyfriend stayed to
stay the night with her for a couple
nights he didn't come back
but that dude wouldn't be able to
[__] fight that dude off what the
[__] you know he's freaking weak you
know
he's just you know he just thought that
was a big white dude
is that who she was with she was with
the dude I'd [__] blow through seven
of him
foreign
trouble man [__] the size of your man
matters
going to these little [__] I.T
Specialists [__] break them with one
hand
well she was she didn't have a man there
she just had a bunch of pillows and that
was yeah frighten the dude away but
still right she should I mean she should
at least invest in like a [__] real
doll or something that she could like
lay in the bed all the time all right
Dad says we're gonna get you a gun she's
like I don't have a gun in the house
no
so I've tried to tell her
well like I said if that happened to me
I'm pretty sure although I mean I know
that everyone can't just move because a
lot of money so probably listening she
listens to the Rochelle recorded
you know how you know how I felt about
so we talked about it
I I'd have moved her instantly
yeah I mean I the apartment complex I
used to live in before
me and Tom moved in together that was
not the best place either luckily for me
I actually worked nights so and I you
know and I worked nights in Daytona so I
was commuting back and forth a lot and I
would stay like at a friend's house like
over in Daytona so I wasn't home a lot
you know what I mean like especially
like at night because I usually didn't
get home until like three or four in the
morning
and I was usually like still up so it's
not like if somebody broke in I probably
would not have been there
which was good because I was also on the
ground floor and I wasn't happy about
that yeah RAV4 is never good I don't
really like being underground well and
especially because when they have those
little porches with the yeah you know
with the screen and
all that kind of stuff because they can
just like
come in especially if you forget to um
to lock your sliding glass door you know
what I mean like which a lot of people
do I never did because I'm really anal
retentive of like that but you know
um all right so are we gonna start
talking about like I said I basically
just have kind of like a list of
particular cases that I thought were
interesting in one way or another and
they're not like super super detailed or
anything like that I'm just kind of
doing like a panoply of different people
who fake their own kidnappings like I
said even though one of the most famous
ones is Sherry papini
um I'm not talking about her because we
did her we talked about her on um on a
show before like on one of our
disappearances show but she's probably
one of the most famous uh
cases of people that fake their own
kidnappings
but this was actually a good idea to do
for a show I can't remember it was
either Victor or Camp guy
that recommended it and it's probably a
good thing to do because like I said
there's been a very famous case of a
fake abduction that just happened like
at the end of July and so
um so I want to talk a little bit about
that and then we'll get into like some
older cases and [__] like that
um all right so the case that I'm
talking about obviously is Carly Russell
and this has been all over social media
it's all over the news everything like
that and this just happened like in the
middle of July of 2023.
so this young woman I think she's 25
something like that she's like in her
20s
and she was a nursing student now what
happened with her was that she
supposedly
um disappeared from her home in which is
in Hoover Alabama and she was gone for
49 hours
and when she returned she said that she
had been abducted
now how this ended up happening
was that at about 9 30 on July 13th of
she called 9-1-1
and she told them that she had pulled
over on the side of the interstate
because there was like a kid like a
toddler who was unattended like walking
down the side of the highway which seems
like a weird random detail like
especially now that you know that she
just made it up and I was like what a
weird thing to say
so she said she stopped to see like what
the deal with this little kid was that
was going on the side of the road so she
called 9-1-1 and then she also called
like a relative and told them the same
thing
um and then like they they kept like
trying to talk to her but like she
wasn't there even though the line was
still open like you could still you know
the connection was still there but like
no one was talking
so the cops go out to the location where
the call came from
and they found Carly Russell's car uh
abandoned but they didn't find her
so she was gone for like I said 49 hours
and her disappearance went viral like
especially like on Tick Tock like
everybody was talking about it Crime
Stoppers came out and raised like sixty
thousand dollars or something like that
like looking for they're looking for
everywhere and it was like this huge big
deal
now I was reading an interview with the
cops that investigated the case and they
said well even from the beginning we
thought something was like a little bit
fishy about it but you know you have to
investigate everything like it's you
know like it is on Face Value because
you never know because weird [__]
happens all the time you know
so 49 hours later Carly Russell turns
back up at her parents house
and then they take her to the hospital
now she says like the cops come and they
interview her she says she was kidnapped
by a dude I think the only description
she gave was that he was a redhead like
he had orange hair and he had like a
bald spot
and it was a white dude and
um that then she was like put into like
the back of a tractor trailer
and she said that at one point she was
actually able to get away but then the
guy like caught up with her like in a
car and like recaptured her and put her
back in the car
she also said that the dude didn't tie
her up because he didn't want to leave
like marks on her wrists or ankles or
anything like that
she also said that he had put a
blindfold on her and that he had taken
her clothes off and taken pictures of
her but she didn't claim to have been
like sexually assaulted or anything like
that but she did say that he did that
kind of stuff
so as I said the cops at the beginning
like they kind of heard this story and
they're like well that sounds like a
little
far-fetched one of the things they
thought was kind of far-fetched was
they're like well her initial reports of
like seeing a toddler like walking by
itself like down the side of the
interstate they're like you would think
that if that had happened that we would
have got multiple calls about that
because that's kind of a big deal like
seeing a little kid walking on the side
of the road you'd get like a bunch of
calls to the cops and they didn't really
have that so they were unable to
verify if there if that actually was
happening
and so they thought that was a little
weird and also like her description was
a little vague like of the person and
they couldn't figure out how she escaped
and got recaptured like you know what I
mean her story didn't have like a lot of
detail
and then when they started looking more
into Carly Russell's background where
they started like doing a little more
investigation into her
they did a search on her computer
and found out that in the days prior to
her going missing she had done Google
searches for
phrases such as do you have to pay for
an Amber Alert
um how to take money from a register
without being caught
and also one-way bus ticket from
Birmingham to Nashville
because she was in uh Alabama
Birmingham that Birmingham Alabama bus
station I used to go through it all the
time really yeah on the way to
Mississippi sometimes yeah
when I was a little kid
above and bust me to [__]
did you ever did you ever get almost
kidnapped there no no no
it sounds like the kind of like Source I
like
going on a bus
it was long though
I have the only time I've ever been like
on a really long well it wasn't even
that long but on a long Greyhound bus
trip was from Daytona to Atlanta which
took six no
it takes six hours if you drive
in a car if you take a Greyhound it
takes 12 hours because they have to stop
everywhere I think it took 12 hours I
took that bus from Detroit all the way
down to [__]
uh
Heidelberg Mississippi or no Laurel
Mississippi that [__] was [__] took
forever like 18 hours probably it takes
a long time well because they have to
stop at like every Podunk little town
like on the way I think they do have
Express ones that don't I don't know
about nowadays because I've been on a
Greyhound in a million years but I think
they do have options where you can just
be like can we just stop in real cities
please instead of just like stopping at
every little you know convenience store
stop like on the way because that's what
the that's what the Daytona Atlanta one
was like stop off at Birmingham and
you're in Birmingham for a long time
like an hour layover well that's kind of
that's kind of a bigger city it's a big
one yeah that's like the major city
but so she yeah so and the weird thing
about Carly Russell is that I'm not
entirely sure like I haven't been I've
just been following it kind of like
superficially so I'm not real sure like
what her reasoning was for doing what
she did I thought the implication was
and I don't know if they really want to
say this outright although they're kind
of like dancing around it is that maybe
she's having like some mental health
issues
um because she didn't really seem to
because like I said when we talk about
some of the other cases like some of the
people like had really obvious reasons
for doing what they did and if they were
dumb as [__]
but she didn't really seem to have any
reason I don't know if she just wanted
to like kind of totally blow up her life
or she was kind of having some kind of
nervous breakdown or something like that
oh she was also looking up stuff about
that movie with Liam Neeson Taken which
is has an abduction in it so there's
that too but yeah so they thought it was
super fishy like all of her Google
things so they started like kind of
questioning her and stuff like that and
then finally finally uh like 11 days
after she was supposedly kidnapped she
finally did admit that she had faked it
now she didn't come out herself and say
that she actually had her attorney like
come out and announce it publicly and
basically what the attorney said and I
don't know if this is true or not or if
this is just the narrative they're going
with but she's like basically nobody
nobody helped her like nobody else was
in on it
nothing like that
um she just kind of like left and like
went to a hotel and then she just
decided to come back like I said I don't
really know and maybe more stuff will
come out because this is fairly new this
case like I said it was just like a
couple weeks ago that this happened so
maybe more stuff will come out about her
like mental state and stuff like that
and I'm not [__] I'm like I'm not
making fun because I know that sometimes
people do have you know mental issues or
they like flip out and they're just kind
of like oh my God I can't take this
anymore and like they [__] take off
but when I was reading about her case it
was in her case in particular that
um I believe it was lawmakers in Alabama
that were talking about oh we should
make it a felony because all they're
charging her with is to misdemeanors
because that's really the only laws that
they have on the books
um you know like false reporting
um you know and and that's pretty much
it so they can't really and I'm sure
they're probably gonna ask her to like
pay back however much money they spent
like looking for her uh because that's
not free but like I said I think it's a
stupid idea
to make that a felony I think that that
is going to have really really bad
unforeseen consequences
that will
make it more unlikely that people that
are actual victims of a crime will
report it now
and it's already bad like it's not so
much kidnapping but I think like
particularly in case of like sexual
assault or something like that that's
why I always get so mad when like people
falsely report stuff because that makes
it less likely that people who actually
have it happen to them now they're not
going to report it either because
they're not going to be believed because
everyone's going to think you know it's
like the boy the crab wolf situation so
you know and the thing about it is that
just as in you know sexual assault and
things like that it's like it's actually
quite rare
um for people to falsely claim to have
been sexually assaulted people falsely
claim to be kidnapped it's not really
that common but they kind of act as if
it is and I think that that's going to
kind of blow up in people's faces you
know what I mean like
people that are actually victims of the
[__] because it's much more likely that
somebody is actually a victim of it so
but we'll see how that goes I just think
that's going to be a dumb idea but
because this case was so
famous and everybody was talking about
it that it's almost kind of like oh well
we as lawmakers have to look like we're
doing something about it even though it
was literally one case and nobody got
hurt
or anything you know what I mean yeah
it's stupid and you shouldn't do it and
it's a waste of money and it's a waste
of resources that could be used on
actual crimes and that's bad but in the
grand scheme of things you know it's
probably not
felony worthy that's just my opinion so
I'm just saying that
so yeah so we'll see how that develops
because like I said that is still a
fairly new case but I kind of wanted to
get a little bit into it because that's
the one that everybody's talking about
nowadays and honestly if you go on
YouTube and you search fake kidnapping
like 99 of the videos are about her
because those are all the newest ones
and then the other ones are about Sherry
papinian like I said you know I'm not
going to talk about that one because we
did a show about her already or did a
show with her already
so this other case I want to talk about
this guy this is kind of a weird case
and I think this one is it's this one is
like not really funny it's kind of like
just a little bit more sad because I
think this dude
um was also having some mental health
issues
so this guy uh this is Dr Mark Salerno
now this happened way back in 2002.
now at the time in 2002 uh Dr solero was
45 years old
and he lived in Phoenix Arizona
now he claimed that he had been
kidnapped in Phoenix
and three days later he was found in
Pennsylvania in the trunk of his car
so he basically said um you know these
guys just kind of grabbed me and drove
me around for a little while like drove
me across the country and then stuck me
in my
trunk and then that's like all I know
pretty much
so it was kind of like a really big news
story at the time because like I said it
was cross country it's like oh my God
they drove him all the way from like
Arizona to Pennsylvania and he was like
in the trunk or whatever
however
it soon came to light
that he had actually not been abducted
how they found out was that when the
case went National and it was on all the
news programs and everything like that
several witnesses came forward and said
that they had seen Dr Salerno locking
himself in his own trunk
so there was that
so they came forward and they're like
that bro there was there was like nobody
else around so when they like
investigated they were like yeah he
basically kidnapped himself
so they questioned him about that and he
did confess to it
um he said that he was having like some
Financial issues that he was having a
lot of personal issues they talked to
his wife and like some other family
friends and said that he had actually
been uh suffering from depression for a
really long time and he actually said
later that prior to the fake abduction
he was actually he had actually
um was going to drive to San Diego
um and was going to jump off a bridge he
was gonna you know kill himself
but then decided on the fake abduction
route which okay
so
so he admitted to it
um and like I said it seemed like he was
having some mental issues
now he actually did get in Arizona he
got three years probation
and he was actually asked to pay eight
thousand dollars back for all of the you
know overtime not the cops had done like
looking for him
now the weird thing about this guy and
this is kind of sad too is that six
weeks after this incident he disappeared
again
and this time
he disappeared from Arizona again which
is where he lived this time they found
him in Pittsburgh
and they found him when he was like
running through someone's backyard and
like stole a towel off of their uh out
off their like laundry line or whatever
like he just like took it and like kept
running and they were like hey that's
that guy so they reported so they found
him again
now the crazy [__] about this
is that so that happened and like I said
he seemed to be having like some mental
issues and everything like that however
he I don't know what what became of him
like in between like 2002 and 2018 but
in October of 2018
he disappeared again and as far as I
know
they haven't I haven't seen any update
on him since then so that's been five
years so I don't know
I I kind of this is probably sad but
it's like I imagine that he might have
taken off and
and killed himself somewhere because
I looked and looked and I was like I
couldn't find any updates about where
he's at now like I'm on Reddit and
they're just like Yeah The Dude
disappeared again in like October of
2018 and apparently no one's heard from
him since so I don't really know what
this situation there was and like I said
I don't really know why specifically
like he chose to
um you know make it seem as though he'd
been abducted like the second time like
the first time obviously he tried to
make it seem he's like oh my God these
guys came and they pushed me in a van or
whatever but it's like the second time I
don't really think he tried to claim
that he'd been abducted he just
disappeared and then he turned up across
the country somewhere else like running
through somebody's backyard and they saw
him so there was that kind of situation
but as far as I know like since 2018 I
don't know if anyone knows where he is
so I'm not
and and I kind of like suspect the worst
and that case is like actually pretty
sad because he really does seem like he
was having some
really having some problems so uh you
know so there's that but like I said I
don't really know
what's happened to him since then
because I couldn't find anything about
it
so this next case
is a little bit less uh
uh depressing I guess
this is the case of Maria Gonzalez
this also happened in 2018.
now Maria Gonzalez at the time was 32
years old and she ran a like a trucking
business uh out in California somewhere
now in 2018 she actually claimed that
she had been
kidnapped
and robbed and also possibly sexually
assaulted although she wasn't sure
she said that she was driving down the
road in her car and that she saw two
dogs in the road that were like in front
of the car so she stopped at which point
two dudes with masks on ran out like and
they were armed and everything and they
ran out got in her car and told her to
keep driving
then she said that she
that they hit her on the head with
something because she lost consciousness
and then she woke up and she said her
head was all messed up like shoot her
head was injured and then she said she
thought maybe they had also sexually
assaulted her because she said well her
underwear was wet so she thought maybe
something had happened there
and she then told the police that she
had had nine thousand dollars in her
purse that she was going to that was
like the payroll for her company for her
shocking company that was what she was
going to use to pay the um pay the
workers you know what I mean
so the cops came out and investigated
and the spot where she said that she'd
been abducted they were like well
suspiciously the only footprints around
the area were her Footprints like there
weren't any two dude Footprints or dog
Footprints or anything like that that
would corroborate her story
um also they thought it was kind of
strange that the only thing that these
purported robbers took was the nine
thousand dollars that she had in her
purse like nothing else was taken like
no there was other [__] or like credit
cards and stuff like that that they did
not take so they thought that that was a
little bit fishy also
and when they asked her like they press
her for more details like well how
exactly did you get away like because
you claimed you were tied up and all
this other stuff and they said her story
didn't really like she wasn't really
good at like coming up with details of
how exactly she had escaped from them
and [__] like that
so as they investigated further they
discovered that indeed Maria had faked
the abduction and had actually hit
herself in the head
um to make it look as though she had
been hit in the head and not unconscious
uh also I think they had some CCTV
footage of the area that showed no one
else around there so once they showed it
to her she was she kind of like
confessed to it and basically the reason
that she did it was because
she didn't have the nine thousand
dollars to pay her workers with
and instead of just telling them that
she didn't have it she decided to say
that she had been abducted and robbed
and that was why she didn't have the
money
seems a little
over the top seems a little elaborate
when you could have just said hey I
don't have the money I spent it on
hookers and blow
so
I don't have any money to pay you so but
I don't know I guess I don't know I
don't get this like kind of overly
dramatic because like I said and that's
not even the stupidest reason
that these people have for doing this
kind of [__]
um yeah Ben said just like John tutor oh
yeah didn't we do a show about that dude
wasn't that that guy what the [__]
remind me sounds familiar yeah I know we
did a show about him
I forgot who that was
he didn't get abducted by aliens did he
no no that was a different guy no
I don't know what he's talking we've
done so many well I know I know that
we've done a show about that but I can't
remember exactly man we've done so many
shows
that we can't remember them all
it's funny man we'll get messages from
from like hardcore fans that'll it's
funny the time traveler there time
travel yeah that's right okay yeah yeah
that's right that's right that's right
now that you said that right I've had
guys [__] come back and throw quotes
that and I said I know I said that but I
don't know what I was talking about at
the time
yeah I mean you have to think we've been
doing this show yeah and movie reviews
and stuff like that so it's like 2016.
so it's like we've done hundreds and
hundreds of shows and like hundreds and
hundreds of movies and stuff like that
it's like so I feel kind of bad because
sometimes I can't even remember like if
we've covered a topic or if we've
covered a movie or something like that
sometimes I'm surprised we did and
sometimes I'm surprised we didn't
because I'm like man we have done like
hours and hours an hour I wonder how
many hours of
show we've produced over the years it
must have been and uh if you add up all
the views it's a lot of them and a lot
of people have seen us
it's funny we'll be on stream mate and
some guy come in and throw some [__] at
me and I go I know he's a [__]
listener like in otherwise it's you
raising the money to get me pegged yeah
that's right yeah yeah that was a we
don't know who that was just
I started [__] and we were just kind
of like hey you watching he disappeared
you watch all right because he knew all
about it
[Laughter]
which I thought was very funny well I
mean we probably knew that would happen
but like I said I really I really like
when that does happen though because
you know at least we have like we can
talk I have somebody to tell me that I'm
famous in high school
that their High School got cats that
listened to me oh that's right remember
that yeah there are dudes in high school
that [__] love it I don't know I
don't know what they're talking about
but which is hilarious that was years
back now yeah I never really think about
it it's like you know we just kind of
come on the show we're on autopilot just
going through it doing our job I mean
not so much autopilot like but you know
we're I don't really think about
I don't really think about anyone
watching it other than you guys yeah you
know what I mean because you guys are
always here and right so we kind of have
like a little Community going but it's
like sometimes I forget that like oh
yeah other people are watching them and
like and new people like discover them
all the time it seems like because I'll
have like comments on a really really
old show and people like hey I just
found this Channel and it's just kind of
like and they're asking me [__] about it
and I'm just like uh that was like
[__] six years ago that we did that
show I don't remember [__] about it but
you know what I mean because I tend not
to listen to them again they're one off
so we don't go back I don't usually
sometimes Tom does but I don't even
think you do that that much anymore
sometimes depends on what it is I'll go
back and go look at like what the what
the view count is on the uh
on the Ed Lorraine Warren show that's
still pretty high oh yeah yeah they
still that one gets a lot of hits
and I don't I don't get as many abusive
comments about that one as I used to
yeah that used to be like Bar None yeah
the video that got the most like
insulting comments I don't to be honest
I think gets rid of a lot of [__]
I have shitty comments anymore like
every now and then I do but it's not
like I mean it's not like the old days
when like people would come on and tell
you to kill yourself yeah [__] like that
oh yeah you [__] sjws and [__] and
I'm going like wait dude you don't
[__] know me man
well yeah but it's like I don't know
every now and then like I get like a
sideways comment but not usually I don't
usually get that many anymore I think AI
gets a lot of stuff
yeah because yeah I think well I think
that if you say like something shitty
like um you know uh in in a comment yeah
it'll well I mean technically it's
supposed to go to your uh review thing
like it won't be and you can look at it
and be like you can let it pass or not
yeah you know what I mean but I don't I
don't usually get any any [__] anymore
it doesn't happen well like I was saying
I've made comments on other videos
though on not these videos videos that
I'm watching
and going back two seconds later and
that comment's gone
I think AI gets it yeah maybe
um
but like I said yeah
and then another thing is is that
I don't get any notifications
I'll make a comment on a video
and never get any notifications on it go
back a week later to go look at that
same video again and I'll see my comment
and I'll have [__] 30 likes and about
three comments on it
and I never got any notices on it
YouTube doesn't really work anymore
they've it's like well it seems
intermittent because sometimes like if I
go to the YouTube channel it'll be like
hey so-and-so replied to a comment that
so I do get notifications sometimes but
sometimes I don't yeah so it just kind
of seems like it's Hit or Miss I get one
out of maybe a hundred
one notification out of a hundred actual
comments or something like most of them
I never
YouTube doesn't work it's it's got a
bunch of censorship algorithms it's got
all kinds of weird algorithms to [__]
keep conversation down to a minimum in
the comment section
I think a lot of it has to do with the
fact they don't have the data
think of how many videos are out there
well that's what I'm saying I think it's
just getting overwhelmed it would
overwhelm it to do all that [__] and so
what they do is is they make an
algorithm to stop
a [__] comments stop most of the
comments and most of the notifications
they're definitely going to prioritize
anything that has cuss words in it
anything that has maybe keywords and the
AI is very good it can
I'll go back to some of our old videos
and it's already got subtitles and
closed captions for them it doesn't take
too long for it to do that it takes like
a little while for him to Auto generate
the audio auto generate is still not
great and then say [__] like Tom talks
about this it knows my name and
everything yeah
but it is getting better because I used
to like I did used to check some of the
auto generated and I was just like yeah
not good but it understood it is
actually getting a lot it understands me
nowadays yeah which is good because I'm
too [__] lazy to go in there and like
do and put in [__] you know what I
mean
yeah but I but I watch other videos
because I'm deaf as [__] so I always
like watch other videos with the closed
captioning on and it does seem like the
auto generated has gotten a lot better
but it's still not perfect yeah because
like sometimes especially if somebody
has like a particular accent or
particular words it doesn't really seem
to know so
um you know but but it's a lot better
this is just an old platform and it's
it's very corporate and it wanted to be
television and
and wanted censorship and it wanted uh
advertising and it wants commercials I
mean I'm having a problem where watching
a video man is nothing but that damn
commercials now you know I like to go to
uh some of the newer platforms where
they're yeah there's not as many people
on them but you don't have to watch
you don't have to watch any uh like
Rumble
there's never any commercials on it so
it's a good thing to listen to when
you're going to sleep because you never
[__] commercials don't wake you up
and if you make a comment on a rumble
video you you see all your interactions
on that comment
you know and it's it's it's a good
platform it just doesn't have a lot of
the
doesn't have a lot of the um
like uh I'm real big into the
entertainment industry and what's going
on with Disney what's going you know
what's going on with comic books and
[__] I like listening to midnight
Edge a lot you know and and they don't
have a lot of the uh entertainment
videos there it's mostly kind of like
news and politics and geopolitics and
learning you know what I mean
YouTube's more for fun
that's what I think
yeah I mean like I said on YouTube I
tend to well I mean I I like that a lot
of people like post documentaries about
very like True Crime and chill like that
because I watch a lot of those yeah but
um mostly what I I have a lot of like
horror movie [__]
um scary stories I like that because I
like to listen to them in the car like
uh like on long drives and stuff
but
yeah I don't really
I listen to a lot of scholarly [__]
though you know what I mean [__]
listen to scientists and stuff I like
Event Horizon that's one of the best
things best shows and but it's only on
YouTube so you gotta put up the
commercials I wish it was on Rumble
then be commercial free well the thing
about it and a lot of creators are doing
this too is that what they'll do is
they'll put stuff up on YouTube but then
they'll put like a page like if you're
on their patreon then you can watch the
[__] on patreon without you know which
you can't really blame him and like I
said the creators got money from not a
lot of money but you get a little bit of
money from ad Revenue so you can't
really blame people for putting ads on
stuff I was listening to this German guy
last night man he was he was badass I
fell asleep during it which means it was
good means I gotta go back and look at
it again because if I'm [__] in bed
and I'm listening to something
fascinating I'll he'll get me thinking
and I'll go off in a direction and I'll
fall asleep
uh the the more important it is the
faster I will fall asleep and he was
talking about [__] how societies
actually collapse and he's not an
American but he was talking about the
United States He was saying and he's
talking about when it [__] started it
started about 20 years ago and he was
telling the [__] story and everything
I was like yeah that's about right but
uh had to do with the collapse of the
middle class and corporatism and rich
people sucking up all the money
and then propagandizing all the [__]
institutions and taking over all the
institutions and he's just his German
guy and he says yeah it's a pattern you
know there's an old there's a law of
oligarchy every civilization goes
through it and just talk about the life
cycles of civilizations and Empires and
[__] and I was about halfway through it
and fell asleep I'd go back and listen
to it again it was a guy from Germany
he written a bunch of books on it kind
of like reminded me of the Lucifer
principal remember that book that we
watch
or that book that we read yeah Lucifer
what was that name of that uh author
Harold something yeah yeah
I have it somewhere how technology can
end Society
lack of it or too much of it
Zach says sometimes I think too many
people watched Gone Girl and assumed it
would turn out how it did in the movie
yeah but you know maybe
um he also says I remember way back when
they started doing Auto subtitles and I
was watching a video about architecture
and the subs were saying something about
Meals on Wheels yeah yeah sometimes it's
their but they have gotten a lot better
I have I've noticed they've gotten a lot
better exactly man you just showing up
now man
he's been talking okay I missed old Bath
House Zachary
you had that problem cleared up now it's
not tingling did you did you go to the
cootie though yeah
Sebastian said Tom and Jenny did you
review Silence of the Lambs just watched
it good film had you not seen it before
is that like the first time [__] oh I
kind of Envy like I kind of Envy um
anyone that gets to see it for the first
time I don't know if you saw it for the
first time but I kind of Envy I saw it
in the theater all right look let me
tell you something if you like that one
see Hannibal Rising it's the origin
story to Dr Hannibal I mean I saw things
still think Silence of the Lambs is the
best one it's good but I buy a long shot
but um yeah I saw that in the theater I
remember me and my mom went to see it in
the theater when it came out back in
1991 or whatever it was and I remember
having to pee so bad like through that
whole movie but I would not leave
because it was just so riveting and I'm
just like I really gotta pee but I can't
leave I can't leave so I was like I
still remember that about the thing but
I've seen it like probably a million
times since then I don't think we ever
have reviewed it it was probably one of
those movies that is just like oh well
obviously for granted well you take it
for granted like everyone's seen it it's
like who really wants to listen to our
take on it necessarily but maybe we
should at some point I don't know
because I really do love that movie see
Hannibal Rising I think it's a classy
flick real good last night you know we
we re-watched last night um
Ginger Snaps yeah that's a good movie I
liked it that's the second type scene
and I liked it better the second time
because we were because I was watching
Night Gallery because I'm doing a Night
Gallery thing you know season two for my
uh other channel
and so there was like a werewolfy
episode on there and Tom's like man I
feel like watching a werewolf movie and
I was like well you know shutter just
added a bunch of werewolf movies like
American Werewolf in London and Howling
and ginger snaps and all this other
stuff and so he wanted to watch Ginger
Snaps yeah they actually had the couple
sequels on there too those two girls in
that movie [__] watching it again I
was I was saying to Jamie I said if I
was a girl I'd be that one right there
that's how I have it been probably it
was just something because they were
just
they were just kind of like Kindred kind
of Spears like yeah I know what you're
talking about that's how that's how my
attitude would have been if I was a
chick that's how my attitude was when I
was yeah even though I'm substantially
older than they are yeah
and then um they kind of reminded me so
much of my Ex-Wives friends
[__] they were two sisters Melissa
and Michelle they were they were the
Mississippi version of that
this is back a long time ago you know I
was about 30. they were still in their
like 20s early 20s mid-20s they were out
of high school but they were still like
that kind of Goths Mississippi Gods but
they've got all fancy corsets and [__]
like that but they came from that kind
of background you know there's it's just
kind of kind of nostalgic in a way great
night late 90s early 2000s fashion you
liked it
her little werewolf outfit was cute
yeah I liked I liked all that [__] yeah
I've forgotten I think I saw the sequels
but I haven't
um seen them in a long time I'm gonna
watch the rest of them I want to see the
rest of them Zach said got the yep got
the cooties looked at yeah eating on
result eating on results what does that
mean I was late enough I filled out the
paper so fast I opted out of blood works
I just did a sample and threw it as well
don't die I think that's enough for them
to learn anything well I guess we'll
find out we're gonna find out man
we're gonna have a full [__] report
all [__] all [__] bad house Bath
House Zachary's [__] STDs yeah we
want to know what two seasons you got
while you were in there
yeah
but yeah I mean we'll definitely I have
been actually thinking about doing
silence so maybe we will although I
think this weekend because hey
um I actually have the next five [__]
days off work
so we're gonna do some streaming here
we're gonna do streaming on the other
platform and uh we also might go to the
movies I want to see that new horror
movie that came out talk to me and I
think
it's playing here but I don't know if
it's if I have to wait till Friday or
Saturday to see it Tom wants to see the
Meg too
so I don't know if that started yet
either I just wanted to see last Voyage
of the demeanor but that doesn't start
until next weekend so I'm [__] out of
luck on that one
but I'm pretty sure talk to me is
playing though so I might go see that
this weekend
but I don't know we'll we'll see how it
goes we might go do something tomorrow
all right so let's get back to the topic
because you know how we do well the
tingle is gone so that's good we'll see
if that is good all right so this next
[__] actually these next two
stories are kind of
similar but the thing that makes me
laugh about these is just how
I mean look if you're gonna fake a
kidnapping I feel like go for the drama
you know like go Whole Hog I'm not like
saying actually to please don't do that
but I'm just sick it's a shitty idea but
I'm just saying if you're gonna do that
think bigger I guess
um because these two seemed like
if you're gonna go to all the trouble to
do that like don't be as lame as this
so this dude
is named Jonathan Davis and this also
happened in 2018.
so this guy uh he was at the time 34
years old and he went missing
and then a bunch of his family members
started getting text messages
and the text messages said that he'd
been kidnapped obviously and the
kidnappers were asking the family to pay
a ransom of guess how much a whopping
375 dollars
cheap I mean you know that's like a
bargain abduction right there
so yeah so he's like we're gonna need
375 dollars
for the return of your relative
um so these text messages also said that
um oh look we broke Jonathan's finger
and they sent a picture
and they said we're gonna break all the
other ones if you don't send the money
so
the family the dude's family they call
the cops and reported it
and then the cops got like the US
Marshals and the FBI and everything like
that involved because you know what I
mean
now interestingly because the
text messages from the supposed
kidnappers
were coming from Jonathan's phone which
doesn't necessarily mean that he wasn't
abducted they could just be using his
phone you know what I mean
but they decided oh well since they're
coming from his phone we'll just Trace
his phone and then we'll find out where
the kidnappers are so they trace his
phone and it turned out that Jonathan
Davis who was
spoiler alert not kidnapped uh was
sitting in a casino gambling sending his
family members
things asking for 375 dollars also
turned out that obviously the kidnappers
did not break his finger and actually he
just got that [__] off of Google Images
because they said as soon as they
searched broken finger on Google Images
that was like one of the first pictures
that came up so I'm like
not a criminal mastermind this one uh
you know so if you're gonna do that I
mean at least go the whole the full
enchilada and like actually break your
finger and don't send [__] from your own
phone and also ask for more than 375
dollars I feel like like I said if
you're gonna in for a penny in for a
pound you know what I'm saying 375 365
[__] ain't much
it's like that's not how I'm supposed to
laugh that's what I mean it's just kind
of like I don't know why that's so funny
to me that it was just like that [__]
amount and it's a it's so it's such a
small amount and also like so weirdly
specific yeah
[Laughter]
375. I need exactly 375 or we're gonna
break the rest of his fingers [__]
funny just like in a stock photo yeah
you know what I mean the stock photo of
the broken figures which like I said I
want
one thousand dollars
[Laughter]
yeah right
that's uh that's why I laughed
um yeah Zach said it's 375 that's what a
10 year old thinks is a bunch of money
yeah that's what I mean I didn't mean to
start laughing if I was okay yeah 375
come on It's gotta be a little kid like
I said if you're gonna be asking for
ransom then he'd ask for like a huge
amount I would think if you're gonna get
all that trouble and risk getting in
your ass and when I was a little kid I
was playing that I was playing that I
was making a car a car store okay and I
had a little [__] I don't remember
what it was like a little [__] car
store yeah I had like a little TV stand
you know no TV dinner stand yeah put
that up on the [__] sidewalk in front
of the house and then I had something I
don't remember what it was I think it
was kind of like a jewelry box that I
found a used jewelry box and had a bunch
of Matchbox cars in there okay in the
jewelry box my dad was like what are you
doing this is I'm selling these cars
this is your car lot all right I guess
yeah yeah in my car lot and I said and
this is how much are they and I had I
had it like scribbled down how much they
were because I could write you know this
is one car one car is 50 Cents it says
in the two cars is five dollars
[Laughter]
all of them is a million dollars there's
one like 20 cars in there because
there's only like 20 is a million
dollars problem yeah it's a million
dollars that's like something a kid
would quite a deal because it's all of
them so [__] that's a million that's
yeah yeah that's a lot of cars [__]
million yeah
that's what it reminds me one is a
dollar
all of them is a million
yeah
yeah that's that's kind of uh the vibe
that I'm getting makes perfect sense
when you're a child sure except this
dude was 34. right yeah
Hugo said I liked your review of the
company of wolves thank you very much uh
that's a cool movie if you guys haven't
seen if you like werewolf movies yeah
Sammy said and 52 cents Zach says
pretends to be kidnapped to be able to
pay for the full Adobe suite right I
mean
how much is that going for these days
I don't even I paid for just Photoshop
for a while
but
um what was I think that was 20 a month
but the more you get like the more they
charge per month you know what I mean
because like really kind of only need
well only I really only kind of need
Photoshop illustrator and InDesign the
other ones I don't use as much but still
I mean even if they're just charging 20
a month each that's like 60 a month
I don't know maybe eventually I'll get
the news because you guys I still have
Photoshop and illustrator like version
six so that's how old my [__] is so it's
like every time I do like something on a
newer version I have to like save it
back like in a
in the old platform so it'll because
otherwise it won't open like in my old
[__] [__] it's sad
but yeah so but yeah now it's like a you
have to pay every month but used to be
Photoshop used to cost
if when you just bought it outright I
think it cost like 700 something dollars
just for Photoshop you know what I mean
but now it's like 20 a month like it's
all in the cloud now or whatever
so okay so here's this other similar
case which also happened in 2018 this
one happened in Michigan actually and
this was a 40 year old dude named Jason
Hillier
same kind of deal here uh this guy's
parents got a phone call
and the dude on the other end who was
not Jason Hillier as far as I know said
uh yeah we kidnapped your son and asked
the mom for just a thousand dollars
it's a thousand dollars which is better
than 375 that's still all that buzz also
wanted the dude's car
called the Dad separate and asked the
dad for 500 so 1500 and a car I don't
know what kind of car it was
uh so Jason's mom called the cops as you
would and the cop said well why don't
you go ahead and pay the thousand
dollars I mean if they said that's me
I'm like pay it with what I don't have a
thousand dollars like what the [__] you
gonna give me a thousand dollars so I
can pay the [__] [__] I don't have it
so it's like he's just gonna have to get
killed or get his fingers cut off
because it's too bad so she actually so
she takes it to the drop point because
that's the kidnappers the kidnappers
quote unquote had told him it's like you
know leave the money here
now the cops I think the cops kind of
suspected there was some funny business
going on so they had like or I don't
know or they just thought they were
gonna catch the kidnapper but they had
like already set up cameras like at the
drop point right
so the kidnapper shows up in a car and
picks up the money
so they show this surveillance video to
Jason's mom and they're like do you know
this person she's like yeah that's Jason
he came and picked up his own Ransom
money damn in the car and they got him
on camera can you imagine his mom is
just like oh
probably is like oh I raised an idiot so
a thousand dollars a thousand dollars
yeah
I love it like I said I love these
[__]
fake kidnappings so they only ask for
that at least ask for like a [__] like
at least ask for like half a mil or
something like that damn if you're 100
000 if you're gonna go all that way a
thousand dollars it's like that doesn't
even pay one month of my business
it's like what the [__] that's like
nothing I wouldn't start any of that
[__] until a hundred thousand be the
bare minimum yeah you would think bare
minimum 100 000 it's realistic that the
victim might be the victim's family
might be able to come up with a hundred
thousand that's kind of right really you
might be able to do that Pro tip
yeah because it's not so much you're not
asking for a million dollars because
people like where the [__] am I getting
a million dollars and I mean most people
can come up with that yeah they probably
that's like a reasonable issue yeah
and yeah it's not like totally over the
top so you might actually kind of get
that but like I said please don't do it
because you'll get really but you have
to understand it's only a hundred
thousand they got people that make that
kind of money just doing a job well yeah
I know you know which means although
[__] man if you want to truly be rich
and if you do three or four of those
jobs a year yeah you know I've been so
broke my whole life that I could
probably live on a hundred thousand
dollars for several years yeah we can
stretch it out let's kind of eat it up
that's true that's why we're [__]
doing what we do now well yeah we're
gonna make some money up in this
[__] we're gonna make some money
could be good yeah I mean you know I'm
hoping we do yeah we'll make one
but uh but yeah so
so the dude not knowing that he's been
busted because like I said I guess he
didn't know what was going on he didn't
know that his mom was like yeah that's
the that's my idiot's on right there
like posing as the like picking up his
own [__] random money so he calls
again posing as the kidnapper and asks
his mom for another 150 dollars
150 dollars
and she paid this as well she probably
thought this [__] was hilarious I would
think this was hilarious
um but and I guess like they had the
same drop-off points so he goes this she
has to like drop the same like 150
[__] bucks like at the place and the
cops were there and they came in and
arrested him uh turned out that this guy
also had an accomplice it was a friend
of his who was like half his age who was
20. his name was Michael Forrester and I
guess he was the one that had been
calling sometimes like so the mom didn't
recognize the voice
um so basically this guy uh was just
trying to get money uh for drugs is what
he was doing so I guess that's why he
couldn't ask his parents for money
outright hey can I have some money so I
could buy some crack uh you know that
doesn't 375 still or was no this was a
thousand five hundred and a car and then
another 150. we was that says at the
bottom there 375 was barely half my rent
when I lived my roommate right that's
what I mean 375 that's what your STD
test cost
[Laughter]
I mean that uh uh I'm trying to think of
like what bill I had that was 375
dollars
a month I don't well I had a car payment
that was almost that much you can't even
build a decent rifle for that
I mean yeah that's like I mean it's not
nothing but it's kind of nothing you
can't get anything major nothing this
little little [__] now 375 I could spend
that on a date with a girl
we can what girl are you talking about
no I'm just saying she's been on a date
with a girl because well she must be
like a lot more more high maintenance
than me yeah
you know it's a hundred dollars
if you take it to a nice restaurant it's
a hundred dollars and hotels another
hundred and something dollars and you
can have at least a hundred dollars to
[__] throw around in the [__] club
yeah that's that's a date money yeah
that's what I mean like yeah yeah you
could easily spend that easily in one
night yep I mean [__] just the two of us
have spent 100 something dollars in a
couple hundred dollars just just drink
it just drink one in the club yeah and
so you know what this happened before
yeah
yeah on yeah drinking at a bar and then
like eating something in a restaurant
after we're like getting tacos or some
[__] yeah but then you factor in gas
that too yeah yeah so it's like really
easy so yeah like I said 360. yeah you
go we go to eboard that's
similar
a good night at e-boards couple hundred
yeah we I think last time we went to to
ibor in you know in Tampa
it was
almost 300 yeah maybe a little bit more
yeah but yeah and that's just like not
even that far we're not even doing much
not even splurging no yeah we're like
trying to be careful yeah like not spend
a [__] ton of money right
but yeah
uh Zach said the cootie test was
actually only twenty dollars oh was it
okay that's quite a bargain actually
although like yeah
cooties more often
[__] [__] or at least go get checked
like every week or something just like
to make sure everything is sympathetic
Zach make a reservation for me you at
the damn bath house Jamie's gonna come
too make a reservation for her she's
gonna bring the camera woman
she could be the Cameron woman and sound
she's got the whole jukebox with [__]
Gavin Friday
we're gonna make our first video y'all
are gonna need all kind of Cooties to
sell that [__] we're gonna sell that
[__] on [__] on on minivids yeah we
gotta shoot some more videos this week I
only have 10 on there at the moment yeah
but we can shoot tomorrow we gotta do
some freedom in this one because now
that I have five days off um we can get
all kind of [__] done make all kinds of
porn make all kind of porn yeah
we gotta go Outdoors this time
it's hot out there though that's what I
mean it's like I I do want to do like
some outdoor [__] but it's like I don't
know if this is the best time of year to
do it yeah because now you just like
walk out the door and you're like well
I'm already all sweaty yeah
so
I'm gonna do this yeah do it in a car
it's hot in the car too yeah and my car
is like really dirty I should probably
like clean my car maybe I can do that
sometime in the next few days too my car
is just like it's not disgusting dirty
it's just like really cluttered and
we get rolling on stream mate you get
rid of that job you come under me come
on streambate full time we'll get you
another car yeah
it does at that rate we were making
money we'll get you another car it'll be
a used car well yeah we got to get rid
of that car that's been a good car but
it's just time to change up I mean it's
20 years old yeah
so it's in a Ford Taurus yeah it's a
Ford the last year of that kind of Ford
Taurus that car was they made that car
for 30 years basically it just changed
the [__] body I mean I will say that
it is very reliable very reliable I
don't want to say that it was [__]
though man it's cooked the pain on the
Florida Sun's cooked the paint off of it
it looks like [__]
but but it works she gets me back and
it's got AC yeah the AC works so that's
something
ah we'll get you a [__]
you saw it or something I had a Nissan
before that was the one that uh yeah
they're pretty good I like they got in a
wreck I had that one for a while that's
a ghetto Honda
yeah I like that car too like I had a
what was it a Nissan Sentra I think yeah
like a white one but it was in an
accident of the fit that Honda Fit was
nice
yeah I bought I actually bought that new
back in 2011 or whatever year that was
yeah
slasher Fred said there was an
underrated 90s comedy called XS baggage
I kind of remember that with uh Alicia
Silverstone who plays a spoiled girl who
stages her own kidnapping in order to
get her daddy's attention yeah I do kind
of feel like that might be a reason for
some people doing this I remember when
Alicia Stover Stone was in that damn
Batman movie yeah and they were [__]
busting on her about how much she had
gained weight and they had to [__]
like Lube her up to get her into the
Batgirl costume that was so shitty I
went back and saw that she looked great
she saw fat no no she wasn't fat she's
that's what and honestly when that
happens delicious looking you know when
that happened I was just like horrified
because I'm like holy [__] they really
that really like they think that she's
fat no yeah she was kind of ahead of her
time she was just kind of she was she
was big fine not big fine what do you
call it too thick she looked good
she look good yeah I don't think they
would do that nowadays but that was like
I I remember that it was like a hole
there's like yeah
I'm like she's totally not fat at the
time you know I kind of ignored it I
remembered it when it happened and I was
saying she didn't look that fat but I
went back and looked at that recently
like a couple years ago it's just no she
looked good yeah she's not found she
looks good real good yeah
yeah
shitty man
the white man wasn't key to Booty at
that time I guess not yeah everybody had
to look like a [__] crap yeah J.Lo
[__] eventually seeped in yeah
I guess so it took long enough
yeah meat put some meat on him Bones
remember all the hotties from the
[__] 80s the porn hotties they were
just [__] Skitty yeah like a little
boy with huge implants that's what they
built like
yeah I kind of feel like that I mean the
70s was kind of like that too everybody
was like super thin no ass on them
there's all that cocaine as well cocaine
but uh that's why everybody was [__]
yeah yeah that's why everybody was that
skinny yeah that's not really natural
but yeah
I mean some people's bodies are like
that naturally but most peoples are not
that's definitely cocaine
um all right so this next guy here his
name is I'm not sure if I'm pronouncing
this correctly uh Rogelio in De Verde is
I think is how you pronounce his name
this happened in 2013. now this guy was
from Texas
now his thing
this is very funny to me and I can and I
wish that I had more follow-up on this
because I would love to know I had a
little bit of fly on the wall like after
the whole thing was resolved
um yeah so this guy he wanted to go out
with his friends to a party
however he thought that his wife whose
name is Maria
wouldn't let him go
so he got two of his friends
to break into the house
and kidnap him
and take him away like literally break
into the house while he's sitting there
in the like sitting in the living room
like watching TV with his wife or
whatever two guys busting
drag him out the house I'm assuming his
wife is like screaming her [__] head
off because you know it's a little
traumatic seeing like two guys come in
there and yeah so they they take him out
the [__] house so she flips out calls
the police as you would
and uh they get like this whole search
party going
they got helicopters they got all this
other kind of stuff and they couldn't
find the dude
two days later
the [__] shows back up at his
house
and says yeah holy [__] honey that was
like that was [__] up it's like yeah
yeah they came in and they kidnapped me
um and they were gonna kill me but then
they changed their mind and they let me
go
so they report this to the cops
obviously because he's back now but the
cops are like that doesn't that sounds
like a likely story and so they kind of
like looked into it turned out
as the theme of the show suggests the
old virgilio was just upset that he
didn't think that his white and I don't
even know if his wife would have
prevented him from going to the bar if
she said no you're absolutely not going
to that party and I don't know what kind
of party it was like he's like what do
you mean I can't go to the go to the
party at the strip club and have sex
with prostitutes you're you're just
you're cramping my style so I don't
really know I don't know what kind of
party it was
and I don't even know if she had
explicitly told him he couldn't go or if
he just thought that she wouldn't let
him go
but whatever the case
he later admitted that he did not think
that she was going to let him go to the
party so he got two of his friends to
break into their house and kidnap him so
he could go to the party and he was gone
for two days
now
what exactly I just wonder what his wife
thought when when he came back and and
she found that [__] out
did she like
what I can't even imagine what she would
have said what would you say
somebody like two days later he's like
oh honey I thought you wouldn't let me
go to that sex party or whatever and
it's just kind of like so I just like
staged to [__] kidnapping I staged a
kid now without so I missed a lot of it
remember I was going to arrest him so
exactly run run it by me again what did
he do
he wanted to go to a party I don't know
what kind of party it was yeah
he wanted to go to a party and either
his wife had told him he couldn't go or
he thought that his wife would tell him
that he wouldn't be able to I don't know
I just I just told you I don't know what
kind of party it was so he had two of
his friends break into the house him and
his wife were both sitting in the living
room like watching TV or whatever he has
two of his friends break into his house
and drag him out the house and kidnap
and take him so she flips out she calls
the cops they have all the helicopters
and [__] like that like looking for him
they can't find him two days later he
turns back up and says yeah that was
[__] up like somebody kidnapped me but
they changed their mind and they let me
go but then like the cops investigated
it and they're like you made that up
didn't you yeah yeah I did
can you imagine like how old was he
um
I don't know actually he might have been
a young guy dumb maybe but that's like
yeah
like I said I was like what kind of
[__] party is this
that he wanted to get a bunch of dudes
ah I guess it said it's a party with his
friends but I don't know so I don't know
if it was going to be like a bachelor
party and they were all gonna go like
have sex with prostitutes and she's like
um no and he was like oh what do you
mean let me step in here
just because it's a bachelor party does
not mean that they're all gonna have oh
no no I didn't say I didn't I didn't
mean to imply that okay I was just
saying maybe that's what this party was
yeah I'm not I'm not implying that all I
know that a lot of people have Bachelor
parties
right right but it's just kind of like I
was thinking maybe this was like another
level and maybe that's why she said no
you know what I mean
I don't know I was just like I know that
all Bachelor parties and actually like a
lot of people have bachelor party just
have regular ass they just go out
drinking they don't even do strip clubs
but
um because I kind of feel like strip
clubs are not really
kind of passe that's what I mean so like
a lot of people don't do them there
anymore yeah but um but yeah so I so I
was wondering if but it could have just
been like a regular ass party and she
thought his friends were
miscreants and she's like no I don't
want you hanging out with them or like I
said it's entirely possible that he that
she didn't even know about the party and
he just thought oh she's not gonna let
me go so I'm gonna
make an end run around her I don't know
what the situation was but it's like I
can't imagine
what she said like when he came back and
she found out that he had done that I
just I can't imagine I hope the first
thing she said was like get the [__] out
because Jesus Christ
so here's another kind of similar
situation and another stupid dude now
this dude actually does have his age on
this wait give us some likes people go
ahead and hit that like yeah Ben said
maybe it was a Scrabble party exactly
maybe they were just playing Monopoly or
Bridge or something like that who knows
or you know [__] I don't know what kind
of wife would say no to that kind of
[__] anyway but you know but then that's
right we're freakazoids me and Jenny go
to the strip club together yeah well
yeah and that's what I mean yeah it
would be like I don't know I can't
imagine any kind of like party that you
would come to me then you would say I
want to go to this and I would and I
wouldn't let you go no you let you you'd
want to come well yeah I'd probably want
to go yeah well I wouldn't [__]
invited you anyway that's what I mean
it's like you're not really the type of
dude that would just go to a party
without me no [__] no
be like Jen they're gonna be some wild
[__] going on you gotta you gotta come
see this yeah we might get lucky
this uh you know
yeah yeah so I can't really imagine this
is Normie drama I guess yeah well and
the thing about it is that here's the
thing like if she doesn't trust you to
go someplace there might be a reason for
that yeah you know what I'm saying there
might be an absolute reason why she
doesn't want you to go hang out with
those dudes because maybe some [__]
happened before and she's like yeah I
don't really like you hanging out with
those dudes because last time you came
back your booty was all greased up and
[__] and I told you don't hang out with
those dudes right or it's like you know
last time you came back with like
gonorrhea you know what I mean it's like
you don't know what the situation is
maybe she had a perfectly valid reason
for telling him because and I don't even
know like I said if she told him he
couldn't go yeah he was over there
hanging out with Zach's friend all right
exactly
the wife was very demanding sexually and
the kidnapping was actually his friends
rescue again
you never know in somebody else's
situation is but like I said in any
situation
I don't imagine staging an abduction is
ever really gonna resolve it or is this
like the not the best way to resolve it
so a similar situation this guy is named
uh Romel pettway and this guy's 36 so
they actually do have his age on here
now this actually happened in 2013 in
Brooklyn
now this guy in a similar kind of
situation he actually left home for two
weeks
and didn't tell his girlfriend where he
was or what he was doing so I imagine it
was probably something
nefarious not necessarily nefarious but
you know what I mean something that um
cheating on her yeah that's that's kind
of what I'm thinking
so because he was gone for two weeks
um he's like well I gotta go back home
at some point uh so what's that what can
I do I know all fake and abduction
so what he did though he's like well I
can't just turn back up and say honey I
got kidnapped because you know no one
would believe that [__] so he actually
bought some duct tape
um and put some duct tape around his
wrists and ankles and stuff like that
and then laid himself like in an alley
someplace so that somebody would find
him you know what I mean and kind of
like messed it like kind of beat himself
up a little bit uh so so it looked like
somebody is
why like what this is like [__] this
is killing me just tell your wife man
that's what I mean she might be
understanding what kind of relationship
do you have that you just that this
happens I don't really I don't really
know
but so yeah so this passerby in I'm
assuming in Brooklyn like finds him and
he's all like taped up and kind of beat
up and everything
and uh so the cops come they take him to
the hospital and he's like holy [__]
um these two guys like kidnapped me and
they held me in this room for two weeks
and then for whatever reason they just
like dumped me out the car and just like
left me in this alley like where this
dude where the where the passerby found
him
um and again I think the cops were a
little bit suspicious at first and um it
turned out well one of the things that
was real suspicious was that he's laying
there
with his ankles and [__] duct taped and
the role of duct tape was just like
around his wrist
like he is like he left the Dead the
roll was still there yeah like he had
just yeah like he went to [__] Home
Depot or some [__] yeah it's like bought
some duct tape and then he just like put
he's like there we go and then he just
left and he goes oh [__] I can't do it
so it's like a dumbass so they're like
um okay yeah
time went on it actually didn't take
them that long to um get him to confess
that yeah I just staged the abduction
because I was gone for two weeks and I
didn't want to tell my girlfriend what I
was doing so there's that like I said I
don't really get it what the [__] are
you dudes up to
so this case here this happened in 2009
and this actually happened in Florida
so this is a woman named Quinn Gray she
was at the time 37 years old
now she goes missing
and then
um her family gets a ransom demand from
a man
and the guy uh asked for fifty thousand
dollars see so see they she was kind of
on to the [__] she she knew like to ask
for ask for a lot no like
375.75 I mean fifty thousand dollars
375. is that all you're worth man we're
on the money there come on
I mean 300 and [__] 85
right like Tammy said 15 cents that's 15
cents
a very specific amount [__] is going on
I don't know
but so this one what are you doing Pokey
leave it alone she's fighting the carpet
yeah but yeah so uh so yeah so this dude
calls and says um you know I'll kill her
if you don't send me fifty thousand
dollars
now
she actually a little while later they
actually found her
in a parking lot uh in Orange Park
and she said that
um some guys had broken into her house
like three days before
and told her that they were gonna take
her because her husband whose name was
Reed gray
um owed them a bunch of money so they
were like kind of using her as leverage
that was the story she told
she told the police that she was kind of
like stuck in this one little room like
they just stuck in this one little room
with a light bulb or something like that
now the more the cops investigated they
ended up arresting this 25 year old guy
named uh Yasmine
osmanovic I guess is how you pronounce
his name and he ran this auto shop
so he got arrested and charged with
kidnapping
because you know all the evidence kind
of like led to him but when they took
him into custody this dude
said
um yeah I didn't actually kidnap her
um what ended up happening was that me
and her have been having an affair for
quite a long time
and
um we have been basically in a motel in
Jacksonville [__] this whole time the
whole time she was gone and she like
roped him into the scheme so he was
actually the one that had called like
you know to get the money and everything
like that so they were like working
together they were in cahoots and this
one like I said it was just basically
her
you know having an affair so there was
that and trying to get money out of her
family so there was that as well
so after that whole scheme unraveled
um they both got uh arrested so what
happened was the guy he got um he
actually pleaded guilty to extortion
which that's another thing that you can
get in trouble for
um and he had to pay forty three
thousand dollars to the St Johns County
Sheriff's Office that was half of the
cost of the investigation Into The
Disappearance so he got six years
probation which is over now because that
was a long time ago
now Quinn Gray herself who was I'm
presuming The Mastermind behind the
whole plot she actually
um pleaded no contest she got seven
years probation and she was ordered to
pay the other half of the money which
was another forty three thousand dollars
so she had to pay that too
um so yeah she apparently got um
like uh married and stuff later on like
after her probation was over as far as I
know she still lives in Jacksonville and
uh teaches yoga so there's that
um but yeah so again that seemed a case
of just her trying to run off with a
with a boyfriend and also trying to get
like a bunch of money out of her family
doesn't seem like
you know the family paid it though
because they're just like oh well she's
just gonna get killed
all right so the next case I want to
talk about this one was actually uh
pretty famous when this happened this
happened back in 2005.
it was kind of like all the rage for a
hot minute this was Jennifer Wilbanks
otherwise known as The Runaway Bride
now this woman who she's about the same
age as me because I was born in 1973.
so she actually ended up disappearing in
April of 2005.
and what ends up happening
um so she goes out for her daily Jog and
she's
um engaged to marry this dude named
Mason
and their wedding was coming off
so she goes out for her regular Jog and
does not return
two hours after she was you know
supposed to come back her fiance Mason
is alarmed and so calls the police and
reports her missing and at this stage
like all the cops obviously they have
like a big search party and everything
like that although even from the
beginning some of the cops were thinking
maybe she just ran off of her own accord
because they were going to get married
soon and she was kind of getting cold
feet or whatever so they were like that
was kind of like a possibility they were
keeping in mind but they're like
obviously she might have really been
kidnapped so we would actually do have
to look for her
um so yeah so they end up spending
like sixty thousand dollars something
like that like in the search for her
um they find like a bunch of stuff that
seems to indicate that maybe she was
kidnapped or maybe she was hurt in some
way but those all turned out to be not
related to the case like they found like
pieces of clothing and stuff like that
but it ended up being like unrelated
so then
um basically so the FBI comes in the
Georgia Bureau of Investigation comes in
this happened in Georgia in case I
didn't mention it and then you know this
there's this big hundred thousand dollar
reward for information blah blah
so a few days after she had vanished
uh Jennifer calls her fiance Mason from
a pay phone
and says
um I was kidnapped but they just
released me and she also called 9-1-1
but she called him first
and she said that she had been abducted
and sexually assaulted by a Hispanic man
and a white woman who were both in their
40s and they were driving a Blue Van
so the cops asked her well where did
these people go like after they dropped
you off and she said I don't she said I
have no idea I don't even know where I
am that's what she said
so they found her at a 7-Eleven in
Albuquerque New Mexico
um now at first like I said nobody
really doubted the story so her family
were like oh my God like maybe all the
stuff that we said in the news like to
bring her back and everything like that
maybe the kidnappers had a change of
heart and they just dropped her off or
whatever
however as the investigation went on as
will come as no surprise it turned out
that the woman had just had a little bit
of a freak out because she was getting
married and
she was having what they call the
premarital Jitters and she just decided
to nope out for a little while
and you know get a little bit of space
so she did it in the most obnoxious and
uh a woman getting pre-marital Jitters
yeah as if women have anything to lose
from Marriage
but it does happen to everybody well and
especially because and I don't know if
this was uh the case in her case but you
know especially if you're having like
the big basic [__] kind of wedding yeah
because you've got money because that's
a lot of money and it's like a lot of
planning like it's usually like some
people plan the [__] like a year year
and a half in advance she called it a
basic [__] wedding well you know what I
mean you're true yeah basic [__] yeah
you're just kind of like big elaborate
like which are nice and everything like
that but they're hugely hugely expensive
that's what I mean it's like if you give
the money to the couple there is your
money yeah it's like I don't I don't I'm
not averse to like having having a party
like celebrating it because that's cool
it's selling forty five thousand dollars
thirty thousand dollars yeah I don't
really get why you would piss away you
know because what's the average cost of
a wedding now thousands and thousands
yeah I think it might be 50 Grand or it
might be more than 50 Grand excuse me
but yeah it's like why would you better
just wait a couple money better to take
all that money just give it to the
couple why would you piss away that much
money I mean you could use that for so
many other things but um you know like I
said said I understand people won't have
a bit if you have the money fine but
it's just kind of like it's like it
seems like a waste rich people and I'm
not averse to like I said like having a
party and stuff like that but you don't
need to spend fifty thousand dollars to
have a good party you know what I mean
traditional [__] yeah so that's what
I mean so I so I don't know if that was
the case it's so it might have just been
the case it's like she'd spent like a
year a year and a half because there's a
lot of stress involved and I you know I
don't know I've never been through this
personally if this is the Americans
you're talking about chances are you're
only gonna be together for about eight
years anyway but well what's the average
I think it's average is like six to
eight years uh yeah I don't really know
offhand yeah but um you know and I you
know I don't know because I've never
been through this myself but I've had
friends that did this thing and they're
just kind of like it's it weddings kind
of like bring out a lot of the worst in
people like especially like the bride's
family the Grooms family they all want
to get involved and they want to tell
you what to do and all this other kind
of stuff so it's all the stress and it's
like we need to invite this person but
this person hates that person and then
there's gonna be a fight and it's just
kind of like so it's just like a big
ball of stress so I get it you know what
I mean so I don't know if it was
necessarily that she was just flipping
out that she was like oh my God I don't
know if I want to marry this dude which
maybe it was I don't really know but it
could have just been like a culmination
of all the [__] stress and everything
like that just kind of going on I had a
wedding and a wedding party and about a
half a dozen dozen friends all Goth
[__] had fun I was married for a year
Jen you were married for how many years
Jen 14 14 years that's a that's a long
marriage that's a that's for the United
States that's a full marriage
and me and Jen been together just in a
[__] boyfriend girlfriend
relationship going on 13 years now yeah
and I I like it
I think not being legally married helped
it because it was because we we both had
the option to walk at all times
yeah so it's not like we were being
forced together
and if we had problems we [__] fought
it out or talked it out
I mean in some ways I think it's good
like well particularly when you get
older because there's like a lot of
legal benefits but yeah and stuff like
that because you know it's a lot easier
like you know if something bad happens
to this person they have to go in home
or something like that then it's you
know it's just um so it's good to do
like in that situation I think it's
easier when we're when you're older yeah
yeah
everybody's more reasonable yeah less
less emotions and hormones involved I
guess I don't know although I'm [__]
hormonal as [__] I inject them that's
what I mean but like I don't know what
you're talking about people being
hormonal time now what it is
what it is is that you're young and dumb
and you have unrealistic expectations
about people and kind of yeah fantasy
idea about the way relationships are
it's not it's when you're older it's a
lot more chilled and laid back and a lot
more forgiving and I always say expect
the worst and then that way you're
always pleasantly surprised when someone
doesn't suck yeah just expect everyone
to sell well we were friends before
though yeah and like I said I you know I
wasn't really all that concerned that it
wasn't gonna work out yeah you know what
I mean we weren't really thinking about
it we just no we had to do yeah it was
it was very organic I mean yeah I mean
when me and Jim first started hanging
out we were dating other people I was
watching her date she was watching be
date we'd go on double dates together
with people yeah yeah
she'd be warning me don't go to that one
that [__] that one's a bad one I said I
know I'm still gonna [__] it though it's
just crazy [__] like that but you know
what I mean it was just it was Club life
yeah then we got together and people
were like well [__] finally
because we were all ready yeah like
staying over people at each other's
houses all the time we were always
together we were always together all the
time yeah well it wasn't the normal
thing we were partners
yeah so and everyone was just kind of
like yeah everybody else well I knew I
knew
part of it was I didn't want to [__] it
up
yeah you did tell me that because we did
actually have like long discussions
about yeah and that was Tom was like
really afraid that he was gonna it's
like I think is I like you and I I this
if I go out with you you're just gonna
[__] it up it didn't though no it didn't
but I could see why you were really
afraid that that would happen right
because you kind of had experience in
that regard so you kind of thought that
maybe that would happen but I thought it
would just [__] it up but it happily it
did not happen because we didn't stress
on it yeah
he wasn't stressed out yeah that's
probably didn't worry about it just let
things roll and we didn't change that
much
yeah
that's true and what's funny is that
I'll go back on YouTube and hear
relationship counselors and then they
say that's not not the kind of
relationship you need and then they
start talking about whatever long
longest or long-term relationship should
be and I go oh me and Jen
yeah because a lot of relationships are
just kind of artificial or they're
they're constructs in the minds of these
people you know I mean that's not the
way well I think a big problem too and
this is and I've done this too like
especially when I was younger and I
think this is something that a lot of
younger people do is that they'll get in
a relationship with someone but they're
almost in a relationship with their idea
of that person rather than what that
person is really like right and that's
very common like I said I've done it
like I yeah everyone I know has done and
because they're in love with the false
image of the other person they actually
love
to an extreme too much and then it's
self-defeating because that's an
illusion yeah because that's not really
that's what you want that person to be
that's not what they're really that's
what and people have known this since
[__] ancient times in that damn Romeo
and Juliet play the priest tells Romeo
and Juliet love moderately
and what he's talking about is that
if you're [__] blown out with your
[__] feelings it's because they're
not they're not based upon a real image
of the other ones yeah of of your mate
basically he was telling chill out get
along
yeah work it out as it goes well just
like know what that person is really
like and just love them as that like
don't construct not an idealized video
right right because I think that's a
real problem when I was young that's the
way I saw it well yeah I think everybody
does like I was like that when I was
younger everybody I knew was like that
to some extent unrealistic expectations
yeah you do liquid that's kind of like I
said that's kind of part of growing up
is yeah like a lot of people are like
yeah that priest was telling Romeo and
Joe to do that they were only 16. well
they were having unreal you know what I
mean you're gonna have unrealistic
expectations yeah and especially like
when you're a teenager and even into
your 20s like everything is a huge deal
like everything is like such a drama so
it's like it's actually kind of a relief
when you get older and you're just like
okay well most things really aren't that
big of a deal yeah like and I'm not
simpler easy to understand if you
[__] don't have well damn and I'm not
saying that and I'm not saying that you
love a person less because you're not
because it's not like this big Grand
thing or anything like that but you at
least have like a more realistic right
expectations of and and that's better
yeah it's a lot better right yes you're
not loving them less you're loving them
more accurately based upon what they're
based upon what the real is it's not a
fantasy love that can never exist right
that that which is always gonna like let
you always you're always going to be
disappointed because they're never gonna
live up they're not actually like that
right and then what happens is when you
get rid of those Illusions you start to
enjoy them before the way they really
are yeah and even all the imperfections
you go yeah that's cool too yes well
that's the best thing about it and like
I said I think that's one of the best
things too about getting older is that
yeah you actually learn that yeah and
you can be like yeah this person's not a
perfect person like nobody is a perfect
nobody is but it's like yeah you learn
to appreciate there even if they're
quote unquote flaws or whatever like you
look that's what makes them them makes
them unique right and a lot of times
their flaws we kind of become cute right
you go like okay and then you it's just
part of of it
relationship advice in the middle of a
damn kidnapping [__] show well it's
fake kidnapping yeah so it's okay and
like I said and we kind of did go off
the thing because she ran away from her
wedding you know Tammy said uh like Jen
said if anything happens medically she
can't be told legally yeah that is one
thing that's kind of a concern
especially like I said as you get older
she also said I was with my kid's dad
for 19 years and when he died legally
they never told me anything as he was
dying in the hospital had to have his
brothers control everything yeah that's
so that's kind of why you know it
probably does make sense when you get
older like and you're getting into a
stage where it's like oh you know
something medically bad like might
happen that it's probably better just
from a legal standpoint like you'll be
the first person they call and [__] like
that but it's like when you're younger I
don't think it's quite as important
I'm not saying that [__] can't happen
when you're young because it does but
you know what I mean I'm just saying
that it does make it easier like when
you get older and it's more likely that
[__] like that will happen
um but yeah so this chick just took off
and you know I can't be
some of these people like I can be mad
at like the dumb [__] that went and
probably went and cheated on his
girlfriend for two weeks and it was like
honey I got kidnapped you know what I
mean because that's some [__] right
there I can feel I can feel a little bit
more sympathy even though this is
obviously not the [__] way to go
about it but I can feel a little bit
more sympathy for people that just
stress out and then just like they don't
know what to do like obviously this is
probably the stupidest thing you could
probably do in that situation uh is to
fake an abduction but I get it like I
get that some people they just get
overwhelmed and it's just kind of like I
can't deal with this right now and they
decide to deal with it in like a really
stupid way admittedly but I get I
understand that like I'm a little bit
more sympathetic with that even though
yes they wasted everybody's time and
money and [__] like that but I don't
know I can't be too mad but if you just
kind of have a problem where like I said
you're just trying to get 375 dollars to
buy drugs or you know what I mean or you
just like wanted to go to a party and
you thought your wife wouldn't let you
go so you like staged a kid that's
[__] stupid but you know what I mean
like that's like a stupid stupid reason
375. that is still
400 is too much don't send that yeah I
just need 3007. I just need 375. that's
[__] funny I don't laugh my ass off
if I was a cop I would understand
this is fake as [__] this is fake [__]
this is not real yeah I mean
Tammy said her um
her her kids died he died at 45. she was
she was 40 years old yes I am so it kind
of happened yeah so it kind of happened
that's like wow that's [__] up uh
that's Tammy right yeah uh I don't
remember if she was American or
Australian I think she's American
wow and because of the laws she didn't
know what was going on only the brothers
knew yeah because she wasn't they
because they weren't legally married
they weren't legally married they don't
necessarily have to call you it had to
be it had to be in the family right yeah
okay so they would call your
your relatives you're next to Ken yeah
that's who they would call okay not your
quote unquote girlfriend that's right
yeah girlfriend's not no they wouldn't
call them yeah so um yeah but that's
that's really [__] young 45 holy [__]
man I passed that a few years ago yeah
which is crazy yeah it was almost 10
years ago for me yeah which is great but
I still looked like a kid at 45 though
yeah 38 I looked like I was in our 20s
yeah you did yeah
so I think that's well now because
I met you when I was 37 or 38 and you
were a couple years older yeah because
you're two or three years older I showed
up here at 28 or 38. to Florida okay so
I met you like probably a couple years
after yeah yeah so I was just 41 Maybe
yeah Tammy said uh yeah she's USA I'm
almost 55 now okay yeah so you're almost
same ages I'll be 51 next in uh
September right
so
but yeah uh so yeah so this woman
um said they found her and she was like
yeah okay I made it up um I just
couldn't take the stress or whatever and
she actually ended up going to a um like
a treatment facility like a mental
health kind of Center
um for a little while
um obviously broke off the engagement
um she did get charged I don't think she
got like a huge uh I'm she didn't get a
prison time or anything like that but
they did charge her with you know making
a false report to police and things like
that and um she said that she would
repay I believe she had to repay like
thirteen thousand dollars like uh cost
incurred like in the search for her [__]
like that
now uh about a year later she actually
sued
uh her you know former fiance for half a
million dollars saying that
um there I don't know it was like some
kind of convoluted thing where the
ex-fiancee had bought a house with
some kind of like I don't know if they
had some kind of book deal pending like
the a book that both of them wrote or
something like that and she was arguing
that the money that he used to buy the
house was actually kind of like both of
their money so she was entitled to some
of it or something like that so she
actually sued him for half a million
dollars
um and basically uh Mason who was you
know her ex-boyfriend he countersued her
but both of them ended up dropping the
lawsuits like later on that same year
now as I said when this case happened
back in 2005 and I kind of remember this
like it was a while back this was almost
20 years ago now but I do kind of
remember this being like in the news
like a kind of a big moment or whatever
and it was such a big deal it was like
you know all the late night talk shows
and [__] like that they were always like
making jokes about her
um and they actually I didn't remember
this but when I looked it up they said
that they actually made
uh like a toy company made an action
figure of her like with like a little
jogging suit on and like and she had
like this little towel over her head
because I guess that was kind of famous
that like that's when they found her she
had like this towel on her head or
whatever and uh so yeah they made like a
little action figure for like the
runaway brand and um there was also a
hot sauce named after her that was
called Jennifer's hightail and hot sauce
that had like a little I think it had
like a little picture of her like
running away so that was kind of a joke
for like a hot minute like I said so
that she kind of like ran away from her
wedding wasn't there that wasn't [__]
Julia Roberts in that movie Runaway
Bride
that's what I mean I can't stand
rom-coms yeah so
like I've heard of them peripherally but
I would never sit through them we saw
that one Ron come that was funny as [__]
though because it was that well yeah
because it was like a parody although it
was like a rom-com in its own right yeah
what was the name of that it was that
Wilson Phillips in it
um no uh
that was the band that was like yeah
what was that name yeah Rebel Wilson
Rebel Wilson yeah yeah what the [__] was
the name of that thing I can't ever
remember the name of it yeah it was
funny as [__] though yeah it was funny
it's good it was good well because like
I said it was almost kind of like it was
a rom-com like in its own right but it
was also like kind of making fun of
rom-coms it was like a parody but yeah
she like she woke up in like a rom-com
world so everything was like super
perfect like a Hallmark yeah like a
parallel universe yeah and like she was
like what the [__] is going on so yeah
it was like it was super funny but like
you could drop it in the comment section
what was that what was that I mean I'll
probably think of it like I even Rebel
Williams
yeah I can even picture the
um the title sequence yeah and the
poster yeah but I can't think of the
name of it it's not like not absolutely
fabulous but no that's sad yeah yeah it
was it was man I love absolutely
fabulous yeah now I want to watch
absolutely fabulous again yeah but yeah
that was funny but like I said I'm not
thank you Jeffy art sorry I'm late to
the game was getting my CPR
certification what did I miss our only
Super Chat of the day right thank you
very much
you missed a lot but that's okay you can
go back and listen to it again later
but yeah that's that's the thing I'm not
um I don't know I'm just not a romp
rom-com girl
the the tropes of them just kind of like
piss me off [__] these [__] too
slow I'm gonna go find it I'm gonna find
it
it's like it's right on the tip of my
[__] tongue it's right on the tip of
my song and I can't think of it and it's
like it's really bugging me like we saw
in the theater and it's and I was just
kind of like ah rom-com but then I was
like oh you know what that was actually
pretty funny
next Dimension media said I lived in
Duluth Georgia at the time of The
Runaway Bride that was just the local
police with nothing better to do uh
romantic that was it yeah
um Gwinnett County PD didn't care
because they knew she just ran away yeah
I the stuff that I read about it it did
imply that like the cops thought that
that was probably a distinct possibility
because they thought it was kind of
strange that she had just vanished like
like right before her wedding so they
thought that it was probably that but
like I said you can't I'm not skinny
yeah I know she looks cute I know she
looks cute she looks cute kitty okay
yeah I thought she had lost a bunch of
yeah I think she got um gastric bypass
yeah probably maybe
but yeah here I'll show you let me see
I don't know
oh yeah
she looks completely different it looks
completely different like her face looks
a little bit weird but yeah yeah I think
her face looked cuter when she was fat
she looks at a different woman she yeah
she looks completely different she looks
like I like her like that though she's
maybe had some work done I'm not really
sure but she might have some loose skin
yeah and at her age they just start
getting it but I mean she was still
pretty heavy when that movie came out
but I don't know I thought she still
looks cute in that movie and it's like I
don't know I think I thought she was
pretty funny in that and like I said I
liked the whole I liked the concept the
concept of it that if you wake up and
you're in a [__]
Hallmark [__] movie yeah the only
time that I will watch like parts of a
Hallmark movie is if um if you guys like
uh uh the Youtube channel um Nick
doramio like he'll every now and then
he'll like do like a breakdown of one of
those like real shitty
uh Hallmark movies like he does like a
lot of this like terrible trickly like
Christmas movies and stuff and that is
funny as [__] because he just like tears
him a new [__] isn't it romantic is
it chick flick that I would recommend to
dudes
because it was goofing on chick flicks
the dudes would laugh but it's still a
good movie it was like a feel-good movie
at the end I was like yeah yeah I liked
that one it was good it was a good
experience yeah you kind of like seeing
things through the fantasy eyes of a
woman
yeah but but what I like them want to
see dudes what I liked about it though
was that you saw it through her
character who knew all of it was
[__] yeah so it was almost kind of
like
two layers you know what I mean so you
could kind of like approach it right
right so I think that's what I liked
about it because that's kind of what I
would be like if I woke up in some
[__] Hallmark rom-com world or
something like that I'd be like what the
[__] is going like it would be super
weird I would recommend that movie to
all players so they can understand
how Normy chicks think
that's exactly how Normie chicks want
[__] to be yeah well
I don't know it's like I think that's
probably why I don't like rom-coms
because you're not an army chick right
because it's like none of this like all
of this just [__] just seems like creepy
or like too much trouble or I don't know
it's just I can't but it was a good
movie I can't deal with it but yeah I
did like that movie it wasn't making fun
of women in the end it kind of came back
around and it was like it was okay dude
it was just well yeah I didn't think it
was making fun of women at all it was
making fun of rom-com tropes and this is
what it was made which were based upon
women's fantasies right it was made that
would never happen yeah it was making
fun of that right which should be made
fun of honestly because like I said I
think it's kind of bad
to especially for like younger women and
I don't think this is such a problem
anymore because I don't know if like
younger women are watching that kind of
crap but um if you would watch that kind
of stuff when you were young like at a
real formidable age and like maybe you
thought that that was how things were
supposed to be or that's how you were
expecting [__] and I'm just like I hate
to tell you but shit's not good yeah
dudes are not liking it it's not gonna
work out like that yeah I don't like it
either but you know there's nothing you
can do about it really so uh yeah so
don't get your hopes up yeah dudes are
primitive
don't get your hopes up just lower your
standards lower your standard
mostly just being funny but kind of but
I do kind of mean it at the same time
well it's the same thing it's the same
thing dude
you're a four you're not getting that
eight with the [__] with the [__]
set of implants and the [__] you're
not gonna get that all right you're a
four
it's the same unrealistic expectation
yeah ever I do kind of feel like we're
particularly younger people and that
goes back to what we were talking about
before it's like a lot of people that's
one of the best things about getting
older is like you learn to temper your
expectations you don't have like these
wildly right
unrealistic like expectations of other
people you don't expect other people to
meet your every single need you don't
expect they're just like oh well I'm
gonna you know have this this person's
gonna be like perfect and everything
this man knows what I'm thinking right
you know because they don't they don't
have any idea nope
they don't even know what they're
thinking their exact time but they're
not thinking about anything
[Laughter]
because I think who was oh I you know
who it was it was um
Mike from MST yeah like he wrote a
couple of books and one book that he
wrote like just had like a bunch of
funny like essays that he had written
and he said one of the same things he's
like he's like yeah he's like I don't
get like my wife will ask me something
it's like what are you thinking he's
like most I'm a man like most of the
time we're not thinking anything he's
like most of the time we're just
thinking maybe I'll have a ham sandwich
or something like that it's just always
something like really really he's like
we're not thinking anything no more like
reacting
it's like so I'm just like so most of
the time I guess their their brain is
just kind of like oh yeah
that's kind of what I that's kind of
what I picked wakes up when you start
talking about machines and [__] you
know what I mean it does well see that's
kind of I mean I get that I know that
that's what it's like but it's kind of
hard for me to relate because like my
brain is just like going like little
crickets like all the [__] time like
just lighting up here and there and the
other thing so it's like it's hard for I
never like phase out
ever machines and numbers
yeah statistics
what is it well I have that going on
that's like over here but then there's
like 40 000 other things going on in
like the other so I can't imagine just
how long is this what does it weigh how
long is this what does it weigh what's
the [__] horsepower behind this
what's this what you know what's it's
just [__] like that it's comparative or
comparative analysis between which one
of these machines is better that that's
that's the essence of [__] men really
and then every now and then ooh ass yeah
ass
yeah actually probably Tom has that more
than more than yeah but I'm at one with
it though it's an art form to me now
it's not personal it's just art form the
judge the art of ass yeah
Jen look Jen brought that up because she
came home from work today to God damn
your ass is [__] popping Jen's ass is
getting [__] great she's working out
she's all gear and [__] she just lost
a lot of weight a little round spheres
in the back it's looking good you got
I'm gonna start taking pictures though
well we can take videos plus I got my
good flattering yoga pants that's a yoga
pants
he misses me when I'm at work all day
yeah
[Laughter]
chance making a comeback
I mean I didn't really go that far away
Jim's making a comeback
he's scratching his beard and he's
getting smug about it
[Laughter]
quits her job starts working from home
I have access 24 7.
that's what he want he wants me to be
here all the time so you can just jump
on it whenever yeah or like I said or we
could just jump on stream maybe whenever
stream yeah we work out we go to eat
be free again that'll be nice yeah I
know I'm really looking forward like I
said being free for the next five days
for sure yeah
yeah we can get all kind of stuff done
the way it used to be the way it used to
be back when back when when um YouTube
was kicking
killed YouTube
it never quite came back
everybody says that though it's not just
us yeah all the other all the other
channels
[__] man it just
everybody's broke Zach says don't forget
to buy a reinforced bed frame too yeah
we need to get another one we probably
should have we're gonna like not just
because it's that good well like I said
it was like a hand-me-down yeah we're
gonna get we're gonna get a [__]
another man we're gonna get company King
like last time it's not super
comfortable we used to have a California
king yeah that was [__] huge it was
massive it was like I would wake up and
he's he's way over there like I was in
another room
yeah holy [__] yeah I can barely see you
yeah what was the name of that thing it
was the air it had an air mattress yeah
it was the one it was like it was like
the Sleep Number thing but it was like
it wasn't Sleep Number like the brand
sleep number but it was another one like
that
I think it's so old
mattresses started spring and leaks that
had to go in there and [__] repair
them all the time yeah they were all
just starting to wear out and [__] like
that because every now and then you'd
wake up and like you'd be like oh my God
my [__] deflated and I had to make
another [__] patch and right
and then all the way Wood it's slowly
all the particle board in there it's
literally warped it started to look bad
I mean that [__] was old it was a little
and like I said and then the one we got
now we just got it as like a
hand-me-down yeah and it's all [__]
cheap it's not like super super used or
anything but it was like in the guest
room for a long time and then when when
we got rid of that other bed we just
like brought in the guest room one and I
was like man it's not super comfortable
we bought that one off it was a bargain
it was a bargain [__] bed so
Tammy says have to text each other from
the other side yeah it was it was that
it was that big I was just I was kind of
bummed out when we first got that bed
because I was like it's so big and
you're way over there yeah I was like I
just feel like I could roll over a
couple times for you guys like I feel
like you're sleeping in another room
yeah it's like I don't like that that
wasn't real good for sex though no it
wasn't because it was it was it was
[__] it was the air mattresses and it
was kind of like dipped in the middle
yeah and you're like
let's get on the floor
because I'm like this is just it felt
great to sleep in it though yeah yeah it
was really comfortable for sleeping but
for others
not so much she usually had to get up
like I said get the forget all the
Blackboard
[Laughter]
[__] scraped up knees and she like
that because yeah because of the carpet
tearing her ass up
around a [__] silk prayer rug cat
watching
yeah Pookie's weird about it not just me
man it's not just us
got videos from fans of them [__]
tearing down on their girlfriends and
the cats watch it also
cats are weird I keep like teasing
you're such a pervert Yeah we get videos
from fans
it's like a funny
the cat's watching so that's a universal
thing to have the Cat come in what the
[__] is going on here yeah it kind of
wears me out a little bit but it's like
get out of here what are you staring
that
Zack says there are actually a lot of
couples going back to separate beds
these days but for like practical
reasons yeah I've heard about people
that have like if one of one of them
snores or you know if they have like
different sleep schedules or something
yeah well I'm going to the man cave and
sleep to keep it from waking her up yeah
like we would do that sometimes because
he has like he doesn't have a bed in the
man cave but it's kind of like a little
futony kind of thing so it's like if
like if I had to get up really early and
like he didn't want to go to sleep yet
or something like that like he would go
in there so I could actually like go to
sleep yeah because he likes noise yeah I
gotta be have some noise in my ears and
I like quiet yeah and he doesn't mind
having lights on he can sleep with
lights on and I can't do that [__]
the louder and the lighter it is the
easier it is for me to fall see I can't
do that it's to me it has to be dark and
quiet and cold like that's why I have
like a column fan it just blows on me
like all the time because otherwise I
can't sleep it's too hot MX Airborne
infantry quiet and dark is danger
noise is safety that's where all the J
yeah that's why he has that yeah I mean
even now like he sleeps like you know
when we sleep
in the bed he he always has his earbuds
in yeah I have to have something and
he's out he always has something in here
I can't relax like that and I gotta find
it maybe they have it on YouTube the
most relaxing sound to me is jet turbine
wine
that will put me right to sleep I love
it interesting yeah it's because I
associate it with airfields right
because I mean I get that yeah airfields
was always post and pre-mission and the
Choppers and the aircraft and [__] are
all around and we're safe we're at the
Airfield there'd be thousands of us
[__] lying out there just [__]
zoned out sleeping
yeah it was just and because you're with
all your friends
and the aircraft are there and it's just
and you're in a rear area it's safe you
know what I mean [__] all this noise
there couldn't be danger yeah I got that
because there's too much they're just
just see what I'm kind of thinking and
maybe I got this from like you know when
I live by myself and stuff like that
it's like I like it to be quiet because
look if somebody is trying to like get
in my house I want to be able to hear
that [__] so I can like wake up and
[__] run your ass so it's like so I
want it to be quiet yeah so if there's a
weird noise I'm immediately awake and
being like what the [__] is that you
know what I mean if I if there's other
noises like I won't be able to hear it
it's like somebody sneak up on me yeah
well I was I don't know
I was from the first in the 506 up in
the DMZ in Korea when we're at Camp
Greaves some of you guys know what I'm
talking about and then I I was ended up
being in the 101st after that was over
101st Airborne Division was this first
327 Recon I was in a reconnaissance
platoon which is like a mini lures D
unit which is long-range surveillance
and reconnaissance units it's all about
slipping around and those in that era it
was all Vietnam style stuff
so combat was quiet everything was by
ambush
Ambush and catar Ambush Patrol so if it
was quiet it's because you were in field
and we would go days without actually
speaking sometimes depending on what was
going on
because you're moving or sleeping moving
sleep and moving sleeping and uh hand
arm signals and [__]
kind of missed those days you know once
once you do that kind of [__] you want
out of there at the time but then when
you're out of there all you do is think
about getting back to it
kind of changes it changes you forever I
think that's kind of true a lot of stuff
yeah
Hugo said I sleep with audiobooks on or
Rain Sound yeah I don't mind like I like
the sound of the fan yeah like I really
well I mean because it not only like
just cools me off like I said it's this
big tall column fan and I just have it
like pointing right at my face yeah um
because I can't like I said it's too hot
otherwise so I actually do like the
sound of that like just like a white
noise
type of yeah as long as it's not too
loud too loud it'll keep me here we go
for you Rain Sound yeah I like that one
too but one notch above that is gent
turbine
a [__] that whining jet turbine in
the distance [__] love it
it's like a white noise
yeah high pitched like I get that like
that but like I said I don't like it to
be so loud that it would drown out no
I'm not I'm not thinking of it
it doesn't if it's real loud it doesn't
it has to be kind of in the distance a
little bit right you know what I mean
just a high-pitched whining jet turbine
like the Jets a couple hundred meters
away and it's not
it's just idling
because they would do that they would
just sit there and just idle
yeah but they weren't powered up right
yeah yeah [__] loved it it's
addictive
I'll fall asleep instantly
well I'm sure somebody's got that on
YouTube there's all kind there's all
kind of like white noise and rain sounds
and all kind of stuff
and they have all that kind of stuff
like for specifically for people sleep
in so this is like a black screen and
it's just those sound of an airport well
obviously yeah they have that I know
they have that because I've seen it yeah
you know and like all ASMR and stuff
like that a lot of people go to sleep
like I said to those scary stories and
that's why they have ones that are like
three four hours long I don't go to
sleep to those because I get too
interested in them so it keeps me awake
because I'm just like oh it's gonna
happen now but um I do like those to
drive though like if I'm like when I'm
driving to work and back because you
know like I have an hour commute each
way
so sometimes I listen to music but a lot
of times lately
um I find it a lot less stressful
because I hate driving and I especially
hate driving
you know with the idiots that are
driving Florida so so it's very
stressful so I find that it's a lot less
stressful just listening to like
somebody reading creepy stories like it
chills me out more so I don't get as
because I'm like I don't know like
because I'm pretty chill on the show I
feel like but it's just kind of like if
you saw me behind the wheel I'm just
like a screaming impatient
what are you doing oh my God and it's
just like I just like flip the [__] out
like when everybody's because
everybody's just stupid and I can't take
it so it's just kind of like so it'd be
probably really funny it's just like
because I'm just like swearing and
screeching the whole time at like all
the idiots on the road so I found though
that listening to like scary stories
like be Buster or Mr nightmare or
somebody like that that it like chills
me out a lot more so I'm just kind of
like oh look at that [__] over there
you know what I mean it's like and I
don't get all [__]
I know I am like that because my dad was
like that
who I inherited for inherited from like
my my complete impatience like with
other people's idiocy like especially
when they're driving or when they're
walking I don't really like that either
but
I don't like people that are slow and I
don't like people that are like in the
way and I'm just kind of like
you know so that's the whole thing all
right so I think I only have a couple
more uh
kidnap people on here that I wanted to
talk about so we'll do that and then
maybe we can just like it's like I said
I don't have to go to work tomorrow so
which is kind of nice so we can just
hang out uh but yeah so one of the ones
uh that I wanted to talk about also
was actually and this girl was a
teenager Carol Sanchez
now what she did uh this happened in New
York she was 16 years old
and she decided I guess
that she didn't want to like I guess her
mom was planning on moving the family
back to Honduras
and I guess that the daughter didn't
want to go so she recruited two of her
friends to while her and her mom were
just like walking down the street like
running errands or something like that
she got two of her friends to like pull
up in a car next to them and like yank
her off the road and like pull her in
the car and like drive away with her so
obviously like her mom flipped the [__]
out as she would because she thought she
would have saw her 16 year old get
[__] abducted right in front of her
face but that actually didn't last too
long they did an amber alert and
everything
but uh it was really only like the next
day
um that they found her and she was fine
and they were like oh thank God and then
she's like oh by the way I staged this
whole thing because I didn't want to
move back to Honduras but I'm sure she
ended up moving back to Honduras anyway
also uh here's another one and actually
this
okay this maybe I can kind of see this
so This Woman her name was Hannah Potts
and she was a writer and she decided
that I guess maybe she wasn't as famous
a writer as she perhaps wanted to be so
she thought maybe a good thing to do
would be to fake a kidnapping so she was
pretty young she was 23. all she did she
was from Indiana and she um this was in
2020 and she actually just posted a
video on Facebook and said she was
kidnapped like she didn't really like
have any evidence or she didn't seemed
like she went Whole Hog with it or
anything like oh you know I'm gonna tie
myself up with duct tape or anything
um so it's like the video she just kind
of like talked about it
she said that somebody had come along
like in a maroon car and stuffed her in
the trunk and then drove her to
somewhere like an unknown location
and so then she said she got away
somehow and seriously she said this on
the video and she posted it to social
media she said she'd been held somewhere
like in this little room
like a single little room with one bulb
or something like that which like I said
seems very much like a movie
so I guess they took this seriously like
the cops did like the FBI got involved
everything like that
um and basically what happened was they
leaned on I think they did kind of think
there was something fishy about it so
they leaned on a friend of hers whose
name was Maria and they said
um yeah dude what do you know about that
like when did you last see her and all
this other kind of stuff Maria said yeah
I haven't seen her for like several days
and then I saw this video and blah blah
and they thought maybe that she knew
something so the cop said you know you
can really get in trouble for like
faking a kidnapping so if you do know
something about this you better say
something and so she um actually did
kind of break down and be like
um yeah basically Hannah just staged the
kidnapping and she went and hid in
Maria's basement so they went down to
the basement and she was she was down
there hiding and like for testing to be
[__] kidnapped and I guess she was
doing like I said I guess she was doing
it for publicity or
because she wanted to write a story
about it or something like that
so I don't know but yeah they did catch
her also here's this person and I think
this is the last one that I have yeah
yeah so this is the last one that I have
so this woman is named Dar Hetherington
now she was actually like kind of like a
city official in Alberta Canada like a
city councilor
and she
um actually had come to the U.S like
specifically Montana like she was on
some kind of it was some kind of
business trip or something like that
this happened back in 2003 so she came
to Montana for the business trip and she
disappeared
now three days later she turned up in
Las Vegas and said that she had been
abducted and sexually assaulted during
the three days that she had that she was
missing
um now she actually did
to her credit I don't know if I want to
say it that way but I'm just saying to
her credit she did actually set this up
quite um
quite well like more than some of the
other people I'm gonna say so she was
actually seemed like she was planning
this for a long time because what she
did was she started back in 2002 like a
year before she quote unquote got
abducted she actually set up a whole
like stalker situation
and she claimed that someone was
stalking her and leaving notes on her
front door and [__] like that so she had
actually like started setting all of
that up then when she disappeared from
Montana
she actually had a rental car full of
[__] that she had bought like on her
trip and she left it she like abandoned
it so it would look more legit you know
what I mean so she knew what she was
doing I guess
um but yeah so it turned out as they
looked into it that even the stalker
situation the person well okay first
thing the stalker [__] like the notes
and stuff that were left on her door she
wrote those
also it turned out that this person that
was supposedly the stalker was a dude
that she was having an affair with and
the two of them were kind of like
conspiring
uh to do this whole kidnapping thing now
I'm not really sure I think the whole
reason that she did this whole stock of
this person stalking me and then oh no I
Disappeared situation was just to cover
up the affair like she didn't want her
husband finding out about it or she
didn't want her constituents finding out
about it because she was a city council
person
so
again that seems a little
um what's the word I'm looking for that
seems like a little bit over the top how
old was she just to you know more or
less I don't know actually
it was kind of a famous case in Canada
at the time like I said this was 2003.
her husband knows she was fooling around
on him and like I said she probably
didn't want because she was kind of like
a public official so I guess she's not
the voters the voters to know either
so she thought it would be better I
guess but like I said she seemed like
she was planning this kind of [__] for a
long time because she set up this whole
stalking thing and she wasn't being
stalked as far as I know but she was
[__] around with somebody and all
this just so she could have a rendezvous
rendezvous with the lover I guess for a
little bit
I don't know how long they were together
to be honest so it's gee dumb that's
what I mean well like I said ever like
almost every other than the the few
people that we talked about that were
like obviously mentally ill or were just
really young and stupid it just seems
like most of the reasons are just like
why yeah like why would you go to that
much trouble yeah there's other ways
well yeah I mean there's much simpler
ways right it just it seems like and you
know like I said this is a very rare I
got a family emergency I gotta be gone
for I got my aunt watching such as she's
dying I'll be back in four days
okay honey you have a good one I mean
that's really all you had to do all
right staging a kidnapping I mean that
just seems like too much trouble right
I had to go see my good friend such and
such I grew up with her you have one of
your friends [__]
spot you
you know dudes do it all the time yeah
Angie I gotta go [__] [__] this dude
he's hot as [__] okay just tell my
husband I'm going over to your place all
right I'll be you know for three or four
days because you know for your [__]
wedding or whatever you know just some
stupid [__] will make up and you make
some [__] up and [__] you don't go to
Angie's house she goes to your
boyfriend's house
to me I don't know maybe it's just maybe
it's just because I'm older yeah but
even when I was younger I don't think I
would have gone to all the trouble just
for that like here's the thing like if
you are in a if you're like married to
somebody or like have a girlfriend or
boyfriend or whatever and you want to
[__] somebody else just break up with
that person and go [__] or you can ask
the person hey like or and you know
let's do with thrupple or whatever right
it's just that there's other options I'm
just saying that the whole rigmarole of
like having to sneak around and lie and
come up with all these stories it just
seems like too much trouble it's too
much trouble yeah it's not worth it
honey I'm gonna go [__] this dude
I'll be gone for about four days but you
know what you're gonna be able to [__]
some chicks for four days that's what I
mean it's like you know that's
at least that's
that's on brothel somewhere like I said
here here Ben here's some money go to
[__] Thailand for a week you know
it's [__] have fun
don't come back with any STD yeah well I
said no I'm just saying that it's like I
guess people aren't really open to
talking about that [__] but see you have
to because it's just kind of like look
even that
even if that's not the solution that you
come to right it's just to me it seems
dumb yeah there's ways you could work it
out like it before you even do anything
underhanded it's like look if you met
somebody and you were just kind of like
hey I wouldn't really want to [__] this
person but I'm in a relationship like
don't go [__] that person and then try
to like lie about it yeah you know what
I mean it's like you could go to your
you know you go to your boyfriend or
girlfriend and say hey I've met this
person I really [__] this person it's
like how do you feel about that and then
that person might say get the [__] out
yeah or they might say oh okay but I get
to [__] whoever you know what I mean you
don't know who it's gonna go I'm just
saying that it's just kind of like this
is the best yeah as long as everybody's
honest with everybody I will see the
thing is the problem is that people that
do that kind of stuff they want to have
their cake and eat it too yeah they want
to still have the the boyfriend or the
girlfriend but they also want this [__]
on the side from the girlfriend to be to
be loyal to them yeah so well yeah that
too but so they don't want to tell the
boyfriend or wife or husband or whoever
because they're afraid they're going to
leave which probably most of the time
they would
um you know when they found out about it
is this thing is just go to swingers
club man and [__] around with another
couple
yeah nobody's gonna run off with anybody
maybe probably not it could happen but
it could but it's less likely Tammy said
sooner or later the truth will come out
yeah that's what I mean it just seems
like too much effort for honestly like
not that much reward I just don't really
it just seems like no no dick is worth
that
honestly it's just dick that's what I
mean
it just seems like it's not worth it
we're talking on a superficial level
here okay we're just having fun in
reality let me back up and be a little
bit more professional about this oh
Tom's gonna be professional right
um just the way women are
if a woman's cheating on you
that relationship has been over for a
while yes that is generally true yeah I
mean not everyone's the same but in
general if a woman has gone to the
lengths yeah of cheating on you and was
like trying then that usually means over
that usually means she's got sick of you
a long time ago and it took her a long
time to finally talk herself yeah into
the spot where she's like you know I
could just yeah right that's usually how
that [__] goes yeah that's that's been
my experience see now now I said I'm
gonna get professional to see now you
now you got to back up off of it because
yeah you're right
yeah that's right women won't I I didn't
tell you you weren't right women will
only CH will only cheat if that
relationship's been over for a long time
usually generally yes I mean that's not
100 true because everybody's different
but in I think in the majority of cases
when women cheat that's usually right
yeah usually they've they've kind of
like decided Well you know this husband
and they'll usually stay with them for
other reasons because the kids or you
know Financial Security or whatever the
[__] yeah
um but it's like but I just can't stand
it you know I can't be around him
anymore so I have to like go and the
other the other option would be like my
ex later and her new husband
Tony who's also he's a friend of
Barcelona
um
they're in an open type relationship
they've been married they got married
they got married after they were in a
relationship yeah and it's um
but with that situation there
later was his Buy
uh I think Tony's kind of bi hard to say
I never really asked him I I always
thought he was yeah yeah I mean I never
asked him out right but I just and they
just kind of have fun and date
couples or singles
but it doesn't seem to affect them they
just kind of think it's fun I guess
they'll videotape it and [__] they they
also work online creators
that's their thing
yeah I guess
um
so that's another option but I don't
think that's for most people
yeah they're very special when you know
well like I said
um a lot of times people are
you know and I'm not [__] because
I'm not like that either so it's just
kind of like but I am like but we know
people like that so I'm actually kind of
more open to all the possibilities which
maybe I think like a lot of people
aren't and I think a lot of people still
have a hard time like talking to
um to their Partners about that kind of
stuff yeah
even though me and Jenna fooled around a
little bit with girls and [__] it
doesn't
we're real loyal to each other
yeah
anything that I'm doing or thinking I
basically tell Jen and she's the same
way with me you know what I mean but we
don't do [__] behind you we don't do
each other each other I just wouldn't do
that I'm not like that no and what kind
of and you're not like that no the only
thing that kind of I'm kind of like man
how can I was talking to Tony I was like
Tony man you did that [__] uh
he'll go out and date he'll go out to
the club with some of his girlfriends
and leave
his wife at home I guess
I was like she no she'd want to go
I was like nah
I could never go out with that go
anywhere without gin if I was dating
some girl
yeah Jim would definitely be with me
yeah because then she's sitting at home
going what are they doing oh yeah that's
what I'd be doing yeah I would never do
anything like that yeah no well I
wouldn't do anything like that either no
well like I said I'm just well the thing
about it is that we've been together so
long that it's just kind of like we're
almost like I told I told our friend
Dimitri one time I said it's almost like
he's like my arm or something like I
can't really like leave the house like
like I can obviously because I go to
work and I go other places but it's just
kind of like I don't know it's just like
feels weird like if you're not around
right
so it's because we were friends yeah
we were friends before we were uh an
item right part of it so
but no I I and so some of that [__] you
know what I mean [__] I I just yeah I
mean I would I wouldn't like that like I
said and I'm not sure like if it works
for them they don't seems it doesn't
seem to bother it doesn't bother them
and I know it doesn't bother some people
but it does bother me and yeah it's like
that would bother me and I wouldn't like
that yeah you stay home I'm gonna go
date this other kid we're gonna go on it
we're gonna go to the club I'll be back
later right it's like I would go to her
place after right are you gonna be
[__] sitting over here by yourself
going those [__] are [__]
over there in another house over here by
myself yeah I wouldn't like that I
didn't like that either that's what I
mean I wouldn't yeah and I wouldn't do
that to you because that would be shitty
no that would be shitty and like they
were in some wild [__] threesome and
that's different story Well everybody's
there because we're all there everybody
knows what's going on what's going on
and nobody's jealous because right
because no one's doing anything like I
said behind somebody else's back right
because that's the thing like even if
I'm kind of like the [__] the
kind of [__] that's like even if
I nobody's left out and that's right
like even if I know that you're going
and even if I well I know that he's
[__] that chick or something like
that I still don't like it no I don't
like that I don't like that idea no it
would be good no no so like I said I
know it doesn't bother some people but
it does bother me
you know it would all that [__] like
that only flies if if it's all all
together
and that's kind of rare to keep that
[__] going because it's just not
throuples are always temporary
somebody's got to have they always leave
yeah all the ones that we knew they were
doing that
doesn't really work out long term a
couple years
yeah
Yeah well yeah that's the thing it's
just like I said like various jealousies
involved there's because
you know having a couple that are
together for a long time that's you know
two personalities you have to kind of
like and that's three of them difficult
like three of them that like
exponentially like makes it more
difficult like all the Dynamics right
Brian and Becky the longest girlfriend
they ever had was about three or four
years
that last one I mean Brian and Becca
been together a very long time yeah and
it's not Brian it's Becky yeah Becky
likes girls yeah so they always have one
yeah at any given time yeah but they do
tend to have ones like for their years
yeah like for several years yeah and
then usually something will happen yeah
but yeah I don't know it's I don't know
like I said it's
again it just kind of seems like so much
trouble yeah
it seems like so much trouble
like that you don't really need to get
involved in but but they're friends you
know yeah I mean yeah it'd be it'd be
different in that situation but yeah
that's the thing no Brian Becky I I
think that that last one that was a
friend of theirs they were yeah
well I think that was true of like most
of them most of them yeah because like
some of them actually lived with them
for a while
but yeah so I don't know I I just kind
of feel like like I said I feel like we
wandered a little bit farther away from
like the fake kidnapping but not really
because they're talking about this
because they're talking about this kind
of [__] and we're talking about you know
the fact that you can't
you know it you can't go to a party or
you're lying to your girlfriend or
whatever about what you're doing and
it's like the fact that you have to
Stage a [__] kidnapping for whatever
reason right to avoid talking to her
about it or this gets back to me asking
how old was this woman because
if you go to the pros okay
male escorts and people that are in the
[__] swap scene and [__]
young people are limited in what they'll
do they'll get [__] pissed off it's
just in in swapping type scenes and [__]
it's always older people the kids are
now grown
they're not at the house anymore they're
kind of free from responsibilities and
then they're dating other other couples
but that but the families have fallen
apart that
the man the woman are not trying to
leave each other they love each other
it's just they're trying to have fun
that's most of it so it makes you wonder
what the [__] is up with this is this
young people [__] cheating on each
other and stabbing each other in the
back or I kind of feel like that's the
case in most of the situations because
otherwise why I mean like I said why
would that be and the weird thing is
like
if here's the weird thing the one dude
that was gone for two weeks yeah
and he evidently did not tell his
girlfriend where he was I'm like what
the [__] was his girlfriend doing that
whole time it's like where the [__]
[__] you leave for two weeks and
don't tell me where the [__] you are I'm
just gonna assume you're dead in a ditch
someplace yeah
and then comes back and it's just kind
of like oh I got kidnapped what the [__]
is that all about
and you know he was out [__] around
because why else would he make up that
story like that
so I don't know like hopefully those
that one and the and the dude with the
party that had his friends come over and
kidnap him from the house yeah so he
could go to the party I'm kind of hoping
those women like told him to get the
[__] out yeah and not come back yeah all
right this is that's only my first one
right yeah well I topped it up a little
bit oh okay so it's about a drink it's
my one and a half one yeah how much you
got left material that was it oh that
was it actually okay yeah if you drink
off off camera
yeah how long we've been streaming
um two hours and 32. okay then there you
go that's a show yeah
oh you ready to wrap it up if it's over
go ahead and wrap you know talk about
other stuff yeah you don't want to talk
about well if anybody want if we can
answer questions if there's any comments
we can respond to them well you could
get me another drink anyway
I mean it's 10 o'clock but I don't have
to go nowhere tomorrow that's true I'm
trying to like okay Mrs Evans already
party said oh dang just got here we
might sound a little bit longer like I
said after party yeah we'll have an
after party because I did cover all my
stuff but
but we were kind of getting into like
some interesting conversations which was
kind of related to the kidnapping [__]
because a lot of them [__] weird-ass
reasons I can almost see
faking a kidnapping to get Ransom money
I mean that's pretty because that's a
practical reason right I mean you're
like well I need a hundred thousand
dollars or whatever it is and it's like
I don't really I can't really think of a
way to get it I mean duh obviously
that's not like a really smart way to
get it but I can see how somebody might
come up with that
however just having a thing where it's
like oh well
you know like I said I didn't want to
tell my wife about that I was going to
this party or something like that I
there's just other ways of getting
around that
Zach says I just found a BG's Discord
server and they're doing listening
parties to their albums Zach you have
really gotten into the bgs and
I mean I have to I'm here for it I'm
here for it
I like the VG
you know what I mean I just think it's
so funny that like people are
we've talked about this before but I
think it's so funny that like um
music is like not seems like it's
absolutely not even generational anymore
like people are just like here's like 20
year olds that are like listening to
[__] from like the [__] 1970s and
[__] like that Tammy said forgot you
were on vacay tomorrow yeah like I'm off
until I don't have to go back to work
until Tuesday
so yeah I had three days paid three paid
days so I was like [__] it I'm taking
them
and then so we can do some streaming and
do some shoots video go to the movies
go eat some shrimp over at [__] uh go
to Ichiban go to Ichiban look at all the
fat people yeah we both got paid so
yeah well I don't get paid again until
Friday I got money yeah I got money but
I'll just I got a little bit I got a
streamate check but it was yeah a small
one because we were only on for an hour
or two
Zach said the I'm really into their 60s
stuff BG's they were doing psychedelic
Rock and Soul Back Then and it's damn
good yeah see they're a good band I
didn't appreciate them in the Bee Gees
oh yeah no the peaches were great yeah I
didn't appreciate that much in the 70s
and stuff because I was kind of like meh
I was like more in a new wave and stuff
but like now now that I'm like listening
to them with the
you know with the benefit of hindsight
like I'm like oh yeah they are actually
pretty [__] great they're pretty
[__] great
but yeah I'm just I'm
I'm super excited to be like off for
five five days
I don't even know what we're gonna do I
don't know what I'm gonna do with myself
I mean I've got
um
I'm gonna put some videos up I'm gonna
hopefully get my Night Gallery one done
because I watched
I'm on season two of Night Gallery
because I bought the uh the whole uh box
set
and I'm doing episodes
one through six of season two and I've
watched the first five and written it
all out so I just gotta watch one more
so hopefully I'll get that put up this
weekend and I want to do another movie
review too but I don't know what movie
it's gonna be yet
and we might go to a movie this weekend
like I said I want to see that movie uh
talk to me that new horror movie Tom
wants to see the Meg too but I don't
know if it started yet
so we're gonna we're gonna investigate
we'll see tomorrow like what started
Zach said it also helps they were real
good looking
they were yeah I mean they had a lot of
hair but everybody had a lot of hair in
the 70s it's funny because I was
watching Night Gallery last night and
one of the um
one of the segments
the episode that I watched had John
Carradine in it but John Carradine had
like a big ass beard and like big ass
long hair and stuff like that and he
really did look like a BG
BG's were what made the BG so good not
not only just was their music and their
singing really good they had [__]
fantastic lyrics
I don't know who was writing that [__]
but then you had a right I thought it
was very Gibb actually they knew how to
write and that dude knew how to write
lyrics to women
all right he he knew exactly what a
woman wanted to hear
they were kind of like the
like the female equivalent of [__]
Judas Priest because Rob Halford knew
what guys wanted to hear in those lyrics
it just it was it was pretty good
they're both great
Zach says Oh yeah talk to me is blowing
up like crazy at the moment yeah I
noticed I was like that horror movie
that I wanted to see okay I was like
yeah um I've noticed like pretty much
every horror Channel I follow has a
review of it and they all see and they
all look pretty happy about it yeah so
I've heard it was pretty scary so I want
to see how it goes it better be good
we'll see it'll probably be good I'm
talking about it's gonna be good yeah I
mean like I said I don't like to read
synopsis and I don't like to read
reviews before I go see a movie but when
I scroll through YouTube most of my you
know subscriptions are horror channels
so it's kind of hard to like avoid all
the thumbnails of people's facial
expressions and [__] like that so
Hugo said something uh I'm watching for
your Night Gallery review love that show
and the story of the people who work
there yeah
um like I said I'm on season two and I'm
doing the first six episodes of season
two so I've got I'm done with the first
five and then I just have to watch one
more and get that done a nice show it
should be going up this weekend sometime
it'll probably be long because
you know how I do like I get roll
I get real uh wordy about the [__]
[__]
and I might do another movie review this
week too for this weekend sometime if I
have time but we'll see how that goes
but yeah uh let me see
man I kind of gotta pee what do you what
do you um go ahead go ahead and do some
commercials then take a break
well you can talk for a little while I'm
gonna talk about
when have you ever had a trouble like
thinking of something to talk about
you're always okay
entertain the people in the restaurant
okay always leaving me by myself I gotta
entertain people you can even sit in the
in the captain no I'm good I'm I'm good
over here
I'm over here me and Spock me and Spock
but uh yeah we're gonna let her go to
the restroom I'm gonna sit here and
drink with y'all
let's see what everybody says what's
those Zach saying something to me
when you're drinking gin it looks like
lemonade yeah it's lemonade
uh lemonade that I made
and um vodka
the other day I made yogurt
in the instapot
and the yogurt separates into yogurt and
whey
and I saved that way
and I found different things to do it
that way
one of the things that I did with the
way is I made my pizza crust my pizza
dough with the Whey instead of water and
yeast instead of water and yeast well
you use the yeast culture but instead of
the water
add whey into it and man it makes a
awesome pizza dough
the pizza crust is great
I've been taking it that
and then I've been taking the way
and putting um
frozen berries that I had
I would candy them in sugar and and
lemon juice
and I put that into the whey
with a little bit of milk and blend it
with an immersion blender man that [__]
was good that that's my new uh proteins
right
there's yeah yeah here I am I understand
that [__] man
I can't understand this man at all
he doesn't understand I don't understand
it oh my goodness yeah
laughs
he said I do like these pants they're
both they're very flattering she's got
these stuck in Black Belt bell bottoms
that we got from Sheen no these ones are
old ones okay
they're still they look great this isn't
from Sheehan okay no I've had these a
long time okay you've just changed yeah
and that ass has changed
walking in here earlier today and I was
like damn those pants fit good yeah
these are my I have like three working
out man dudes I have like three or four
pairs of these they're like yoga pants
but they're yoga pants they fit like
yoga pants but they're like office pants
like you can wear them
to work and stuff too because they're
real thick but yeah yeah I really like
them I'm gonna tear that up
maybe not tonight I'm probably too
[__] up
I'll get around to it well again I'm
gonna put it on the list put it on the
list I'll put it on the list yeah well
okay thank you I'd appreciate it yeah
I'm looking forward to you being here
five days yeah me too yeah me too we'll
have fun
I know I'm looking for like I said I
don't even know what I'm gonna do with
myself all this I mean yeah I do we got
to get that Twitter hooked up I got it
done already I told you I'm gonna put
stuff on it yeah and then I'm gonna take
this and I'll move it here
oh yeah that's right you don't want that
do you I want that I know that way we
can get this shot over here yeah
okay that's gonna look good I know just
I'm we'll have to be very very careful
with it so we don't [__] we're gonna
take everything out of there and put it
over there we'll do it yeah and it'll be
a lot more uh
the space will look it will make a lot
more sense and if we want to get this
shot for 13 o'clock we can get something
else to put here
you know what I mean yeah to put the to
put the camera there to get this shot
but they might be might be time to have
a different background for 13 o'clock
for a while
yeah I mean it's a better same
background for more than a year yeah you
know
Tammy said what you all think do you
think it's time for a different backdrop
we got a real nice one over there
Gothic I'll show it to you right now
he's gonna pull that camera pull the
camera off here you can see his hand
yeah
look at that backdrop
just Gothic
curtains the Black Mirror back there I
can light that up a lot better
it would look really cool
behind us
now let's look at Jan's Booty like crazy
okay all right okay all right
you're so silly yeah
okay that's like way look what you did
go ahead and fix it then
look what you did it wasn't even They're
laughing at me
Tom's ridiculous
okay okay there it goes
yeah now we got this [__] chip yeah
all right
Tammy says I found a channel called a
great undertay king
the guys reviewing all of Stephen King's
books and their movies or TV shows based
on them
holy [__] I'm gonna have to I'm gonna
have to look that up
yeah Tammy says why don't you just use
one of your spare bedrooms through your
other show dress it up all sexy and such
they're not really spare well one of
them is a man cave yeah and that doesn't
gym and then the other one's a jam yeah
so
and then we went downstairs that's used
for something else so and then like the
living room up here it doesn't really it
does it's not suited to it
we could we have thought about
um shooting some stuff in the bedroom
yeah but we don't really have anything
on the wall the walls are painted like
Tom painted the walls like they're doing
some they're dark blue and stuff so they
look pretty but it's not like a real
interesting yeah there's no art up
there's no anything like that which like
we've lived here for like almost two
years
there was some big expensive when we
when we yeah there were
first thing I had to do is I had to buy
the lawnmower and all the lawn gear all
right I need a ride on lawn mower that
was like four grand all right
and then I had to put a new roof on the
place that was about 13 Grand yeah all
right otherwise they weren't going to
give us any homeowners insurance right
or you'd lose your insurance
what the [__] is happening man turkey
behind the behind that
yeah your face comes out
[Laughter]
he's on the curtains moving all weird
and he's like what the hell is that she
pops her little face out she's like hey
yeah I was back there the whole time it
took me
so this is where the computers are this
is where all the lights and the studio
equipment is so we just want to do it in
here we got a good backdrop and
everything you see look I got
a bunch of these too yeah lights yeah
got uh yeah we got a bunch of those and
we got we got a bunch of Big Ring lights
and then we have like on big trip on
this camera the new webcam that has a
ring light on it we gotta order that
I'll order it show me which one you're
looking at
I got the money for it I'll order it
okay I mean I don't have Amazon Prime we
could have it here by tomorrow yeah
I mean I I just looked at the one that
looked like it had like the most good
ratings and like came up on
lists of like you know best budget
cameras foreign
you guys said maybe you can do several
sets in the same room dressing up two or
three walls in the same room yeah we
thought about doing that it's just kind
of a pain in the ass to like move the
camera the laptop and [__] like that
like around all the time
because what we've been doing
for a while when we were doing streamate
we would actually pull
this off and put it over here so that
the curtains are in the background and
then we would just like do [__] on the
floor but that was kind of getting like
crazy yeah we were just like that was
like kind of uncomfortable and it was
just switch it like that yeah it wasn't
real versatile and then so now when we
do stream eight we just do it from here
like we would do this show
um but we just like back up so you can
see more
um and that seems to work out better
because we seem like one more
comfortable because we're used to
streaming from this area so it's not
weird and we're not crawling around on
the floor I just want to take this
computer this computer and this table
and move it there
which will shoot that way yeah we'll get
that wall and then we'll have a much
larger area to deal with because it's a
deeper shot yeah
and I can like that easily
it may be able to even permanently
install those lights
yeah that might be something so that way
we're doing too and then uh because this
background back here is good enough for
for um for the show I'm gonna Spock into
the shot or whatever
but there won't be any pictures yeah we
gotta have Spock in this room right
we could always change the camera back
somehow
um well that camera is on a thing the
thing is you're looking into that
computer right there so we need the
camera the computer in the same location
yeah because otherwise I'm going to be
really confused right
what we could do is get like a little uh
oh something almost kind of like a bar
or another desks or something put here
smaller desk
one of these
set this up over there yeah put the
laptop on it
yeah we could probably do that'd be the
better way to do it
we'll even leave that ring light
attached to the wall
we'll figure it out
I just want things to be
seamless right and easy so I don't have
to keep I just don't have to move
everything around all the time if this
was over here it would be and then we'd
have a wall here basically
so it would be like this would be a
studio area yeah and we can even take
you know all those books and [__] well
let's just move them over here if you
wanted to take that we could maybe
incorporate that as part of the wall I
don't know if you wanted more room there
yeah
yeah that might work out you know what I
mean yeah
because that I mean
I moved this stuff all around
a while back
it's just it's a big undertaking like
moving everything but no not for me
well it's not so much it's not well it's
not so much that it's just that I have
to take everything out like how to take
all the books out and take all that
stuff out
and then put it all back yeah in an hour
easily which is kind of a pain like I'm
doing it in an hour easily but you know
I'm just worried about the electric the
electric that's what I mean it's that
kind of [__] too it's like it's like a
[__] bird's nest over here it is like
cords and wires cores and wires like 40
million things yeah all of you guys
lights and cameras let me show you
various other things plugged in phone
chargers where's the light
okay I got a flashlight on my phone yeah
where's his phone it's right there it's
over there
don't knock it's right there it's right
there it's right there it's right there
it's right there no down it's right
there where the end of the corner
turn the light on perform
look and this is y'all right there
oh look at that it's going meta and [__]
look at that [__]
look at that [__] there is a printer
that's the printer the Wi-Fi thing
there's my postage scale yeah look at
Jenny's feet look at her feet you used
to be grossed out by your feet
grossed out by feet now he's all
undefeated a little cute feet I do have
cute feet I told you that before
he used to get all like [__] weird
and upset about my feet but no now
they're cute I guess which is in there
I'm trying to turn this flashlight off
okay
also because I guess we had like some
foot finishes on
on the three main show so yeah turning
up asking for various shoes and things
not so much foot fetish a shoe fetish
which you kind of have that too you like
yeah you like shoes yeah he started
trying to get me to talk about shoes he
wasted all our time because to talk
about his shoes the way shoes smelled
everybody's getting to her and you have
the cam management oh man stop it you're
not getting seasick
yeah he's gonna start like rocking it
back and forth now just to be an [__]
but yeah you can plug that back in who's
what is this what is this push the
camera back down you're getting the
ceiling in the shot
there you go
I'm pretty sure it was like that before
my mom just got a cell phone
for the first time yeah she she can't
manage it well you know what's funny is
like well I got a text from her like a
couple and I didn't know it was from her
but she just she sent a text and said
um just got a cell phone haven't quite
figured it out yet or something like
that and I was like that's my mom
there's more people on the [__]
stream now than there where we were
doing the show
that's [__] funny well you know
that's what happens when we start
talking about stuff like other than
other than the show other than the show
now everybody's like oh here we go yeah
what are we talking about now we're
going to talk about like some [__]
now we're gonna talk about dirty [__]
we're gonna talk about like [__]
giving relationship advice all that kind
of crap
[Laughter]
relationship advice lately
I've been watching a lot of those what
they call the uh videos out of the
[__] red pill Community with the the
big towel guys and some of the [__] that
they say is just [__] ridiculous well
you're [__] hilarious
everything's from the point of view of
guys in their 20s
that's that I guess that's who's making
it I don't know yeah probably and it's
just like they don't have much life
personally yeah I'm like yeah that
complaint you're saying is true but you
won't care about that in about 10 years
that's what I was thinking you know what
I mean like some of these guys have not
truly accepted the nature of what men
and women are and how they work
I just think it's funny
I don't watch any of that crap I don't
like to listen to dudes whining about
[__] like that
it's not really wine and it's just you
know I mean it's just
[Laughter]
whining
and well I mean the funny thing about it
is like that whole mgtow movement it's
like it's hilarious to me that they even
like thought that they would start a
movement men going their own way I'm
like okay bye yeah well they did bye
they did no one cares they did
don't let the dogs I actually actually I
think I think some people did because uh
a lot of uh young younger women on Tick
Tock are not complaining the guys won't
date them
so I think it did work but I think
they'll get older and they'll be like oh
why the [__] did I care about that yeah
I don't know but you're not an army
well yeah that's kind of another thing
you know you just date girls
you know what I mean the the [__]
Normie girls won't you know or nobody
yeah or nobody I just like never mind
I'll just sit home and read I don't need
any of this [__]
I'm just waiting for these dudes to
realize that they can just date other
dudes
yeah why don't they yeah
like I said I think girls girls seem a
lot more open to that yeah if I can
eventually even the thing is even even
women that wouldn't necessarily identify
yeah as
lesbian for example or even bisexual I
think if they met another woman that
they really connected with I think that
would be and they would be okay with it
but I but dudes are not they seem a
little bit more
um uh uptight in that regard
a lot more they're not desperate enough
you have to go it's not desperation
you got to look at you got to look at at
history
you can go back to Germany
1920s and 1930s during like the collapse
of the Weimar Republic
and the end of World War One
you had a whole new breed
of basically
paramilitary
political armies
they were malicious basically they
didn't have guns
but they were men's rights groups
the main one was the sa and the essay
was
run by
Ernst Rome
who ended up basically propelling the
the Nazis into power
and if you look at Ernst Rome was openly
gay he was just a predatory Warrior
homosexual all right and they were a
mgtow group
that promoted male Supremacy
a lot of it had to do with the fact that
because of the collapse of their society
a lot of the women had become
prostitutes so women were seen as
unworthy and dirty
and that men were more righteous
and this started to they started to
emulate things going back to Sparta and
ancient Greece
it was a basically a gay military men's
Rights group
and they were [__] violent real
violent
and it had to do with the imbalance of
[__] men to women and who is an
acceptable mate or not so the men
started to mate with each other
and started to basically embrace
masculinity is the and basically hyper
masculinity
as uh the [__] thing to go for in a
mate
so and that led to bad [__]
whenever there's a male female imbalance
and you've got a lot of these single men
that have no Prospect for mates they
always get violent if you look through
history it's uh rebellions revolutions
and religions
if you were to actually kind of analyze
the tenets of Islam it's coming from a
male Rebellion like the sa a rebellion
of male Supremacy where men are the now
the standard women are inferior their
only purpose is to give birth to other
men
and they basically Enslaved the women
so it's not good you gotta have to watch
on this [__] you know what I mean there
has to be a balance between men and
women it has to be a good relationship
between them well yeah but I mean that
wasn't what I was saying I was I was
saying that a lot of times if a woman
just ends up uh [__] this I'm going out
with another woman it's not necessarily
desperation it's just kind of like she
likes that better that's all I meant I
think men or in general
in in general men are wired I think for
for more
more for for heterosexuality it's more
of a primitive thing it's just getting
people pregnant they're they're pra
they're programmed for that
they're like that throughout all the
entire Animal Kingdom and humans are
animals which that upsets a lot of
people right on the right and the left
because there's religions involved on
the right and the left humans are
animals
I'm an animal TR an ex-animal trainer
among many other things in the horse
industry I don't see much difference
between human behavior and animal
behavior it's the same thing
um
so the men are not quite as Flex as
flexible yeah that's the word I was
looking for yeah they're not quite
they're not flexible
so it only happens in Mass when there's
like a desperation involved and it's
like a rebellion
when you have a massive men's Rebellion
you basically got a bunch of [__] rob
Halfords running around it becomes kind
of like the Damned pdsm type thing which
that goes back to
[__] some of the Greek city-states
were like that
you know there wouldn't be any statues
of women around it was all statues of
nude men and boys
women were considered to be ugly
this is not a healthy way to look at
people you know what I mean uh
there has to be a balance
if not then it [__] up with the
reproductive process of human beings and
people stop being born and that's what
happened to a lot of those Greek
city-states that were like that they
couldn't keep a population they they're
a popular their populations would
implode because they won't have enough
children
this is Evan's Arty party said from what
I understand the top 10 of guys on
dating sites get all the women that's
probably what fuels a lot of the Big
Town stuff yeah guys got to stay off the
dating sites and go into the real world
yeah that would help uh don't cold call
chicks either yeah for Christ's sake
please don't and don't talk to women on
the internet get to know them make them
laugh then ask them out yeah I do kind
of feel like it's probably better too
and I'm not saying that because a lot of
people have met their Partners online
and [__] like that but it's the worst I
think it's better I'm not a big fan of
dating sites I know that some people
like I never really use them to any
great degree when I was single but it's
just kind of like it's just it's a meat
market kind of situation I find that you
have better luck
um when you're not actively looking for
that kind of [__] I'm just saying like
even if it is online get into a group of
like [__] you're interested in like if
it was me it's like you know I'm into
horror movies and [__] like that you're
a lot more likely to meet somebody on
that because you know that you have
something in common yeah than just like
some dating site where you're basically
just like
shooting and like into the wind you know
what I mean yeah the dating side thing
is this
it's the worst possible situation for
men to be in is to be on a dating site
and really for the women too in a way if
they're trying to find a long-term
relationship or a husband type deal you
don't want that on a dating site you're
not gonna get that okay
in general yeah most of the time now I
know some people have but yeah
generally it's you know they're kind of
a [__] Jen
characterized it as a meat market that's
only partially true
there's a phenomenon called hypergamy
women like guys who are at least as good
as they are they don't date down
all right they they want to date up they
want a guy who's actually higher status
than them makes a little bit more money
than them is a little better looking
than them they want a guy that's hard to
get they don't want these easy guys they
don't even really want to appear
all right this is just a fact the
statistics say it not all women are like
that
but most of them
and that's been that way since hit
throughout history and throughout animal
history too because female animals are
exactly the same way they're going for
the males that put on the best display
the biggest males the ones that can
provide most meat because they're going
to make the best children and they're
going to get you through your pregnancy
then I'm gonna go for a [__] weak
bales
it's called hypergamy well on the dating
sites hypergamy is maximized
all the girls are fighting over the top
10 percent of the guys there and those
guys know it to the top ten percent so
what do they do they run through all
those women they don't [__] mate with
any of them they just [__] them and then
they just replace it with another one
over and over and over again because
they can so it's because they can
so the guys that were there that weren't
in the top 10 percent don't get what
they wanted they got passed over all
right
and then the girls that were trying to
find a good guy didn't get what they
wanted because the [__] the alpha
males just [__] [__] them and
[__] pumped and dumped them all right
nobody gets what they wanted in General
on those so don't do that meeting women
on the internet is the worst way worst
worst way
for me
as a man Club game
Club game if you're well anything that's
good in a club and [__] met a lot of
girls a lot of women well like I said it
was because and I mean our situation is
kind of different because the goth scene
is kind of its own thing you can get
known in it but well and I'm just saying
so the equivalent of that would be not
like regular nightclubs because Jesus
Christ but um that's a whole other Meat
Market yeah but just finding people if
you go to a golf club those are all
people that are into the same kind of
[__] as you so it's somebody that's
people that are into all the same kind
of [__] so I would always Advocate not
necessarily going out goal oriented like
trying to oh I'm going to find a
boyfriend or a girlfriend or whatever
but just going out it's like I'm gonna
go to this group that's talking about
this thing that I really that I'm really
into and maybe you'll end up meeting
somebody that's into the same kind of
[__] as you I just think that's like a
lot better strategy and dudes get [__]
up over the money looks and size yeah
that's all a factor but a dude could be
big he could be jacked he could have
money he could be good looking
but that's only getting him in the door
that woman might give him some attention
but then she gets to know him she didn't
like him yeah it won't sustain it just
gets him in the door anything all right
a lot of the successes I had back when I
was younger damn I wasn't shocked back
then it wasn't it didn't have anything
to do with that a lot of it had to do
with branding
I was the kind of Gothic guy that could
attract a certain kind of girl in the
golf club and that was enough
so what that means is is that that
should be if any of you young guys out
there listening it should be a message
of Hope
no matter really who you are you pretty
much
as long as you're branded properly you
can find appropriate mate
because even the dudes that are say
bigger better faster stronger richer
better looking than you even they're
striking out
yeah all right because maybe a lot of
times those dudes like you said can get
in the door faster they seem like
they're getting a lot more women and
maybe they are but a lot of women are
keeping them they're not keeping them
correct because maybe they're [__]
maybe they're cocky maybe they're
abusive maybe you know you don't know
yeah my advice is for you young guys if
you listen to this [__]
looks matter you know looks matter
because you're looking at the girls that
you like to look at well those girls are
looking at guys that they like to look
at
get fit that helps wear cool clothes
that are appropriate for you at least
look like you put like you're kind of
put together you can't be like other
dudes you gotta stand out they just
these women just don't like dudes that
just blend in
they don't they kind of stand out you
just gotta you got you gotta have some
kind of a bread
if you're gonna be a [__] Outlaw
Biker you better be a [__] badass
[__] hot Outlaw Biker
if you're gonna be a jock you better be
a good jock if you're gonna be a [__]
artist dude that's [__] with his
paintbrush and [__] you better be a hot
ass [__] artist women will go for all
that
yeah they'll go for all that as long as
it's a hot version of it and that's what
it's it's called I'm gonna call that
branding you have to have a the brand
has to be proper for you well and also
just be I think the problem that a lot
of the dudes have especially like the
ones that are like in cells and mgtows
and all that kind of [__] is that nobody
wants to be around somebody that's
constantly pissing and moaning yeah
about how much the world is not fair to
them and [__] like that nobody wants to
hang you don't want to hang out with
that person I don't want to hang out
whatever you got to be pause nobody
wants to hang out with that person
nobody wants to hang out with a person
that's just constantly whining all the
time you got to be positive you want to
hang out with somebody that's fun and
funny and it's like that you want to
hang out with you don't want to be with
somebody that's just complaining about
[__] all the time and it's negative all
the time exactly nobody wants to be
around and don't listen to what women
[__] say just don't
because women say all kinds of stupid
[__] if you go to a woman say what kind
of things I'm gonna tell you you're just
gonna make perfect sense it's going to
make perfect sense when I get done
you go to a woman and you say describe
your perfect man she's gonna say he's
gonna be six feet tall he's gonna have a
six pack he's gonna have six figures
he's gonna affect him she's gonna
[__] read off this [__] list right
that's [__] just she's talking about
the
half of the [__] one percent half of
the top one percent of all men go back
three months later and she's with a dude
that's nothing like she asked well I
told you nothing I've told you before
like why that happened yeah and it
happens like the other way the dudes get
caught up in that those women don't know
what they're talking about well it's not
so much that it's just that a lot of
times she just might meet you and like
you and all that other [__] [__] gets
thrown like I said you can't you can't
get too hung up on that because a lot of
times well I think people are saying
that because it's like they see it on
dating sites yeah I'm like you're on a
dating site there's no one in front of
you you're just having to write a
profile and they're asking you well what
do you want and it's just I don't know
it's just about this that the other
thing they're not really thinking about
a person and exactly specifically
exactly you're just like putting some
[__] up there like I don't know this
that and the other thing yeah so it's
that doesn't really mean anything she'll
go to a club and [__] oh he's cute
and the [__] looks like Egon
weighs 110 pounds all right nothing was
cute shut up yeah so you know what I
mean he's probably like young enough to
be my son yeah so it doesn't it doesn't
don't listen to what women to say they
just [__] they know it when they see
it
okay and that might be you so the thing
is though is that you got to have your
brand and you've got to be on game and
you got to have confidence and you gotta
know your [__] and uh you have to be
something you can't be
a faceless
nameless [__] Wallflower but don't be
try hard either I don't really like
people that are just kind of like look
how weird I am I don't like that either
most of the advice that I'm hearing
in the [__] red pill scene is is
correct it's sound their advice is stop
focusing on women focus on yourself
improve yourself well that's pretty much
the only thing that if they've ever said
that I could agree with yeah well no no
they say they say a lot they say a lot
of [__] you would agree with you just
haven't listened to them I have actually
yeah okay well they will just say
improve yourself because
[__] would if you or a girl would you
choose you
but see it's weird because I feel like
most dudes don't have the capacity to
like
well I'm not saying that dudes don't
have empathy like they do but I don't
think they they don't really seem to
especially if they're younger they seem
to have a hard time like looking at
themselves from someone else's yeah but
that okay look in the red pill scene
most of them are saying that improve
yourself
okay and then once you're something
you're gonna get people are gonna
[__] take notice well yeah that's
exactly you won't even have to like try
then because like I said I I think the
one thing that
um that they make a mistake on a lot
that a lot of people make a mistake on
is that they're trying they're trying
too hard and like I said if a dude comes
in a club and it's like very obviously
trying to pick women up and trying to be
a certain way like with lines and stuff
like that I mean that's very unappealing
um because they're being really obvious
and really try hard right and it's just
like not attractive right let me see
right through this it's kind of better
and I know how to be natural it's Gotta
Be You right yeah that's what I mean it
just kind of has so you kind of it only
comes with status and women or that's
what they're looking for status and it
doesn't mean their status doesn't
necessarily mean Rich no not a blue rich
guy right out of [__] water in those
clubs
Jenny's seen it they're blowing that
[__] right out of [__] water
because he doesn't have any [__]
status any style you know I mean you can
see what he is oh there's always one of
these
you know what I mean that's what I mean
it's like yeah having a lot of money
would be nice but it's like would you
really want to put up with that [__]
dude the rest of time just for that no
thanks
no no we gotta have some other [__] a
lot of women at least around here even
kind of the ones that are [__] semi
poor
at least in a golf club will just turn
their nose up on a dude like that you
know I mean a lot of goth girls were
born poor it doesn't [__] bother them
yeah they don't really I was like yeah
having a [__] sound of money be nice
putting up with your ass I'm used to not
having money yeah so it's like I'm not
putting up with a bunch of [__] yeah
and so I can buy a few more things yeah
these girls in the [__] Golf Club
will tell a [__] take you and
that Ferrari is shove it up your ass and
get the [__] out of it it's uh
absolutely well they don't give a [__] I
kind of feel like because goth kind of
came out of punk I guess yeah there is
kind of like an I don't I don't know if
I'd necessarily call it anti-rich but
yes there there is like a slightly like
not impressed by that kind of [__] right
Vibe Elon Musk had a golf girlfriend and
I think it's because she was anti she
didn't give a [__]
he just like her and she didn't give a
[__] he liked him and you know he
thought he was a cool dude making
Rockets
this is Evan's already party said look
for someone that wants to build
something with you instead of just
getting what you can from someone yeah
that's another thing too well you can't
just like look at another person as just
like well just trying to get everything
you can get the thing is Mrs already
party I've been in a lot of these dudes
shoes I've been 24 year olds before okay
that that concept is [__] far outside
their reach they're having a problem
these guys are having a problem just
talking to women much less anything else
they're having a problem even getting
some girl's attention
so they're they're have they're they're
at the very
beginning stages a lot of them are
failing and it's because I guess the way
a lot of these guys are raised now
depending on what state they're in
Florida seems to be doing fine I've seen
young guys they're about their [__] okay
in some of these states I think they're
mostly up north these dudes just don't
have any game
scared of girls
you know
Jeff yard said people can always pick up
when someone is comfortable in their own
skin rather than putting on the show I
think that's another thing too like any
time you're trying to like pretend to be
something that you're not I think most
people can like pick up on that and I
think that most people don't like it
another thing that dudes have to accept
even young dudes must accept this
life is a struggle
life is a struggle for survival just
like the struggle for survival in the
animal kingdom it's the exact same thing
there's going to be a certain amount of
casualties
nature doesn't select everybody there
are some men that just can't be saved
there are some women that just can't be
saved just to just
they drew a bad lot in life dark
statement very dark but some dudes are
just that's it
we I got friends
I know the pattern of life
I see how they're going I'm going that's
it he's never going to get another
girlfriend again get another girlfriend
again he's gonna die single you know
what I mean if if he goes along that
path and he's going along that path he
had uh Jenny knows what I'm talking
about because we talked about it before
he said he's over he used to get
cute little girlfriends but
he couldn't hold it together couldn't
hold himself together in a certain way
bad things happen to him and I would say
that's it he's done
it's sad but that's you can't save
everybody
you know I've talked to him I said you
need to get back up on your feet you
need to do this and that man start
coming back out again and it just well I
think to a to a degree I think people
need to have their own come to Jesus
moment yeah as far as that goes because
you can have other people give you
advice all day long but until you
actually get to that point in your life
where you're like holy [__] I need to
get my [__] together
um yourself you know I I kind of feel
like that and some people never come to
that sometimes beta got a beta and he
that motherfucker's bowing out I can
tell poor guy trying to try to help him
but some people can't be saved
he's got a [__] buckle down and
[__] stop what he's doing
snap out of it and make a comeback if
not because
Time Marches quickly
he'll be
45 or 50 soon
and it's a wrap for him
his dating options have dried up I mean
you just got to keep on keeping on you
know yeah
Hugo said what do you think makes a goth
person the clothes you wear or the music
you listen to or other uh it's other
It's a combination of those things
um the clothes and the [__] music
were almost all byproduct
I don't know I came to the music and the
look well I don't know if I want to say
that I think I came to the music first
although I don't really know if that's
the case I think what happened with me
was that I was always kind of like a
creepy spooky person yeah into that kind
of [__] and then I found out in the
early 80s that there was a whole like
sub-genre of music that was like that
and I was just kind of like oh neat like
that's for me goth music and got the
fashion appeal to a certain kind of
person yeah that's more like a that's
more like a product than them that's
what I was trying to say yeah it starts
with the person
and then they gravitate it's a certain
kind of mindset it's a certain kind of
aesthetic it's a certain kind of yeah
like I said it's a certain kind of
person it's the ability to embrace
and love things
that on the surface have a dark
aesthetic to them and a dark feeling and
realize that just because it's dark
doesn't mean it's something you should
run from that there's a good to it
you know it's not a
some a member of [__] people used to
old people when I was a kid used to see
God stuff and say oh that's satanic no I
remember that no no
their idea of Satanism was an inversion
of Christianity it's not an inversion of
Christianity it's not it's it's just a
different it's a way
of seeing Beauty in things
that are in saddened that's a good way
to put it yeah or things that are morbid
or things that people don't usually like
to think about in their daily life like
death and [__] it's very
Arthur schopenhauer you know would he uh
which is
pessimism but pessimism doesn't mean a
rejection of life you can embrace it too
you could go yeah there's an end there's
a beginning the middle and end but it's
all right I I accept that
right it's like an acceptance of death
of death life and death and you go it's
all good yeah yeah
and also like you said finding Beauty in
because I don't necessarily want to say
the grotesque although that might yeah I
guess finding Beauty in the grotesque
also
and things that maybe like I said peop
most people don't like to think about
it's almost kind of a Victorian View
of things
yeah in a certain way where you know
what I mean [__] it's not perfect but
it's okay it's in a way I think
old-fashioned Christians would say it's
accepting God's will you know it's the
way it's just the way it is and then you
love it love it the way it is and
honestly I kind of feel like most people
because I know that a lot of people
maybe not so much nowadays but like back
in the 90s and 2000s I think there were
like a lot of kids that like just went
through the phase and bloody blood
because it was kind of popular yeah and
that's not really what goth but that's
not really and that's why like a lot of
us old farts got so cranky about it it's
because if you know somebody if you you
know came up in that scene and stuff
like that and you know people in it most
of those people in it were
I want to say they're kind of like born
like that like it's a very particular
okay kind of uh mindset and most of the
people are just that's just what they're
like and they just were attracted to
this subculture because of that not the
other way around if you're a normie and
you want to know what the goth feel is
what goth feels are you can go on
YouTube and go look up A Band Called
Death in Rome
and they will take pop music that you
know and turn it in Gothic Neo folk in
the Death in June style and because
they've changed it that feeling you'll
see what I'm talking about but that's
the best emotional way to com
communicate to you what what the spirit
of goth was look at death in Rome
maybe look up a song that you know that
they might have in their catalog my
favorite is love is a battle Love is a
Battlefield they do a great version of
Love uh [__] they do uh [__] uh
Pump Up the Jam if I got a version of
Pump Up the Jam they did want to [__]
Barbie girl too yeah that Aqua song yeah
uh [__] it's unrecognizable yeah
you'll see there's a certain Gestalt to
it you're gonna like huh okay I like
that they make them like all Epic yeah
it's epic and it's kind of folk and it's
Germanic and it's [__] dark and it's
kind of it's so great yeah yeah real
serious yeah it's like not funny
and it's folky it's kind of like
it's Neo folk it's kind of like folk
horror like [__] yeah from uh [__]
what was the name of that [__] uh
mid-summer and [__] uh
[__] wicker man
Mrs Evan says what if you love creepy
spooky gothy stuff but hate black
clothes my kids call me a secret goth
well I mean that's fair enough
God swear other colors too it's just
that black is so slimming and it goes
with everything and usually I'm just
still attracted to like that if I go in
a store and like look at clothes I'm
almost always a try or red I'm really
into red also
She also asked uh Jenny do you have any
of those Victorian morning photography
books um so beautiful and cool I don't
have any of the books but I've seen a
lot of those photos and I really do like
that whole aesthetic that's one of my
favorite like I love all that Victorian
morning photography like all the weird
pictures they took of like the dead
babies and all that kind of stuff it's
like so creepy but it's just kind of
like once you know the context behind it
it's not I mean it's still creepy not
gonna lie but um but you know you
understand like why they did it so it's
not quite as weird I'm also really into
the whole aesthetic of
um like like late 19th century like
early 20th century spiritualism and like
all the Seance kind of stuff like all
that Spirit Photography they had I was
in um
New York one year is probably like
[__] 15 years ago now and at the Met
they had a um they had like an
installation that was all like like fake
like Seance photography from the
Victorian era and it was so [__] cool
like getting to see all this I mean
they're all fake obviously but um just
the way that they did like people with
ectoplasm coming out of their mouths and
stuff like that I love that kind of [__]
I love all that and it's just kind of
like I'm actually working on a um
like a card game now that's based around
that aesthetic a little bit
because I'm it's like all spiritualism
and Seance and stuff because I love that
kind of stuff
what murder Hornet said I tell my mom
everything
I know well I used to but uh anymore
[Laughter]
but yeah I do kind of feel like
um
I don't know it's it's hard to explain
like I said it's hard to explain
I do feel like people that aren't into
it or don't know much about it it's just
like any subculture it's like I'm sure
that anybody that's into any subculture
that I'm not into could say the same
thing
like you know a lot of people watch we
were kind of worried when that Netflix
show Wednesday came out which is a good
show actually I really liked it but um
I was like oh now we're gonna
we're gonna have all the people like
thinking that's goth now what's that so
Wednesday oh yeah which that was a good
show yeah a great show and she's got
she's got but God she doesn't like that
right and so like I get that like and
it's cool and I appreciate it and it's a
good show and everything like that but
it's just kind of like every time
something like that comes out like every
few years you have some like big thing
comes out that's sort of like goth
adjacent and then like everybody
suddenly like all the normies think they
understand goth culture now yeah and you
don't and then well that's what I mean
like I said and I was saying like while
you're in the bathroom I said it's just
like any subculture that I'm not a part
of but I don't go around like thinking
that I understand like other subcultures
and I'm not part part of I'm not gonna
like pretend I know like all about
whatever
if I don't know about that but for some
reason it does seem like a lot of people
want to I don't know I don't it's maybe
just because they find the whole God
thing fascinating and it's just kind of
like so they're always kind of like
I don't know man it's just like I always
like my whole entire life I've gotten
[__] yeah
okay look
this is death and Rome
foreign
[Laughter]
so that's what Gothic Pump Up the Jam
sounds like
they also did take on me they do take on
me they got all and Careless Whisper
yeah yeah all the great [__] 80s
classics
I'm trying to think of like the other
songs like I said love was a battlefield
yeah but yeah it's just Gothic covers
oh they're talking about ask a mortician
that's a great [__] Channel
love is a bathroom
yeah and said she did a show on uh
spirit Photography in another funeral
photography I think I saw the funeral
photography one but I haven't seen the
spirit of Photography one I'll have to
look that up
because I really do like her she's super
funny
murder Hornet said Ministry Stigmata I
love that [__] song honestly like
even nowadays and when did that [__]
song come out in
1988 1986
mine's a terrible thing to taste I
thought it was yeah
that's not that early that was mine I
thought it was 88.
yeah maybe I think it was 88. uh new
world order came out in like [__] 92
I think right yeah or 90. yeah well
because Stigmata came out when I still
lived at my grandma's house and I was
watching because I used to see it on 120
Minutes
all the time
and I was how old was I I was still in
high school I think
pretty sure so I think it was 88. yeah
that song came out and it's like
nowadays
they could play that song at a golf club
nowadays and you will still every single
time you will get a mosh pit
yeah every single time
so could you guys actually hear um Death
in June or uh death and Rome when I
played it
I don't know if I don't know if the
microphone picked it up or not
this is Evan's already party said Return
to Oz turned me into a goth at eight
years old I found my tribe oh my God
Return to Oz I did a thing on my scare
Salon Channel about that [__] little
farooza box she was only 11 years old
cute as a book when she was in the cute
as a bug they ran into her at a at a
convention or a Convention of here yeah
I can I didn't really recognize her she
was standing right behind me when I was
getting coffee
I thought she still looked
pretty much the same she's so skinny
well yeah that's what she looked pretty
much the same
but yeah she does horror cons and stuff
like that
Tammy said she could hear it yeah okay
yeah okay you should listen to that song
it's great the microphone doesn't do its
Justice and that tablet of course is my
in mono yeah
they played at the club when I show up
because they know I like it yeah pretty
much every time we go to mannequin it's
like yeah Paul vain will play I'll pay
it for me because he knows Tom's about
I'm going to dance and he plays it early
I'll be the only one out there
because everyone else like what the [__]
is this like what my song is that yeah
murder Hornet said I think I need more
vodka but I can't walk what's wrong with
this foot he keeps saying like
something's wrong with his foot he said
he's got a surgery today oh yeah the
city had an out-of-body experience what
today yeah
from the anesthesia
and he wasn't really sure when he woke
up and I was trying to tell him he said
yeah when you woke up out of anesthesia
you woke up in the car but you had been
talking to me for an hour which would
freaked me out when you told me about it
I was like really I don't remember any
of that yeah he thought he woke up late
I remember waking up in the chair for a
second because I remember saying man
it's freezing cold in here yeah and I
remember like I remember being really
cold and I remember them putting a
blanket on me but then I don't remember
anything until I was getting in the car
yeah murder harness said that he uh
during the surgery he was in a dark
place there were people around him
staring at him
spinning around him and he was in a
place and I said yeah you were in one of
the lower levels
I've seen those before when I went had
out-of-body experiences it's like a hell
but not a not a burning hell type of
deal no pain it's just one of the one of
the places that you can go to it's like
a frequency you can go to where there's
just kind of like there's a very low
energy
and uh spooky
but you can come out of there you just
[__] go up into a higher frequency
there's no way I say it sounds [__]
crazy people don't they're like what do
you mean go up
it's Dimension with inside within
Dimension within dimension
when you're out of body
in both times when I was out of body I
had a spontaneous Out of Body Experience
when I was in the Army and then later on
I had a near-death experience and in
both times it was always
in a higher Realm
a white ball of light with a bunch of
singing
and I knew that if you went into that it
felt like singing it doesn't doesn't
really sound like singing it just feels
like singing in joy and it's like a big
welding Arc
and if you go in that you never come
back out you
you just you're just dissolved into a
sea of Consciousness kind of lose your
identity
it's what the Greeks called the pleuroma
it's what this Jedi and [__] Star
Wars are calling becoming one with the
force
you can't come back except Qui-Gon
figured out a way to come back
so so there must be a way to come back
it's just that
it's normally I think you come back
through reincarnation
that's just my theory because I don't
believe you have one life
I believe you have a multitude of them
life is kind of a universal thing and
it's Evolution you probably start off as
[__] single-celled organisms and
animals and worms and [__] and you come
up into higher Realms of Consciousness
into higher more advanced creatures to
experience
life for the fun of it really
because I was under the ex under the
impression when I was
when I was out of body
that all of this was basically for fun
that it's not real serious
even all the horrible things that happen
it's kind of like horrible things that
happen in a video game it's not that
serious
we're just watching a movie basically
and we're selecting what movie we want
to see
that's that's what it seemed like
yeah murderer said I thought I died
yeah let me get another almost wise
sure
let's talk about NWO that's a good song
too
I like their earlier [__] though not
their real early [__] I'm not really
into like [__]
uh
uh [__] every day is Halloween and
all that I'm kind of really over that so
really over that though
but yeah
I was I was always more I'm more of a of
a goth Rock and death Rock and post-punk
person than I am an industrial person
you know what I mean I like a lot of
industrial but
my favorite [__] is all
postpunk or Josh rocker [__] like that
you know so I like Ministry but
I don't love Ministry you know what I
mean
like I think I only bought one or two of
their albums and skinny puppy same thing
this is Evan's already party said I like
horror punk I do as well
I do as well
um
you know who I really like and I've
actually only got one of their albums
but I really dug it I don't know if
you'd necessarily call it horror Punk
it's kind of like
I don't know I guess that they're
usually classified as but they're called
um the mission creeps I don't know if
you've ever heard of them but they
almost kind of like I don't want to say
it's like country but it's almost kind
of like old school
like sort of Outlaw kind of stuff but
it's
I guess they're kind of classified as
Psychobilly a little bit but it's not
exactly like Psychobilly
but I don't know I really like them but
I have like one of their albums and I
really like it a lot I listen to it all
the time
and who's that other like horror punk
band that's really good that I liked
um
zombina and the skeletones I like them
and
[__] the horror Pops I like that
yeah I like a lot of that kind of stuff
I have to walk to get more booze can't
you like call drizzly or something and
have them like freeze up
to happen today have drizzly where you
live this is what I like I was big in a
switchblade Symphony
yeah that's it let's see if it's just
waiting out okay there we go
90s
yeah
they were called switchblade Symphony
they're gone now
as Tina root she's now a real estate
agent
which is kind of depressing yeah she got
married
well that doesn't have to mean anything
she got married and
but they were a gray band I was just
always one of those [__] even
when I was like younger I was like I
just never want to be a normal person
here
it just sounded like the worst thing in
the world to me
yeah y'all gonna get slapped with
copyright [__] well Tom clearly does not
care I clearly do not give a [__] I mean
it won't pick it up yeah it will it
always does
I don't think that is even copyrighted
yes it is it is yes it is I don't think
uh I don't think
um what you call it was
death in Rome I don't think it's
copyrighted oh I'll get one yeah you
think so yep I'm sure I will it always
happens every time you do that show
really yeah
they demonetize this [__] yep damn yep
[__] YouTube you keep doing it and
[__] YouTube
it [__] sucks man
well everybody got to get their cut yeah
everybody's gonna get their cut every
[__] YouTube sucks
yeah but it recognizes it how quickly
usually by the next day like I'll get it
how many seconds does it need
oh I don't know
even with poor audio quality yeah damn
yeah it used to not be that good
well no but like I said the ai's got a
lot better
so now you just like put a few seconds
of a recognizable song in there and
they're gonna
they don't necessarily demonetize it but
what they'll do is they'll make you
share
the um ad Revenue with whoever is on
right is what usually happens yeah which
means they get five sets yeah or some
[__] like that yeah that's what it
usually ends up happening so you usually
have to split the ad Revenue because I
remember that song yeah that was clown
yeah
switchblade Symphony clown
yeah they were cool I had all their
albums yeah I feel like they weren't
around that long no
they made a big impact like in the scene
but they weren't around that one yeah I
saw him live at uh
uh man rays in Boston
they were cool because they hung out
with everybody
I never did get to see them actually
yeah not that I remember I met him real
quick but they were just hanging out
with everybody in the whole crowd and
later on I heard in an interview Tina
said uh yeah the best she was like the
best goth scene we've seen was in uh
Boston and Man Ray
just it was fantastic
and uh so she gave us she gave us the
[__] thumbs up it was a good seed
back then if that club's gone now
well a lot of that shit's gone I mean
although I mean there's still a lot of
clubs around nowadays yeah I think the
best club in the United States right now
hands down would probably be the castle
yeah that's I mean we haven't been in a
while but that's the best golf club in
the country I think probably yeah I mean
just the building is cool yeah the whole
vibe about it is cool it's uh I haven't
been in a couple years but it's renowned
throughout the United States
now used to be [__] [__] like the vault
in the bat cave and everything up in New
York but I think they got clubs but you
just don't I mean when last time I was
there which is maybe about 10 years ago
I guess now looking back on it maybe not
that long
it was before me and you were together
so I guess it was probably more than 13
years yeah it must have been so um
I showed up that [__] and I was
a [__] most fantastic goth in the
whole [__] club I was [__] shocked
those [__] didn't have any damn
money
clothes sucked well I told you that
um back in
2009 2010 something like that and I went
to New York and I went to the drop dead
Festival which is all death Rock
and it was in it was at the Knitting
Factory which is a three story so they
had like the top two floors were bands
and then the bottom floor was like a
club like a club it was like DJ's like a
million different bands they have like
old ones and new ones skeletal family
was there Lena lovage
um they had [__] uh Cinema strange
who I was really excited about because I
really like them
um just tons and tons of [__] and that
was amazing they had a huge huge turnout
and like I said it was all death Rock
people so they came from like all over
the world pretty much and everybody was
just dressed to the [__] Hill man and
everybody had made their own [__] our
boy up in New York would know which club
I'm talking about
I I went to the pyramid I think it was
called The Pyramid club and there was
another one I think it was called the
pyramid
um this is over 10 years ago it wasn't
it wasn't as good as the castle
but maybe it's changed now I don't know
yeah I mean I haven't been to New York
and yeah a long time
but I mean I used to go every year or so
for a while
and like I said I went to the drop dead
Festival two or three years in a row and
that was always really fun but
I mean I heard there were some good ones
out in California too they used to have
like some good ones but I don't know if
they're still there or not yeah
but yeah I mean the castle is still
there Castle's been going for
how long the [__] how long is that
show oh man [__] 40 years huh no well
30 maybe 30. yeah
yeah when did that [__] [__] start
it's been around for a long see if I can
find some videos of the castle I got
videos of me and you at the castle on
YouTube oh yeah that's right I forgot
yeah
like I said it's been a while since
we've been yeah a couple years but we
went to the vampire ball
a couple years back
but
we have been in a while
it is a cool place though
I'm just you know I'm sad we don't have
uh well I mean we still have independent
bar but it's not called independent bar
anymore and it's not at the same
building anymore
which is kind of a bummer I do kind of
like the the new location just because
it's
off the Beaten Track which is nice I've
seen that's the inside of the castle
2022.
I don't know what's going on in there is
that that's is that the dungeon no
that's the stage stage girls doing
something that's the stage in the main
Dance Floor room yeah they're putting on
some kind of show
okay see if I can see that
they're putting on some kind of show I
don't know what it is
that's just the kind of [__] they do
that might have been the fetish ball
yeah
Maybe
yeah it's probably the Finish ball
that's what it looks like yeah
I gotta look for the vampire ball
man we went to that it was like
it was like 40 million [__] people in
there
I mean it's a big place but you could
barely walk in the [__] there were so
many people here's a vampire ball from
seven years ago
we were probably there
was that the one we went to I don't
remember
I don't remember if that's what we went
to or not I didn't think of the one we
went to was that long ago but it's
possible
that it could have been
not real sure
yeah
it's a dance floor
Sam
see what's going on here
foreign
can't really see it through the video
but it's got a lot of like
everything's brick and it looks like it
is a castle and it has stained glass
windows yeah
well it used to be didn't it used to be
like a cigar Factory or I know it was a
[__] it was a temple
or like or yeah that's right it was a
like Ebor used to be they used to make
cigars down there yeah
so there's a lot of the buildings down
there used to be cigar factories yeah
but I think that was a masonic lodge
Masonic Lodge yeah it was a masonic
temps I think what that building used to
be
because I think they left some of the
or some brickwork in the front there's
the crowd
oh look there's a what's her name oh
yeah
what's her name again
[__] I haven't seen her yeah yeah I
don't think we've seen her since that
this is a long time yeah
murder Hornet said I made a video in
Mexico and a car was blasting a Mexican
song and I got a copyright thing yeah
I'm telling you you can't put anything
in the [__] [__] Zach says random as
[__] but is it weird I'm thinking of
converting to Judaism is it because you
think Jewish guys are cute is that the
only thing yes it is you try because
yeah the castle is there that's Igor
City it's a [__] party it's like the
it's like the [__] New Orleans of uh
uh yeah newborn city is the New Orleans
of Florida
basically I mean they call it eboard
it's Tampa but it's champ Ybor City they
call it that because that's like the the
historical name for it like I said
that's where the all the cigar factories
were and [__] like that like back in the
day
you done yeah oh okay I wasn't sure that
was just I was waiting for you to like
put more [__] up no that's why so I can
move
everybody's buzzing murder harness says
he's buzzed
feel like I can walk but I know it's a
false sense of security yeah we still
got a lot of people in yeah I mean don't
like go walking around because I know
what you know you kind of get drunk and
you're like yeah I can [__] do it and
then you're like oh I couldn't do it
yeah don't do that
Zach says yes I do think Jewish dudes
are hot that's yeah but I also just
think the culture is cool and I like the
people and sense of community I mean if
you want to it's entirely up to you be
honest Zach you like dudes that are cut
that's all it is you just like dudes
that are cut
although I kind of feel like that's not
a huge issue in the United States
because don't they [__] I don't know
how they do it nowadays but it's just
like I thought they just like um
I thought they just cut everybody unless
you told them not to yeah they did me
yeah they did me when I was a kid that's
what I thought but I just kind of I
don't know I don't [__] with Zach it's
just I don't know about nowadays no no
I'm kind of curious like anybody that
has had sons in recent years I'd be
curious because I've thought for a while
yeah I thought they just did it
automatically Without Really asking like
unless you specifically told them not to
I heard it was that they started that
[__] basically just because all the
doctors were Jewish
and then it was just an automatic thing
that they did it might be true
well I don't yeah I never heard that but
it's just kind of like I don't know that
was just like made sense a lot of Jewish
doctors
and they just said yeah it's more
sanitary if I can cut them
which it may be
you could probably get some dick cheese
and [__] the thing about it though is
that I mean every not that I've looked
at every study on that but I have like
looked at some studies because I was
kind of curious about it and there
really is no biblical answer to that
Jenny curious about the dick no I'm just
saying they're really because I well I I
thought it was interesting it's like
really they just like cut four skins off
without like asking anybody that seems
kind of [__] up yeah so I was kind of
interested in that and I was just kind
of like as far as I know like the
Studies have shown it's like they there
really doesn't there's no definitely
much difference yeah why not
or they can't really like see any
difference from the studies that they've
done I wouldn't know any difference
well that's what I mean and that's the
thing I think it's a little bit weird
because it just seems like a weird thing
to do to a baby when they don't really
have any
say in the matter like I said if you
want to do a little Old Testament [__]
that's what I mean but like I said any
anything
okay look I'm an atheist all right so
it's like anything you do just like for
religious reason you don't have a reason
I'm so you just don't have a reason
you're keeping the Covenant man
that's not a reason
give me a good reason it looks good give
me a good reason it looks good
well that depends doesn't it that
depends on what people think I guess
right that's what I mean that's that's a
that's a subjective subjective judgment
yeah so it's just kind of like if the
only look I'm if the only reason you
have for doing something is a religious
reason as far as I'm concerned you don't
have a reason you come up with a better
reason than that
what do you select well Mrs Hammond said
I agree Jenny we didn't cut our sun he's
fine no problems
really and the weird thing about it is
that I've known people that had sons and
like you know I don't ask them about
that kind of [__] but like if they talk
about that kind of stuff there's like
well we didn't really want to but we did
because we thought that well his dad was
cut so we thought that he'd think it was
weird like if he looked different from
his dad and we didn't want to give him a
complex Tammy which I get that but
it's just I don't know it just seems
kind of a strange Tammy said no you have
to sign papers to get it done okay well
I guess they do it different now than
they used to then that's probably by
state though but she yeah it might be
right she said at least when I had my
son in New Jersey in 1990 yeah so yeah
probably each state was different it's
just that but I heard I was just kind of
like oh we're just gonna do it if you
don't say anything we're just gonna do
it I was actually born in California it
was automatic
that's see that's what I thought like I
said it seems like nowadays that seems
like something that they wouldn't do
yeah like without asking you it was just
considered part of the birthing process
like right removing the biblical cord
right and that's what I thought yeah
like my impression was that in Most
states they would just do it unless you
specifically said hey don't do that but
like I said nowadays with the way [__]
is it does seem a weird thing to do
without asking
people you know like they're like okay
well
you at least some [__] in the time that
I was born at least in California it was
considered
it was considered more hygienic that you
would have like less infections and
spread less venereal disease and like I
said that's not even like that has not
been it could because right but from
every study that they've done it doesn't
really matter well the thing is is that
people aren't as [__] loaded up with
VD as they used to be so maybe well
that's true maybe in the past that would
have been yeah maybe it was better the
past because everyone was filthy because
you're diving deep off in some chick's
ass right and then you pop out and the
[__] foreskin [__] seals that [__]
right in there right and then you jump
in her friend's [__] ass or her cooch
and then all of a sudden you've now
[__] spread the disease some kind of
weird disease
you know what I mean that's what they
were worried about oh that's what they
were worried about was was that actually
happening maybe I don't know well if
everybody wasn't so grossed yeah
I'm sure they were gross I'm sure then
we wouldn't have this problem it had to
do with [__] being gross
yeah and like I said that's some [__]
you need to sort out and if you weren't
circumcised maybe it protected you a
little bit from being gross
it might have helped back then because I
don't [__]
totally discount
old school ancient practices I do
no I can go back to like you can look at
this you can you can look at Islam okay
Islam is a good [__]
is a good example because most
westerners don't have any vest a vested
interest in his Islam it's an alien
moral system
Islam and even Judaism said don't eat
pork
that would have been good advice at the
time that that was given because
they didn't know how to take care of
pigs so they all had [__] [__] like
shift of psomiasis and stuff you know
trick knows this
I think is what it was called trignosis
so eating pork back in the old days yeah
it was probably [__] quite dangerous
you get parasites from that
but nowadays we know how to raise pigs
you know yeah we'll see that's why
that's why I'm not super down with that
because it's like the weird thing about
it is that they came up with all these
rules some of them they just pulled
right out of their ass but some of them
they came up with for you know probably
legitimate reasons at the time the time
right um but then they couched them in
religious terms but the thing about it
is that the circumstances that cause
them to come up with that in the first
place are not relevant anymore so it's
just kind of like okay but I think I
don't really see the point of the thing
is though is that you're saying it was
couched in religious terms in Islam not
quite
because Islam is not a religion like
Christianity Christianity is definitely
a Roman religion there's a bunch of
weird [__] in there that is Roman okay
most of it has to do with and there's a
lot of gnosticism in there in other
words how you think can make you clean
that thinking like that
Islam wasn't really like that as Islam
was law
it was a part of a legal system and a
lot of it was based upon marriage and
safety and [__] like that
so not quite the same tenor behind it if
you know what I'm talking about
if you get get what I'm saying
in other words I'm saying is that
Christianity when you say religion
you're saying the word religion from a
Christian or Western mindset where
there's a lot of spiritualism and
spiritism and Supernatural stuff
happening in Christianity not so much in
Islam most of Islam is just it's just
law
you know I mean it's not claiming to be
anything Supernatural
and you know be like saying don't put
your [__] pie out
on the [__] windowsill on [__]
Sunday
there's a law they had laws like that it
made sense at the time it doesn't make a
sense now
you know it's like that
that's what I mean I don't think so any
laws they came up with back then even
though you know just tangentially they
might be like good ideas still yeah a
lot of them are not good ideas because
we don't have the same context as back
then the culture is different yeah
completely different so it's just kind
of like looking back to some ancient
time like they knew better than we know
or [__] like that it's like that is that
is a stupid stupid thing to think it's
just stupid
yeah well the world is completely
different than it was back then and
honestly like a lot of the laws they
came up with back then are just
meaningless to us because the world is
completely different mostly I'd agree
mostly yeah yeah that's what I'm saying
yeah
like some of them we don't even have the
context for what the [__] they were even
talking about yeah you know what I mean
so it's it's always better it's always
better to stay flexible and be like look
what's the situation on the ground right
now what is the best way we can deal
with this right now yeah you can look
back at like some [__] in the past what
worked in the past that's always good to
do
um but you have to keep in mind like the
context of the past too it's like look
all these situations were different back
then than they are right now so how can
we mitigate that and come up with some
plan that would work better for what's
going on yeah right now here's a good
example of what Jenny's talking about
if you look at the marriage laws say
original marriage laws and say Old
Testament stuff Judaism Christianity
Islam
marriage laws today sent to us from
westerners sound very
kind of outdated
but you had to imagine
these laws are being prescribed back
then to people who were 12 13 years old
and they didn't have long lifespans
so being married for life that did that
wasn't a big tall order
5000 years ago three thousand years ago
four thousand a thousand years ago that
wasn't a tall order they didn't live
that long they got married early they
didn't live that long sorry the reason I
laughed was because I just thought of a
line of dialogue from
I think it was Saint Elmo's Fire where
Andrew McCarthy says something like you
know marriage laws were come up with
when people were lucky to make it to 30
without getting eaten by times
well another sense like I mean he was
obviously joking but yeah that made me
laugh yeah that's what I thought of when
you said well another thing is that
a lot of people in the western sphere
are looking at religion through the lens
of Christianity
and modern Christianity is basically
full of [__] it's nothing like what old
Christianity was
example when it comes to marriage loss
Christians of today would say man is
between a marriage and a woman
or if you actually go back into the
scriptures says no it was not between a
man and a woman marriage is between a
man a man and a woman a woman and a
woman and a woman and a woman
it was between a man a woman who knew
that the Mormons had it right they had a
rough time is it in a man a woman her
handmaidens her female servants uh
[__] there's a lot of [__] so there
was no
there was no yeah that shit's not in the
Bible yeah they only say that like
because they don't like they because
they think Gay's getting married is Icky
that's the only reason they say that
yeah yeah that shit's not the Bible uh
it's in the Old Testament it's not in
the New Testament even if it was in the
Old Testament it's like still I was
always what I said before applies [__]
that's in a thousands year old book is
not relevant I was always I was always
under the impression we read Saint
Thomas of Aquinas
is that Christianity was gay friendly
there were gays were writing a lot of
that stay away from women that kind of
[__] real Christians don't get involved
with women
to
real Christians are monks it's just men
amongst other men doing manly manly
things these are gays
probably yeah probably
maybe they are
[__] um
I'm not gonna say just because they're
gay they're [__] everybody they might
have actually been it's a monastery they
might have been celibate it might have
been gays that said we're not gonna have
sex anymore
they have that
might have been something like that but
no real heterosexual man is going to
want to be a priest under those
conditions
crazy well that's why a lot of priests
are kind of [__] up yeah
no because nobody wants they were gays
nobody wants to do that gotta be they've
got it now they've got other issues some
of them might have been some of them
might have been
uh what do you call it
what do you call it when you don't have
sex
celibate you just said it yeah yeah
that's it I'm drinking they might be
celibate but I think they were gay I
don't think any straight guy would have
anything to do with that
the [__] no I'm gonna give me some [__]
you know that's that was the thinking of
everything you got to be elevating
yourself above it yeah come on get out
of here
guys aren't going to fall for I'm gonna
go for that [__] and [__] history
kind of sense a lot of them weren't
weren't going for that they had
girlfriends too they were the nuns yeah
there's a lot of that but I think I
think originally it these are Greeks
it's all the writings in Greek and these
are Greek dudes you know what I mean and
they'd come from along
history of what what the grease called
pedestry and homosexuality and that that
was religiously Sanctified under the old
Greek religions you know that that was
like a higher it's above the [__]
carnal desires of Base desires between
men and women we're we're going for some
spiritual sex here you know what I mean
that that's what they were doing man
going back to you uh I got behind on
some of the comments uh talking about
circumcision uh Mrs Evans already party
said hubs is cut never been with uncut
just couldn't do that to my sweet new
baby because she said that yeah I don't
blame you um that's kind of a weird
thing to do with baby
um and she said they definitely ask now
well that actually makes me happy
because I don't like the idea of like
like hey let's cut some [__] off your
baby without like asking you that seemed
like really [__] up to me
um but yeah and then Tammy said
for me personally it doesn't matter uh
I've had both and it's all good yeah
same
um I've I've
had sex with both cutting uncut and it
really did not make a single bit of
difference I did not notice any
difference so
just saying
I I really don't it really doesn't
matter one way or the other to be honest
but but to me I always thought it was
like kind of weird
to do that to a baby like it seems like
kind of a big thing to do to a baby
without like
asking about it and even then it just
seems like
that baby can't really pick and to be
fair I don't really like because you
know there was a there was a time I
don't know if they do this I don't think
they do this anymore but
there was a kind of a little bit of a
mini Trend in the 80s 90s I want to say
for like people having babies like girl
babies and then like having their ears
pierced like as soon as they were born
like when they were still newborns and I
was like I was like
that's kind of [__] up you know what I
mean it's just kind of like look if they
want to get their ears pierced you can
wait till you're like uh you know old
enough to say hey I want my ears pierced
like like a normal person like it seems
really weird to do to a baby like why
would you want to cause a baby
trauma for something that's like not
that's just like
you know cosmetic like they're aesthetic
like that why would you want to do that
I don't know it just seems really weird
to me
it just seems very weird why would you
want to cause unnecessary pain just
where something is
useless as that it's just it's dumb
yeah Mrs Evans already said son is 14
now we've told him if he ever wants it
done we would support him he's never
been interested it's actually sealed
when they're little so it wasn't hard uh
to deal with diapering yeah so yeah
that's the thing it's like it that just
seems like definitely a decision you
should make for yourself like when
you're older like because you have the
decision taken away from you
which just seems really weird you talk
about circumcisions yeah I think the
only difference just looks
I think well like I said but if so if
that's the only difference then it seems
to me like pointless to cause a baby
like pain unnecessary pain I don't
remember anything well no I'm just
saying that it's like I wouldn't want to
do that baby it's a body modification
a body modification should be something
that you undertake yourself when you're
old enough to make that decision for
your own self it shouldn't be made for
you yeah like I'm not gonna disagree
with you and I think it's just kind of I
mean unless there's some kind of like
medical issue that you need to have
something done obviously but if it's
just something cosmetic like I think
it's cosmetic that's what I mean it's
just that seems like really pointless
like you're just pointlessly probably
doing some [__] to a baby well when you
were in the other thing I said there was
a thing where
sometimes like people would have girl
babies and they'd have their ears
pierced when they were babies why the
[__] would you do that it's lat it's
Latin it's a Latin tradition but that's
what it's like that's so like why would
you do that because she's gonna have
earrings when she's older anymore right
but it's like so wait till she gets
older like and she could you know the
baby's like one it's unnecessary pain to
the baby two like the baby can like pull
them out because it's a baby they don't
do it though you know what I mean it's
just I don't know it's just in Mexico
they're born it just seems pointless to
me well you guys understand Latin and
South American cultures when I was
living in Brazil
I mean
eight-year-old girls wore high heels
which I don't think they'd do that here
but an eight-year-old
Brazilian girl could go at a full run
and [__] high heels
down the [__] Street and with a purse
they had high heels and purses at about
eight nine
everything was uh
everything was uh I'm a big big girl you
know what I mean it was all
training to be a woman
well that's not that weird because it's
like makeup I remember well yeah I
remember when I was a little girl I
wasn't super into it but I had some of
the stuff where it's like they give you
little makeup sets and little little
play Princess yeah high heels and [__]
like that I had some of that [__] it
wasn't my favorite [__] because I wasn't
super good really girly but you know
what I mean yeah so it's not that weird
like they have it here too yeah but
it's just like I said I don't really
know like something like ear piercing
and something like that I think that
should definitely be something I think
Brazilian girls wear their ears were
pierced by the time they were 10. well
that's not that strange because mine
were too but like I said that's old
enough to make their own decision
because like somebody said Tammy said
yeah my hub's daughter took her new baby
to get her ears pierced just a few
months ago I let my daughter decide when
she was five and then Mrs Evans already
party said didn't Pierce our daughters
and ears until she was eight yeah I
think I was
I was probably
eight or nine I think my um my aunt did
ear piercing
and she did them
so because I really wanted them done
so so yeah but that's I mean that's old
enough to like know yeah you want yours
because it's not super super painful
yeah you know it's not like a big huge
thing or anything you're not getting
your [__]
you're not getting other body parts
pierced
you know what I mean that's that I did
so uh yeah
Jeff Harris said I believe piercing
should be a rite of passage in my
opinion yeah I mean they definitely are
in some ways but I definitely think you
should be old enough to like
I don't think you have to be like an
adult but you could be a kid that was
just kind of like yeah I just wrote I
want my ears pierced that's not weird
but a baby they can't decide anything
for themselves that's weird
yeah Jeff yard said piercings and
tattoos are a form of personal
expression and thereby should be a
choice yeah that's what I mean so I
think if you're taking that choice away
from somebody and like ear piercing it's
not like a huge big deal because you can
just like take them out and they'll grow
over and stuff but it just does seem
like an unnecessary it just seems
unnecessary
because the baby doesn't care you're
just putting them there because you
think it looks cute you know what I mean
and that seems like a weird way to
[__] go about like hey look my baby
has pierced ears you know baby doesn't
give a [__]
Zach says I saw a vid once where a dude
had his taint pierced ouch yeah yeah
I've seen those 10 years I've seen girls
with that yeah yeah on video yeah that's
a real not in real life but in video
soon I can't imagine although
it'd be easy to do no I'm not saying
that I'm just saying that it I don't
think it'd be painful don't get me wrong
I don't think it would be as painful as
the nipple piercing yeah she was [__]
rough doing that
I mean and honestly the nipple piercing
that wasn't even the worst pain I ever
experienced
I mean it's bad but it wasn't the worst
pain I've ever well it's over with
but
I gotta get new ones because
I was in uh the shower the other night
in my because I have like a whole bunch
of different ones but my favorite ones
are like the silver ones because they're
the longest and they were the ones that
he put in first and I was in the shower
and one of the the balls on the barbell
fell out and it started going down the
drain and I was like no no no like I
tried to stop at my foot and it went on
the train yeah there's no way to get it
back so there's nowhere to get it back
but there's they have a set on Amazon
and I think it's only 12 and it's six
pairs okay seven pairs and they're
they're silver black like kind of a cool
like bluish like oily
kind of look to it there's ones with
like kind of crystals on the end
they have some really Kick-Ass ones like
on Amazon they're not hugely expensive I
want to put rings in there with captured
Ball but there's a tool I need to get
that to get those in there yeah let's
get them hard to do because you gotta
I'm just the only thing that is I like
the look of the Rings better than the
barbells but the only thing that I'm
afraid of is that particularly like if
we're streaming and stuff like that is
that they're gonna get caught
on my tights or something like that and
it's gonna like ring won't do that Rings
won't do that because there's nothing to
catch
it's round
the bars will do that before anything
else
a ring won't get caught
oh it'll find it trust me we'll say
where are these no it's a straight bar
with bars on the end some can easily
catch around that
on the other one would be harder
I want to see if there's another way
to get the look of a captured ring with
captured Ball but without using the
captured ball as the ceiling
there may be a way where there's a ring
with an open spot in it like a hinge
yeah it'd be easier to get it into the
piercing and shut it and it's easier to
to remove
to remove and replace so you could
change them yeah because I like to just
want to capture balls in that's it it's
gonna be in there
until you [__] remove it you gotta
bend it
right I don't love that and I because I
like to be able to change them out my
vision isn't that good and my hands are
[__] I got big sausage fingers it's
hard to [__] get that ball because
then the ball has two indentations in it
where the
where the ring closes in and grabs it
see and you need a tool to do that to
keep it round there's a there's a ring
tool for that
we have them but I I tried to bend it up
and tried to bend it back it would even
my hands my fingers were not strong
enough to bend that ring back yeah I
don't like that and I would never be
able to get it done and [__] get the
ball captured at the same time it's
fiddly super fiddly that shit's rotating
so I wanna maybe like a fake captured
ball
yeah someone has a trap door
because I mean I've just been using the
barbells because I have like a bunch of
different ones of those like a bunch of
different colors Rings look better I
know but it's like I said it's just kind
of a pain in the ass
Mrs Evans already party said daughter's
always losing the ball from her nose
ring this was actually the first one
that I lost which shocks me
yeah and it's kind of pisses me off
because that was like the best
uh the best pair that I had we got more
people in here now we had during the
show
yeah it's all ridiculous good because
it's getting later he's getting later
here
super chats are active people if you
want to send us a Super Chat we could
use we only had one all night and if
you're listening to recorded we also
have super thanks activated I think it's
some kind of little icon it's a button
it's a little button you can press you
can give us a tip listening to our
recorded show
yeah Mrs Evans already party said we're
all off work yeah
it's weird because I mean to me it feels
like Friday night because not only
because we're talking about stuff other
than the show but also because I don't
have to she didn't work tomorrow so it
feels like we're gonna have fun for the
next five days so I have to keep
thinking that it's like oh no it's just
now you're gonna put your notice in
you're gonna quit
yeah eventually and then we're gonna be
ho we're gonna be hoes online
we've already been at hoes online we had
all
got all kinds of fun experiences [__]
with these [__] man on [__]
streammates hilarious
but you know it's nothing like I thought
it was going to be
it's nothing like I thought it was gonna
be
the clientele is just normal guys
and um they're having fun and
they don't really you know
I kind of thought it would be some pervy
skeevy [__] no man these dudes
that turned their camera on are [__]
fine
that one dude that we turned his camera
on could have competed in an ifbb male
fitness competition he was doing [__]
push-ups while he's jerking it and
[__] putting on a show and waving and
laughing and [__] was funny man
um we had all kinds of
dudes that were on there that were a
trip
I don't know if they're bi or straight
or whatever we don't really care we just
put on a show and
talk to them and they just
kind of regular guys so far thank you
very much who is that this is Evans
already party thank you very much says
great conversation guys thank you
Zach says I always thought face
piercings look kind of weird though my
sister has one of those little studs on
the side of her nostril and it looks
pretty cute
yeah the thing nowadays is like that um
that rape that thing that goes across
there
you know what I mean like piercings on
that side
I'm kind of thinking about that but I
don't know if it would look good on me
or not oh the one with a little chain
yeah I can do it let me see
it might look good sounds like he's not
sure if he looks good because my nose is
big I don't know it's hard to say we'd
have to mock it up and see if it was
good that's what I mean just draw it on
there with a marker and I have to see
where where it would have to go in
look at me again
I don't know I don't know where it would
go in I don't know if I want to go
through another yeah
piercing situation would you would you
be more comfortable if somebody else did
it
no okay
that's a that's a very small gauge
needle though that's Yeah well yeah it's
very I was gonna say like after the
nipple piercing it's probably like
everything else is gonna be nothing
compared to that be like me giving
myself injections
yeah that [__] like I said I have a
high pain tolerance and even that it's
not the most painful thing I ever
experienced I'm not saying that but it's
just it's up there it was top five
that's for sure I got uncomfortable
yeah I was going damn this material
nipple tissue is very elastic and very
tough yeah and when you're trying to
pierce through it
you hear and feel a bunch of things that
are very disconcerting
crunchy one way to put it crunching and
popping
as the needle's going through there and
then you got to put in you got to put
the bar in behind it and push the needle
out and she's just [__]
losing her [__] [__] laying down just
bear with it and I'm having like empathy
pains you know what I mean going [__]
man [__] well like I said the first
one you did the first one I thought I
was gonna black out yeah that's how
painful it was and I was just kind of
like oh that would be bad the second one
was worse though wouldn't it
it's hard to say yeah well the second
one was actually when you did the second
one you I thought you were done and I
was like oh that I had to do that twice
but then you had to do it again and I'm
like [__] me I was like I don't want to
do it I had the wrong diameter needle I
had to go over a bigger needle because I
couldn't get the [__] the bar in
behind that small needle every time I
try to push it you'd scream and I go
[__] I need a bigger needle so then I
[__] took another needle and pushed
that old needle out through using the
bigger needle and then I put the [__]
bar the second one I think was better
because I was laying down yeah like the
first one I was sitting up
and like I said I didn't expect this to
happen like I knew it was gonna hurt
okay like I knew that but it's just like
kind of like it's okay I'll I'll [__]
suck it up or whatever but I didn't
expect that my Consciousness was going
to start to waver and I was just got he
was doing it and I was like I'm blacking
out I'm blacking out I'm blacking out
and like I started like my Visions are
going yeah like that and I was like oh
[__] I didn't even expect that because
the pain was too much and like my body
was like shutting down and I was
thinking well if she shuts down I'll
just put the I'll just put it in what
she's done
it'll save her the [__] suffering
from it though you know so the second
one was painful but it wasn't as bad
because one I knew what to expect and
two I was laying down yeah so I was like
well even if I pass out there's nowhere
for me to go because I was worried that
it's like I was sitting up I was like
I'm gonna pass out and it's like it's
gonna tear my [__] nipple off like or
something like that well I showed him to
Bill he's like yeah you did good because
he used to do it yeah you did you did it
says yeah they're straight and they're
in deep they're not hanging out for the
[__] he says yeah you did good
[__] and I said dude I told him how
it went down he goes yeah that's how it
is
says that's not that's you know it's
because that's not that doesn't feel
good
you said yeah it's bad
it is bad yeah
but
I don't know like I'm glad I did it
though like at the time I was like why
the [__] am I even doing this holy [__]
you look good this is a stupid idea but
then like afterward I was kind of and
like he did one and then I was just kind
of like man [__] me it's like I really
don't want to do the other one because
the first one was saying I see girls
with one right and we and we're like oh
I get it yeah I know what happened there
you were just like [__] this I'm not
doing it again like I get it I get it
because I didn't want to do the second
one either because we waited like a
couple hours like a ride a passage like
in between it's like a native but yeah
like once once it was done I was just
kind of like
yeah I would it was yeah it was like
like a rate of Passage kind of
um murder Hornet said sounds gay now but
in the 90s I have my belly button
pierced
Tammy said I took my daughter to get her
tongue pierced and it bothered me more
than her because the sound of it was so
nasty yeah I can imagine I can imagine
yeah
I think
ah I'm trying to think of like the
tongue would be worse than the nipples
yeah I mean I'm sure the tongue doesn't
feel good either bad also because
tongue's pretty sensitive my tongue is
pretty sensitive to you so it's just
kind of like
because I can't even eat like hot
[__] food anymore without it there
was I've seen some [__] piercings
that dudes have done that I was just
like dude you're [__] crazy
one of them was a dude that was a
professional peer series piercing other
people for a living and he did one to
himself
through the septum
using a [__] needle
that was of almost an inch in diameter
where there's just a sharp blade really
with a [__] you know what I'm talking
about and he pushed that man I was just
like and he said it he said it nearly he
passed out nearly doing that [__]
pushing that thing through except it was
already big yeah not a little one a big
one right through there to get so he
could big get a big thing in his nose
yeah because normally that's not the way
you do it you start out smaller and then
you stretch it out like bigger and like
bigger gauges you said it was the
hardest one it was like it was like
notoriously hard to do that piercing to
survive it but he's just some kind of
pain freak you know yeah you'd have to
be it was decided even funny pork a size
of a cork out of a [__] wine bottle
and it was and and it was the needle was
looked like about I don't know
one-third or maybe a half inch in
diameter and it was a round needle it
was a sharp end on it it looked like a
plug more than a needle he put that
thing through it which would have would
have been like a putting a cookie cutter
through you yeah because it was hot you
know
oh I totally probably would have passed
out yeah like I did myself I didn't pass
out when you did the [__] but I almost
passed out like the like my yeah you
know how you know how your vision when
you pass out like the black goes yeah it
was like that and it was like right
there then I was like don't don't pass
out don't pass out don't pass out
because I was I didn't want to fall
backward
and like because you're because you know
you had it in the clamp yeah and I was
just kind of like man I can't fall
backwards so I was really trying to like
keep my [__] together but um
but yeah I could see it because it was
really really painful so I can't even
imagine
putting that [__] through your own yeah
yeah he said it [__] him up his friend
was watching and the shop hadn't been
open it wasn't open yet they were they
did it in the piercing shop before
opening time
yeah he did it to himself his friend was
watching the other guy was working with
him
to see if anything went wrong
well yeah I mean he's poking something
that big through your body he didn't
have a video of it he just shut he just
said it right he said it was the worst
of all times I mean yeah I can imagine
yeah I mean even thinking about even
thinking about you doing the nipple
piercing I still can't believe that we
did that [__]
because even now we're gonna think about
it I'm like
even though I'm used to it now and it's
just kind of like it it's fine well you
just wanted it you didn't know what it
was gonna feel like well I mean actually
I knew it was going to be bad I said I
know this is gonna hurt
like I P like you know I pierce my own
ears and [__] like that so it's not like
and like I said I have a high pain
tolerance but I was like this is gonna
be bad I know it but it's always like
worse than you think it's gonna be there
I saw tutorials I saw I saw how to do it
you know I'd put a lot of needles
through myself just injecting stuff and
I was just like I can do that oh it'll
be like that it'd be like that no no
it's a bigger gauge needle and it's
going through a much harder material and
it's good yeah I mean like injecting
yourself with you know with steroids and
stuff like that I mean that's a tiny
needle and you just go kachok and like
just because he injects me with [__] all
the time like in my arms and stuff so
it's just kind of like that's nothing I
don't even feel it
but this with this needle was
big like he showed it to me and for a
second I was like
I was like I don't know if I want to do
this now I was like that needle is
[__] enormous
it was so big but um but yeah it's but
it's done now and it does look good and
I'm actually glad we did it even though
show them one
I can't do that I don't care I've
already got this [__] demand you already
got me like copyrights right you know
that almost every one of our videos gets
demonetized now almost all of them just
because of the [__] we talk about it
okay yeah the the uh the topics
yeah
um yeah murder one is talking about his
belly ring his belly button I could
still put a ring through it
I remember when that was very big I
remember that if it gets demonetized
that means they pull commercials yeah
they just don't shake them good then
[__] their commercials
good I hate commercials how many of them
actually get to monetized half
well I don't know if it's that many I
mean pretty much like all anytime you
talk about like True Crime [__] if
you're talking about like sexual assault
if you're talking about anything like
that this is Evan's already said LOL
y'all are so y'all are too cute
[Laughter]
I mean you know
that was a great we're insane I think I
sometimes think I think compared to the
average person yeah probably I mean I
guess we don't really think about it
because we're just kind of like used to
being the way we are but it's like this
way but it's like sometimes like when
I'm around normal people which I try to
avoid I'm just kind of like holy [__] we
might be
crazy
no I don't think I don't think we are
the Rockers I don't feel crazy no we
will go to Ichiban and look at the
people at Ichiban
and we'll go to the [__] dead mall
that is across the street from Ichiban
to go watch a movie and look at people
going no we're not crazy
I mean but those people would think that
we were but if we're looking at them or
not though I don't think I don't think
we're crazy and the girls that were the
girls that [__] make the coffee
drinks for us [__] love us
they won't they don't want to stop
talking to us
we've got it's weird because we've got
almost kind of be regulars at the
Books-A-Million coffee shops because
it's across the street from the Ichiban
and we always go over there go get a
clock like to look at books and like go
look at and the and the girl that works
there like makes a cool like different
flavor every week and she knows that we
always want to try the flavor because as
soon as we come in she's like oh we got
this today oh that sounds good give me
one of them yeah you know what I mean
yeah shovel Brew cold brew coffee yeah
and it's it's not sweet like uh
Starbucks coffee is [__] bitter but
it's good it's got good flavor that's
what I mean it's peanut butter coffee
yeah she made a peanut butter cup one
peanut butter cup she made a raspberry
danish one yeah Cinnamon Toast Crunch
yeah the one she made La the one she
made last week was actually really good
too it was s'mores I think
so it was like it was very very
chocolate forward and had like like a
marshmallow and it's not sweet it's not
like drinking well that's what I like
about it it's like oh yeah I'm not
saying that I don't like those Starbucks
like super sweet like coffee milkshake
things that they do because those are
good but
I mean if I'm gonna get a coffee drink I
want something that actually kind of
tastes like coffee you know what I mean
it's like kind of coffee what's the name
of that coffee shop Joe mugs good job
Joe mugs that's the one that's in books
a million two books a million I mean
Barnes and Noble has Starbucks you're
right and books a million has Joe mugs
that's how that works
but yeah they're kind of like Joe bugs
better well yeah their cold brew is is
good I've honestly I mean to be fair I
haven't I don't go to Starbucks a lot
anymore like you go I go yeah because
there's one that I don't drink coffee
there yeah I usually get the real fruit
stuff like the summer stuff yeah
I do like their their
um like Frappuccinos and stuff but
usually if I get a frappuccino I'll get
one that's like just like a coffee
flavor like just espresso or the
espresso with like the chips in it I
don't get like one of these vanilla and
all that kind of [__] because that's
like I said you might as well just get a
milkshake I want a coffee drink you know
yeah
uh Zach says I think the worst pain I
ever had was the high I had when I gave
myself ethanol poisoning from using one
of those long barbecue lighters on a
bong
the poison yeah
holy [__]
smoking a bomb with ethanol
Mrs Evans said Tom did trauma bonding
with you in your nips yeah that was a
whole that was a whole experience it did
I feel like it did bring us closer
together though I guess so yeah because
you were kind of like
um
I don't think you'd ever seen me in that
much pain before I was I was getting and
you were and you were doing it yeah so
you were kind of like getting all [__]
up about it yeah but I didn't want to
[__] I didn't want to um
upset you right oh I was plenty upset
already so I was just trying to remain
calm you know what I mean it's gonna be
okay okay but he told me afterward that
he was just I was freaking out holy [__]
he's like I was freaking out so bad God
damn this much [__] oh my God
I'm putting that big needle through
there here go crack
pop
going through that [__] nipple I
thought it was gonna be like smooth as
butter going through there nope no not
how that [__] went it's not like it's
not like going through meat or skin or
fat
no
it's like going through rubber yeah well
like I said baby's gotta [__] chew on
that for years and years yeah it's got
to be tough Yeah It's just tough as [__]
[__] popping and cracking
and she felt every bit of it sounded
felt it sounded like oh I did yeah every
little tiny millimeter had it been
muscle it would have
it would have been a lot easier
because all you got to do is get down in
between underneath the skin and once you
pass to the skin they can't feel
anything I can't
but that nipple I guess it has Sensei it
has sensors well you told me like when I
got the implants yeah
um
when I woke up like I said I was still
on the anesthesia
when I woke up I did have a sensation
that it hurt like it did really feel
like a huge weight like on my chest and
I was like oh [__] like it
really hurt but then like you took me
home I slept you gave me a sandwich I
slept for six hours and I woke up and I
was pretty much fine yeah I'd never seen
that like it like it hurt a little bit
but I was like meh it's all right it's
negligible like I drove a car the next
day which they told me I probably would
not be able to do my first wife got
implants and I think they're probably
about the same size as those she was
skinny like olive oil though
and man she was laid up for four or five
days I had to nurse her and keep her
doped up
next day she's like nothing I'm gonna
work bye yeah she had to work I was like
God damn and I didn't take any more
painkillers out there yeah I don't want
you those it's like no that's all right
she's like it doesn't hurt
it didn't yeah it hurt when I woke up I
think the difference was is that
Tiff basically was flat chested yeah she
went from that to like a very large D
all right if not [__] maybe like e
cup there's a lot of stretching there's
a lot of stretching you were already big
yeah you already had d
cup
probably it's just I would say probably
about D it's just you know what I mean
you lost weight so you just filled them
up right you know yeah so it's not like
this is kind of like stretch out right
like it wasn't quite soon I mean they
still did cut I mean because I had them
put underneath the muscle so they did
actually cut yeah the muscle and then
they had to like you know sew it back up
and all that other kind of [__] but
it hurt when I woke up but really after
I slept for a few hours and woke up
it was it kind of hurt but it was just
kind of like you know how like sometimes
when you work out too hard and you're
just like oh man like it was like that
yeah and you're just like ah and you
just kind of shake it off it was just it
was like that yeah the difference was is
that you had big boobs
yeah that's probably what it was and and
Tifton she didn't have boobs at all she
was just a rib cage and [__] nipples
and then went to [__] heat large D
because yeah you had to like right
there's a lot of stretching going she
didn't I just had to keep her doped up
she was just unconscious five days later
she got him she goes let me see him and
she [__] looked in the mirror and
goes God
then she put a shirt on she goes these
look fantastic and then she went back
and slept for another two days
yeah although I remember that like they
look really weird for like the first few
days they're too high like they're too
high and they're kind of square yeah
because they haven't like settled in
yeah yeah so it's like really really
weird looking hers were all like that
yeah they're like way you're like I was
like they're not gonna stay like that
right because that looks really [__]
up
I was like they're square and they're
yeah like under my chin yeah I was like
you put a bread box under her Channel it
does that's what it looks like at first
they don't like nobody ever thinks about
that like they see like these hot chicks
with [__] yeah and when she when she
finally came out of that [__] though
[__] eventually she's like trying on
all her clothes because I'm so glad I
did this God
because she did she looked good
Zach says oh no wait I remember to
repress memory worst pain I ever had was
when I had a dry socket when I had my
wisdom teeth out oh [__] yeah I you know
what I never did have my wisdom teeth
out I still got them
um I have a tooth in the very back
that's broken but that just kind of
happened over time yeah one of the other
worst pains that I had was when I was
probably like 11 or 12 and I used to get
constant [__] ear infections all the
time I had [__] ear infections and I
went to the doctor and they were trying
to get a sample from like way inside
like my inner ear or whatever and he
takes this big long thing
like a big long metal thing and he stuck
it in my ear
and it felt like
it went all the way through my [__]
head like all the way in my brain or
some [__] and that was like my mom was
with me and she said you didn't yell or
make any noise or anything like that but
she said your face just went white
like she said she said I saw the color
drain from your face like because of how
painful that was but but it's just like
like I couldn't believe it like I
couldn't believe how much that [__]
hurt like this thing going all the way
in my mind there's dude dudes in the
[__] tool those [__] from the
toolbox Murders it took that damn ice
pick and shoved it through that girl's
ear and then went through the outside
and killed imagine what those girls went
through man that's what I mean it's just
like even Stick it and this wasn't even
like it was pretty thin but they were
trying to get like samples like I said
for my inner ear to see what the hell
was wrong with it but when they stuck it
in there you had the perception that it
was going like all the way through your
head and it felt like that like you
could feel it like it was all like going
all the way through your head and it
felt like really really [__] up and
like I said I didn't
I felt like I wanted to scream or
something like that but I just couldn't
I was like flabbergasted and Frozen like
how [__] painful it was
murder harness laid up right now they
just did uh operation on his foot yeah
that's what he was saying I don't know
if he's still in the hospital right now
are you in the hospital he said he was
walking to get some booze okay so he's
at home yeah he's at home now
yeah you're gonna get some booze
you said your foot was bleeding he's
bitching about his [__] foot now he's
gonna go there and get some booze okay
go ahead good drink it up Mrs Evans
already party said I got free Dolly
Parton moves right after the first birth
hubs was like Hey I was like hell no it
hurt
oh you guys got some implants is that
what she's saying yeah yeah it's like
getting an internal bra
yeah although the thing about it like I
guess because like you said I had had
big boobs before and then I lost a bunch
of weight yeah and then I had them put
in and so like so I was kind of like
just filling them back up because I lost
so much weight so mine are like a lot
more natural I don't think a lot of
people know and people don't know that
she had that they're not yeah I think I
might have some suitable photos
to show that are not new because they
look actually they actually look pretty
natural yeah you can see Jen's boobs not
nipples but I'll show you the boobs are
you really Tom yeah I got photographs of
you that are um
suitable that
will show
murder Hornet said Tom I sent you some
Trend LOL he did not send me that
we were having a big discussion about
that the other day yeah I was like yeah
you need more of that [__]
War
I mean if you do I'm gonna like [__]
tie you up and stick in the closet yeah
[Laughter]
Zach says okay so if one of the implants
pops do you fly around the room like a
deflating balloon in the cartoon
no
they put them underneath the muscle and
then the and then it builds scar tissue
around it so even if it did deflate like
it would um even if it did pop
um you would still have the scar tissue
there so it would look a little bit
deflated but that's about it
okay yeah Mrs Evans already party so Tom
trying to make YouTube into streaming
yeah pretty much
that's Jam
that's my white wig
my white wig
and my fake lashes
yeah they came out nice
it came out nice
but like I said they don't actually but
that was one of the things that I liked
about him because I really didn't want
because you know how sometimes like
chicks will get like
implants and it looks like they just
kind of stuck two hockey pucks on their
chest yeah that's that's like that's
like the porn star round ones yeah I was
like I don't I don't want that actually
you could have gotten those neighbor
looked good because you had enough meat
to go over the top of them it's just
that they look real they look very
artificial on a very thin woman that
didn't have big boobs to begin with
like my ex-wife she looked like that
yeah she had porn boobs yeah because she
just didn't have any meat you know right
but it's just a different look
you know
I'm just saying like personally I didn't
like that it's like I didn't really want
I said I wanted him to look more natural
I don't really want so I got them the
teardrop shaped ones I didn't get round
ones
um Tammy says if Tom takes Trend have
somebody kidnap him
there we go bringing it back around
that's what I'll do I'll have somebody
kidnap you
Mrs Evans already party said beautiful
Jenny thank you
yeah those came out pretty good
those pictures came out pretty good
I got that white wig you you told me to
get that white wig that way it looks
good yeah yeah trying to see if I got
any videos that could actually
work I think this one
will not
wait a minute what are we looking at
they will not be able to tell no if I go
here no no no no no no no no no no no no
no
yeah
okay you could tell what are yeah
you're drunk
go home you're drunk oh you're all ready
[Laughter]
yeah it's very obvious Tom let's not do
that let's not do that
Zach said y'all I can't sleep but why
don't you tell me until tell a bedtime
story
[Laughter]
bedtime well here's here's a cute well
wait a minute let me see you first you
can see it okay here's a cute one can I
see it first yeah
that's my Wednesday Adams yeah yeah
look I look like someone's teacher yeah
I'm gonna hit him with a paddle it's
just your goth mom yeah yeah
if you don't spell [__] right
okay this is what
oh there's my blue wig it's my favorite
that I have on right now
don't get too excited don't get too
excited it might come up with something
that I was gonna say there's something
yeah yeah yeah
I remember that shoot
I didn't have my blue contacts and also
yeah
these get a lot spicier
see time gets drunken he is I love that
[__]
and you can't tell him This Is My Jam
this is Jen I know I'm sure I'm sure
well you know I think everybody knows
right yep
I'm just mostly me all the time man I
only got a 14 energy in this [__]
14 better
that's what you get for all those
shenanigans
killing your battery
Zach says how do you stay balanced with
those things they're like aren't they
heavy they are heavy but it's like I
don't really
I don't know
I guess I'm just kind of used to it
I guess
they're just there it's not really like
you know
and like I said I had them before so
it's just kind of always had them so
it's just kind of like
yeah they're heavy and yeah it's a pain
in the ass but yeah you don't really the
boobs but you don't really think about
it because it's like well it's just like
a part of your body
I always just kind of Wonder it's like
oh isn't it weird that like dudes just
have that thing like hanging between
their legs all the time that must be a
real pain because I don't have that but
dudes don't think about that because
it's like
you're just used to it you know what I
mean damn Jeff what I think you're funny
why am I funny
I mean you don't think about well you
probably think about yourself you
probably think about your dick all the
time
but not everybody does
it's just like you don't you don't
really like think of your arm or nothing
like that it's just kind of like that
you know what I mean look yeah it's
almost midnight I know we gotta we gotta
shut it down all right you guys got an
extra long show this week this Wednesday
yeah and it's like even um because we
we're penalizing you one show
we got rid of we got rid of of honey for
now but we're gonna put something else
there eventually probably yeah we'll see
we'll see how it goes yeah
this is Evan said it's Tom embarrassed
you do think about your dick all the
time though
what makes you think I think of him I
did it we are talking about it I don't
think about it
well like I said then it's the same
thing you don't really like think about
your book I think they're like I think a
lot of times like maybe straight dudes
think that chicks are thinking about
their boobs all the time the same way
that straight dudes are thinking about
their boobs and they're really not
they're really not it's just another
part of your body like your [__]
elbow or something
you know I mean they just kind of happen
to be there on the front so uh all right
yeah so we've been on a very long time
so we should probably I'm gonna have an
oatmeal cookie and I'm gonna go to bed
yeah
so yeah uh we'll be back on Friday night
for the side track show which this kind
of was too but you know what I mean at
least that will be more legitimately
like a sidetrack
we'll probably talk about some of the
same [__] so yeah hopefully you guys can
join us for that thank you for dropping
by this evening thank you for all the
super chats and we will see you guys
again on Friday night